ITEMS ON THE AGENDA- IT'S ME
AND ONE OTHER MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT'S HERE. I WANT.
I WAS SPENT MISTER SAY OUR TERM
FOR BEING HERE ON TIME AND
READY TO GO. WE NOW HAVE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALEX LEE IS NOW
HERE. SO WHAT I'M AND MEET
NUMBER BEGIN AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
ON THE START WITH THE
HOUSEKEEPING. THINGS THAT WE
NEED TO DO AND WE WON'T BE OPEN
TILL WE HAVE. A POOR. AND SO I
WILL START. WITH THE OUR CODES
ARE COVERT PROCEDURES. SO
WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY
HEARING. DUE TO CONTINUE STAY
AT HOME ORDER WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING SO WE'RE ONLY
ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WATCH AND PARTICIPATE
IN THE HEARINGS IN PERSON.
WE'RE ALSO REQUIRED REQUIRING
THAT MASK THE WARRING AND
PHYSICAL DISTANCE TO BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING WHETHER
HERE IN ROME ALL RIGHT A VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE IF YOU DO NOT
HAVE A MASK WE CAN PROVIDE ONE
FOR YOU. WE HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR WITNESS
TESTIMONY TODAY. FOR THE PUBLIC
IN A ROOM. THAT MEANS TODAY IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- TO A CAPITAL WE
CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE A MINIMAL
CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND A
LIMITED NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC
AND MEDIA SO WE CAN MAINTAIN
SIX FEET SPACING. THEY'RE ALSO
STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL OF
THOSE HERE IN THE ROOM. WITH
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A
BILL PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND. I
WILL LAST YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. I WOULD ASK THAT THE
PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE.
YOU CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM
ONCE YOUR ARE DONE TESTIFYING
OR RETURN TO YOUR SEAT. PLEASE
BE SURE TO OBSERVE PHYSICAL
DISTANCE ST UPON LEAVING THE
CAPITAL. INCLUDING LIMITING
ELEVATOR USE TO ONE PERSON AT A
TIME. FOR B. FOR W. B. R.
WITNESSES IN ADDITION. TO BEING
ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE
HEARING ROOM WE HAVE SOME BILL
WITNESSES MAKING USE OF OUR
WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCING
ROOMS B. WBR ROOMS WHICH ARE
LOCATED HERE IN THE CAPITAL.
THE CORRESPONDING ROOM FAR
HEARING IS ROOM ONE TWO SEVEN
DOES ONE TWENTY SEVEN. THOSE
WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON THE
SCREEN SO MEMBERS CAN WATCH
THEIR TESTIMONY LIVE FROM
OUTSIDE OF THE HEARING ROOM AND
ALSO ASK THEM QUESTIONS. FOR DO
WITNESSES WE WILL ALSO BE USING
A MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
TO WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY ON THE BILL THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS.
877-692-8957 AGAIN THAT'S.
877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ARE YOU READY ONE THREE
ONE. FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO
AGAIN THAT'S. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY WEB
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON
YOUR TV SCREEN IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO
AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOUR
TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING
THEY'RE BUILT PRESENTATION. THE
OPERATOR ONLINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO PLACE IN
Q. BASED ON WHETHER YOU SUPPORT
OR OPPOSE THE BILL IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE. THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCAST AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION. PLEASE ALSO BE
ADVISED THAT IF YOU ARE A MAN
IF YOU'RE A MAIN WITNESS
PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR OR
AGAINST THE BILL YOU REMAIN ON
A LIFELINE IT WILL NEED TO MEET
YOURSELF UNTIL YOU ARE CALLED
ON TO SPEAK. IF YOU'RE HAVING
ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATE
A PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL
THE COMMITTEE AT AREA CODE.
916-319-3744 AGAIN THAT'S AREA
CODE. 916-319-3744 AND MY STAFF
WILL BE THERE TO HELP YOU. I
ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO
THE- ADDITION LETTER PORTAL ON
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE. I THANK
YOU FOR BEARING WITH US AS WE
IMPLEMENT METHODS TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL
FACE. OKAY WE HAVE FOUR MEMBERS
NEED ONE MORE FOR QUORUM. SO.
SO I WILL GO TO THE OFF
CALENDAR. SO THE OFF CALENDAR
ARE THE FOLLOWING BILLS THAT
HAVE BEEN PULLED. ITEM NUMBER
SIXTEEN MATHIS A. SIX FIVE NINE
DUMPING PULLED BY THE AUTHOR. I
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT JONES SAWYER
AB EIGHTY NINE PULLBACK
COMMITTEE. AND I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO STATE I WOULD LIKE TO
PULL ITEM NUMBER EIGHT A. B.
pTHE ORDER BUSINESS FOR TODAY'S
COMMITTEE HEARING. MY CATS IN
DOING SO IS TO PREVENT ALSO IS
TO INVITE MY PREVENT INVITE ALL
STAKEHOLDERS TO REACH OUT TO MY
OFFICE TO WORK WITH ME ON THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE WHICH WILL
PROFESSIONALISE COOLEY SEEM AN
ADDRESS THE ROOT CAUSES OF
EXCESSIVE FORCE BY INCREASING
PEACE OFFICERS EDUCATION AT AGE
CONDITIONS FOR EMPLOYMENT. BY
OPENING UP CONVERSATIONS FOR
ADDITIONAL COUPLE OF WEEKS I
LOOK FORWARD TO LISTENING TO
ALL PARTIES AND I REPEAT. ALL
POWER PARTIES HOWEVER. IN ORDER
TO ATTRACT MEANINGFUL POLICY WE
MUST RELY ON IN ACCEPTED DATA
THAT WE HAVE OR THAT YOU BRING
TO THIS COMMITTEE. THE CLAIM
THAT INDIVIDUALS ARE COLOR
CANNOT MEET EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS SO FAR IT'S BEEN
STE PREVENT UNJUSTIFIABLE
ASSUMPTION AND FRANKLY AS AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN MALE FINE
TOTALLY OFFENSIVE. INSINUATIONS
FROM PARTICULAR STAKEHOLDERS TO
RECRUITMENT OF BLACK AND BROWN
INDIVIDUALS IS HAMPERED BY
HIGHER EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS
NOT ONLY MISSES THE MARK ON WHY
THOSE INDIVIDUALS DO NOT WANT
TO BE. PULLED POLICE OFFICERS
AT THIS TME BUT IS ALSO LAZY
AND DOES NOT CHANGE HOW AND
WHERE TO RECRUIT. MY OFFICE
EVEN MY OFFICE EVEN HAS THE
DATA TO SHOW IT IS FACTUALLY
ACCURATE TO ASSERT HIGHER
EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS HAMPERED
RECRUITMENT OF PEOPLE OF COLOR.
IF AND WHEN WE INCREASE
EDUCATION AND AGE REQUIREMENTS
ARE INTENTIONAL ABOUT WHO WE
HIRE 
RECRUITS OF COLOR. BY HAVING
CONVERSATIONS OVER THE COURSE
OF THE NEXT COUPLE OF WEEKS I
AM OPEN TO LIST NAME AND
WORKING TOGETHER. BUT I WILL
NOT BE RECEPTIVE A MISGUIDED
ASSERTION THAT MERELY A SUMP
GIVE AND NOT DATABASE. WE HAVE
TO ACCEPT THE DATA AND ACCEPT
THE PREMISE THAT COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ARE
BETTER. WHEN OFFICERS ARE MORE
MATURE AND BETTER EDUCATED.
BETTER EDUCATED SIGNIFICANTLY.
HAVING A MORE MATURE AND BETTER
EDUCATED POLICE FORCE WHEN
SHORT COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WILL
NO LONGER LIVE IN TERROR. THE
MOST IMPORTANT WHEN IT COMES TO
MAKING THE CHANGES THAT WE
EFFECTIVELY NEED WE NEED TO
START FROM THE BEGINNING. AND
START BRINGING IN INDIVIDUALS.
WHO UNDERSTAND WHAT IT'S LIKE
TO RECRUIT A PERSON OF COLOR.
QUITE FRANKLY SENDING SOMEBODY
DOES NOT FROM THE COMMUNITY
THAT DOESN'T UNDERSTAND A
COMMUNITY CHALLENGES AND THEN
TELL THEM. THAT THEY REPRESENT
THE COMMUNITY AND THESE ARE THE
BEST WAYS THAT THEY NEED TO BE
AN OFFICER WHEN IN FACT THE
COMMUNITY HAS ASKED FOR
CHANGES. THAT IS THE WAY WE
NEED TO MOVE FORWARD SO WE CAN
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS. I REPEAT
INDIVIDUALS NO MATTER WHAT
COLOR THEY ARE. WHO ARE
RECEPTIVE TO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES A RECEPTIVE TO
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND THEY'RE
RECEPTIVE TO THE NEW WAY OF
POLICING. IF ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS ARE SERIOUS ABOUT
HAVING THIS CONVERSATION PLEASE
REACH OUT TO MY OFFICE AND
LET'S WORK TOGETHER. OVER THE
WEEKEND IT WAS EAST EASTER I'VE
TRIED TO WORK WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN FACT I'VE SHAKEN
HANDS WITH CORRECT I'VE GONE ON
TRIPS WITH CCPO WAY. TO TALK
ABOUT HOW WE CAN CHANGE THE
SYSTEM I'VE SHAKING THEIR HEADS
LOOKED MANY I NAY TOLD ME THEY
WANTED TO MAKE CHANGES IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AND THEY
IMMEDIATELY TURNED AROUND A
SAID THEY WANT TO GO BACK TO
THE OLD WAY OF DOING THINGS.
THAT IS NOT. WHAT I'M LOOKING
FOR. I'M LOOKING FOR HONEST
BROKERS. I'M WILLING TO TURN
THE OTHER CHEEK. I'M WILLING TO
SIT FORGET ALL THAT'S HAPPENED
IN THE PAST IN FACT. I KNOW
BECAUSE OF THIS EASTER AND MY
PRAYERS WHEN YOU LOOK AT A G.
IS ON ACROSS WHEN HE SAYS
FATHER FORGIVE THEM THEY KNOW
NOT WHAT THEY DO LIVE TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR. I BELIEVE IF
YOU WITH WE TALK AND YOU
UNDERSTAND FULLY WHAT'S GOING
ON ANY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. YOU'LL BE ABLE.
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO MAKE THE
RIGHT CHANGES AND WORK WITH ME
TO MAKE THOSE. SO THAT'S WHY
I'M PULLING IT TODAY AND NO
OTHER REASON. THANK YOU. I
THINK WE CAPRICORN. THE GROUP
TO GROW JONES SAWYER HERE
BLACKIE HERE TO OUR QUE HAN.
WORK YEAH SANTIAGO THEY ARE
TELL HER WICKS LEE HERE PRESENT
QUORUM IS PRESENT WE NOW TO
PROPOSED CONSENT CALENDAR ITEM
NUMBER FOUR A. B. NINE ZERO
ZERO SEVEN CARILLO FORCE
INVOLUNTARY STERILIZATION
COMPENSATION PROGRAM ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN AB SIX SIX SEVEN
IRWIN FIREARMS ARE FARMS ARE.
PROHIBITION PERSON SYSTEM ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN AB NINE NINE
EIGHT INCARCERATED PERSONS
HEALTH RECORDS A. B. I DON'T
KNOW FOURTEEN AB EIGHT NINE
EIGHT LEI COLONEL RECORDS
AUTOMATIC CONVICTION RECORD
RELIEF ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN AB
SIX OH THREE MCCARTY LAW
ENFORCEMENT SETTLEMENTS IN
JUDGMENT REPORTING I REMEMBER
NINETEEN SIX SEVEN THREE SALAS
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY ONE AB SIX FIVE THREE.
MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENT
GRANT PROGRAM. THANK THE MOTION
SECOND CALL THE ROLL. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR JONES SAWYER
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY LACKEY
I BARRICADE HAND BACK HE HAD
AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE
SANTIAGO C. R. TWO C. R. TWO HI
WICKS LEE LEE I. CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED- WE'RE
GOING TO GO OUT OF ORDER WITH
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB ONE TWO
TWO THREE MISTER LEVINE
FIREARMS AND AMMUNITION EXCISE
TAX MR LEVINE THE CHAIR HAS.
GIVING YOU AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT FIRST FRAZIER. MEMBERS
I'M GRATEFUL FOR- YOUR
DISCRETION ON THAT AB TWELVE
TWENTY THREE IMPOSES A TWENTY
FIVE DOLLAR EXCISE TAX ON A
RETAILER FOR THE SALE OF
FIREARMS IN AN EXCISE TAX ON
RETAILERS FOR THE SALE OF
AMMUNITION WITH REVENUES USED
TO PROVIDE ONGOING FUNDING TO
REDUCE GUN VIOLENCE IN OUR
STATE. TO THE HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL
CALVET PROGRAM MEMBERS
ACCORDING TO THE GUN VIOLENCE
ARCHIVE IN THE FIRST FOUR
MONTHS OF TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
ONE ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE
AMERICANS HAVE BEEN KILLED DUE
TO GUN VIOLENCE IN JUST THE
MONTH OF MARCH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE SIXTY SIX AMERICANS WERE
KILLED BY GUN VIOLENCE
INCLUDING EIGHT. A SMALL
BUSINESS IN GEORGIA TEN HAD A
GROCERY STORE IN COLORADO AND
FOUR KILLED ON MARCH THIRTY
FIRST AT AN OFFICE COMPLEX IN
ORANGE CALIFORNIA INCLUDING A
CHILD. MEMBERS THESE ARE NOT
STATISTICS THEY ARE HUMAN LIVES
GUN SALES IN INCIDENTS OF GUN
VIOLENCE HAVE INCREASED
DRAMATICALLY SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THE CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC IN TWENTY TWENTY A
HUNDRED TEN THOUSAND FIREARMS
WERE SOLD IN CALIFORNIA THAT
SAME YEAR. ALSO SAW 46%
INCREASE IN GUN HOMICIDES IN
JANUARY OF THIS YEAR WE SAW THE
DEADLIEST MONTH FOR GUN
HOMICIDES SINCE TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN. MEMBERS ENOUGH IS ENOUGH
AND THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS ARE
NOT ENOUGH. BUT THE CALVET
PROGRAM IS ONE OF THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE COMMUNITY BASED
VIOLENCE INTERVENTION PROGRAMS
IN THE STATE. COMMUNITIES WHICH
RECEIVED CALVET FUNDING DURING
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN CYCLE SOFT
HOMICIDES DECREASE. BY THREE
TIMES MORE THAN THOSE THAT DID
NOT RECEIVE CALVET SUPPORT IN
TWENTY NINETEEN THESE PROGRAMS
HELP CALIFORNIA REDUCE GUN
HOMICIDE AMONG THE HIGH RISK
AGE GROUP OF FIFTEEN TO TWENTY
NINE YEARS OLD. TO THE LOWEST
RATE SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY.
GUN VIOLENCE WILL NOT END ON
ITS OWN. WE MUST TAKE
RESPONSIBLE ACTION TO END THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS THAT IS
GUN VIOLENCE IN OUR STATE IN IN
OUR NATION. AS WE SEE MORE AND
MORE INCIDENTS OF GUN VIOLENCE
WE MUST BE REMINDED THAT WE ARE
NEITHER HELPLESS NOR HOPELESS
TO END THE CARNAGE AND DEATH
OCCURRING IN CALIFORNIA AND
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. AB TWELVE
TWENTY THREE WILL PROVIDE A
RELIABLE FUNDING SOURCE FOR THE
CALVET PROGRAM. NEEDED TO MAKE
CRITICAL INVESTMENTS THAT RULES
WILL REDUCE GUN RELATED
VIOLENCE IN OUR COMMUNITIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU DO
YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES WE DO
HAVE TWO WITNESSES ON THE PHONE
WE HAVE CRYSTAL UP TO AUTO FROM
MOMS DEMAND ACTION FOR GUN
SENSE IN AMERICA AND FERNANDO
RINCON- URBAN PEACE INSTITUTE.
AND CAN WE HEAR FROM EIGHTEEN
T. CAN YOU BRING IN THE
WITNESSES. THE LINES ARE OPEN
MEDICARE JERRY WHOEVER WANTS TO
START FIRST GO AHEAD. DANRY I
THEN READ A CRYSTAL. WHAT ARE
FERNANDO. YES HI GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS-
MY NAME IS BUT NOT A WHOLE AND
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE URBAN PEACE INSTITUTE AND A
MEMBER OF THE L. A.
INTERVENTION COALITION IN LOS
ANGELES. GIVEN OUR REALITY WE
KNOW NOW MORE THAN EVER THE GUN
VIOLENCE THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY ISSUE. AND A BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITIES IT'S A
CRISIS. WE'RE SEEING CERTAIN
VIOLENCE ACROSS CALIFORNIA-
DURING THE PANDEMIC CALIFORNIA
SUFFERED A 46% INCREASE IN GUN
HOMICIDES. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STATED IN JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE CALIFORNIA WAS DEALT WITH
THE WAS A CALIFORNIA SINGLE
MOST DEADLIEST MONTH FOR GOING
HOME IT WAS ONE OF CALIFORNIA
SINGLE MOST DEADLIEST MONTH FOR
GUN HOMICIDES. SINCE TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN. EXAMPLE IN LA
WE EXPANSION OVER 6100%
INCREASE IN SHOOTINGS IN SOUTH
LA AND JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE OF ALL. CALVET FUNDING HAS
BEEN CRITICAL TO ENSURING
COMMUNITY SAFETY AND CITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. BONTA
INTERVENTION PROGRAMS FUNDED BY
CALVET IN CITIES SUCH AS LOS
ANGELES OAKLAND STOPPED IN
SACRAMENTO HAVE BEEN EVALUATED
AND HAVE DEMONSTRATED
SIGNIFICAN EFFECTIVENESS OF
SAVING LIVES. THIS WORK EXPANDS
THE STATE'S UNDERSTANDING OF
PUBLIC SAFETY BY INVESTING A
COMMUNITY BASED SOLUTIONS. FOR
EXAMPLE FOR A JOINT USC UCLA
EVALUATION OF OUR PREVENTION
EFFORTS AND LOS ANGELES. BONTA
INTERVENTION WORKERS HAVE
DECREASED RETALIATORY VIOLENCE
BY 41% OVER TWO YEAR PERIOD IN
SOUTH DELHI. THESE PROGRAMS NOT
ONLY SAVE LIVES BUT SAVE
IMMEASURABLE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH COMMUNITY TRAUMA AND
WASTEFUL CRIMINAL JUSTICE COSTS.
WE NEED SUSTAINABLE FUNDING TO
SUPPORT GUN VIOLENCE PREVENTION
EFFORTS WE SUPPORT WE SUPPORT
THE FIREARMS INDUSTRY TAX NOT
TO PUNISH GUN BUYERS OR
SELLERS. BUT TO GENERATE
SUSTAINABLE REVENUE TO ADDRESS
GUN VIOLENCE AND ACHIEVE A NEW
LEVEL OF COMMUNITY SAFETY.
THANK YOU CRITICAL. THANK YOU
ITS CRYSTALLINE. WELCOME HERE
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR NUMBER MY NAME IS
CRYSTAL OF PALATO I'M A
VOLUNTEER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF MOMS DEMAND ACTION
WHICH IS PART OF EVERYTOWN FOR
GUN SAFETY WE HAVE THOUSANDS OF
ACTIVE VOLUNTEERS SURVIVORS
INSTANTLY RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. CAN VIOLENT
COMPETITIVE ENORMOUSLY HARMFUL
IMPACTS ON CALIFORNIA FAMILIES
COMMUNITIES AND TAXPAYERS.
EKING IN SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE
TWENTY THREE TODAY AT THE
VOLUNTEER CENTER LAST
ADVOCATING FOR INCREASED
FUNDING FOR VIOLENCE
INTERVENTION AND PREVENTION
PROGRAM. PLACING A MODEST AND
REASONABLE EXPECT HACKS ON THE
FIREARM INDUSTRY TO FIND
PROGRAMS THAT YOU CAN MITIGATE
THE HARMS TOO OFTEN CAUSED BY
FIREARMS. IS A NECESSARY STEP
IN ADDRESSING THE PERSONAL
SOCIETAL AND FINANCIAL COSTS
THE CALIFORNIANS HAVE BEEN
FORTUNATE TO WORK IN THE
CURRENT DOWN BALLOT CRISIS.
CONFOUNDS REMAINS THE LEADING
CAUSE OF DEATH INJURY AND
TRAUMA FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
ESPECIALLY YOUNG PEOPLE OF
COLOR IN CALIFORNIA IT IS
UNACCEPTABLE. MEANWHILE IT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE
INDICATED WITH POWERFUL
STATISTICS CALVET GRANT
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN PROVEN TO BE
EFFECTIVE IT INTERRUPTING
CYCLES OF VIOLENCE AND
PREVENTING SHOOTING FOR THEIR
CAR. THE PROGRAM NEEDS TO
CHANGE MEANINGFUL INVESTMENT.
TO CONTINUE THEIR LIFE SAVING
MARC. ORDER EIGHTY TWELVE THREE
IT'S ONE OF HAPPENINGS PROVIDE
THE MUCH NEEDED RESTORED. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROME AND SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN THE
TELECONFERENCING ROOM. AT&T YOU
CAN OPEN UP THE LINES- FOR
TELEPHONE SUPPORT. THE CHAIR
DON'T MIND IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE TWO TWO
THREE. ONE DIDN'T ZERO AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
MY NUMBER AND PLACE IT BACK
INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWELVE TWENTY THREE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN THERE ARE NOW.
THE TERATOMA LOOK LIKE WE HAVE
ABOUT FOUR PARTICIPANT IN Q.
THEY MAY BEGIN. MY NUMBER ONE
FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE. THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS COMP ONE CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
REGISTERING BY NUMBER ONE SIXTY
SIX. THAT'S GOING TO CARRY
MEMERS THEIR NAME LONGER.
UNLIKE MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THEIR NEED A LOT OF MONEY TO
GET- FOUNDATION SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU LINE NUMBER ONE
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
REBEKAH MARKETS ON BEHALF OF
THE BRADY CAMPAIGN IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO TWO THREE ONE TWO TWO
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AT
THIS TIME IS THAT HERE WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU
WE'LL BRING YOU BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE OR ANY QUESTIONS FOR
MR LEVINE. SEEING NONE. I YOU
MAY CLOSE. I'M SORRY I'M SORRY
OPPOSITION ARE THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL I HAVE A
DAN READ FROM THE NRA AND
MICHAEL FRIEND DALY FROM
NATIONAL SHOOTING SPORTS
FOUNDATION AGAIN GENTLEMEN I
APOLOGIZE YOU YOU MAY BEGIN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. MANY FOR
THE RECORD DAN READ WESTERN
REGIONAL DIRECTOR OF THE
NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION.
WRONG OPPOSITION TO DATE YOU AB
TWELVE TWENTY THREE. AS YOU
HEARD THIS IMPOSES AN EXCISE
TAX OF TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS PER
FIREARM ON GUNTER'S AS WELL AS
AN UNSPECIFIED PERCENTAGE. ON
AMMUNITION PURCHASES THIS GOES
ON TOP OF THE EXISTING PEACE
THAT GUN OWNERS HEY CALIFORNIA
IS ONE OF THE MOST EXPENSIVE
PLACES TO BE A GUN OWNER WITH
ALL THE FEES THAT GO INTO IT IN
FACT THE FIRST TIME GUN OWNER
IS LOOKING AT SOMETHING IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD ALMOST SEVENTY
DOLLARS IN FEES FOR THEIR FIRST
PURCHASE SO- AND THAT'S NOT
EVEN INCLUDING STATE AND LOCAL
TAXES SO RIGHT NOW THERE'S AN
INTERESTING 11% FEDERAL EXCISE
TAX ALL. ARMS AND AMMUNITION
AND THEN SPECIFIC IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA YOU HAVE A THIRTY
ONE DOLLAR NINETEEN CENTRO C.
VICO STRICTLY BACKGROUND CHECKS
THAT THIS LEGISLATURE JUST
RAISED- IN THE LAST TWO YEARS
YOU HAVE A ONE DOLLAR CHOIR HE-
ACTUALLY OFF FIVE DOLLARS CT.
AND FORSMAN B. AND THEN YOU
HAVE A TWENTY FIVE DOLLAR
FIREARMS SAFETY CERTIFICATE THE
THAT'S ONLY GOOD FOR FIVE YEARS
AS WELL AS YOUR COSTS THAT ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH AMMUNITION
ELIGIBILITY CHECKS ONE DOLLAR
NINETEEN DOLLARS DEPENDING ON
WHETHER YOU'RE GETTING A
STANDARD OR BASIC ELIGIBILITY
CHECK. IN ADDITION TO STATE
LOCAL TAXES SO AT THIS BILL
INTO IN A FIRST TIME GOVERNOR
IS GOING TO BE LOOKING A CLOSE
TO A. HUNDRED DOLLARS THE THIS
IS GOING TO. RIGHT OUT MANY OF
COMMUNITY. YOU WON'T BE ABLE
TO. THEIR CALLS RIGHT BECAUSE
OF THIS ADDITIONAL COST BORNE
ON THEM- AND- I WANT TO BE
CLEAR THAT OUR OUR POSITION
HERE IS HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
THE COUNTY I. T. PROGRAM BUT-
OUR POSITION IS THAT MATTERS OF
PUBLIC SAFETY SHOULD BE OF
STATEWIDE CONCERN IN PLACE ON
THE PUBLIC AT LARGE. AND NOT-
ON PERSONS WHO ARE
DIFFERENTIATED FROM THE GENERAL
PUBLIC ONLY BECAUSE THEY ARE.
OF GUN OWNERS ARE OUT THERE
EXERCISING THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT SO WE FEEL THAT- IF THE
INTENT IS TO FIND A FUNDING
SOURCE THAT IS GREAT BUT TO PUT
IT ON GUN OWNERS. IT IS
UNCONSCIONABLE MISSENSE IN
THERE SO MANY EXISTING THE-
GUNNERS ARE STRAPPED THERE'S A
LOT OF THE THESE ARE GOING TO
MANY DOJ PROGRAMS. AS I'VE
OUTLINED THESE- ONE STRONG
OPPOSITION OF THIS AND- HOST
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MYSTERY. MISTER BEEN
BLOOD. FRIENDLY. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN NUMBERS THAT MANY FOR
THE RECORD MY NAME IS MICHAEL
FLEMING THE DIRECTOR GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS WITH THE NATIONAL
SHOOTING SPORTS FOUNDATION AND
WE STAND IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWELVE TWENTY THREE TODAY I
WANT TO ECHO A LOT OF THE
COMMENTS THE DAN BREEN MADE
EARLIER AND ADD TO- I WANT TO
BRING YOUR ATTENTION TO A
RECENT REPORT AND THIS IS IN MY
ROOM WRITTEN- TESTIMONY THAT I
PROVIDED THE COMMITTEE. IT WAS
RELEASED BY THE US DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE WHICH OUTLINES THE
ONLY TWO POINT 3% OF VIOLENT
CRIMES STATE AND FEDERAL
INVOLVED FIREARM TAPE FROM A
RETAIL STORE IN FACT CRIMINALS
OF ALL TYPES ARE LIKELY TO USE
A FIREARM PURCHASED AT A
RETAILER ONLY ONE POINT 3%
CRIME STATE AND FEDERAL
INVOLVED A FIREARM OBTAINED BY
A CRIMINAL FROM A RETAIL STORE.
WHAT THIS MEANS IS THAT LAW FOR
PERSONS WITH PASSED THE
CRIMINAL AND MENTAL HISTORY A
HISTORY BACKGROUND CHECK AND WE
HAVE UNDERGONE A MANDATORY TEN
DAY WAITING PERIOD IN
CALIFORNIA ARE NOT PROHIBITED
FROM PROTESTS ARE POSSESSING A
FIREARM AND ARE NOT THE SOURCE
THE VIOLENCE INVOLVING FIREARMS
YES THEY SHOULD NOT BE REQUIRED
TO PAY FOR PROGRAMS THAT ARE
STATUS DEAL WITH VIOLENCE NOT
ENGAGED IN BY THEM BUT
COMMITTED BY OTHERS FOR
INSTANCE CRIMINALS AND THE
MENTALLY ILL. IF THE MOTIVATION
BEHIND AB TWELVE TWENTY THREE
IS BASED ON THE THEORY THAT
BALANCE WOULD SOMEHOW BE
REDUCED TO FARMS- PRICE THREE
TAXATION ADDED THE BUDGET UP A
LARGE SEGMENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
POPULATION THAT IS DESTINED FOR
FAILURE SINCE THE INCREASED
COSTS WOULD HAVE NO EFFECT. ON
THE LEVEL OF VIOLENCE IN OUR
SOCIETY THIS IS TRUE BECAUSE
CRIMINALS WILL HAVE OTHER AND
LESS EXPENSIVE MEANS OF
ACQUIRING A FIREARM SUCH AS
THROUGH THAT THE UNDERGROUND
MARKET IN FACT 43% OF OFFENDERS
ACQUIRE FIREARMS FROM THE
UNDERGROUND. MARKET 6% OBTAINED
A FIRE THREE THESE THOSE THAT
HAVE IT USE A FIREARM VIOLENCE.
SEVEN THREE CAN. IN THE CRY.
GIVEN THAT CRIMINALS WHILE
CRIME. NOT TEAM. FARMS SMALL
FULL REPEAL SOURCE. IF SOMEONE
THIS TACK WILL EVER BE RENDERED
AGAINST CRIMES VENDORS- WE HAVE
A LOT MORE SANDERS BUT AGAIN
I'D LIKE TO ECHO DAN READ
COMMENTS AND I WERE AT THE
TIME. WE ARE IN OPPOSITION OF
TWELVE TWENTY THREE AND WOULD
STAND FOR ANY QUESTIONS THAT
THE COMMITTEE WOULD HAVE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU SIR ARE THERE-
ANY OTHER. WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION- THAT ARE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES THERE IN OPPOSITION
IN THE TELECONFERENCING ROOM
AND OUT EIGHTEEN T. WILL OPEN
UP LINES FOR ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWELVE
TWENTY THREE POINT FIVE POINT
AND ZERO. AND THE OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE IT BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWELVE TWENTY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW. A
MOMENT MEDICARE LOOKS LIKE WE
HAVE ABOUT A PARTICIPANT IN Q.
THANK YOU NAME AN ORGANIZATION
PLEASE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LINE NUMBER ONE OH
TWO THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS
IS ROY GROUP OF SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE
AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION ARE
THOUSANDS OF MEMBERS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. WE STAND IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL FOR THE
POINTS ALREADY MADE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT. MY NUMBER ONE
SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE KATHY
WENT STREPTOCOCCUS LOBBY
OUTDOORS WORKING COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA SPARKPLUG
INTERNATIONAL DOING ENTERPRISES
NEED WALL CORPORATION IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND THANK YOU
FOR GROUP IN A MALL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ONE ONE SIXTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS DAN BUT WELL IN A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE
AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION I'M IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO AB TWELVE
TWENTY THREE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WHY NUMBER ONE SIXTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
CARLENE ELLIS AND I'M A MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND
PISTOL ASSOCIATION AND THE
NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION AND
SEVERAL OTHER- GUN
ORGANIZATIONS AND I STAND IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO AB ONE TWO
TWO THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ONE ONE SIXTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS TONY ROMA'S
DALLAS OF CAPITOL RESOURCE
INSTITUTE IN STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE
NUMBER ONE FIFTY ONE THE LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RESEARCHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BILL
GAINES SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSE WITH FOR
CONSERVATION CALIFORNIA DEER
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE WORLD SHE
FOUNDATION THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
WILDLIFE FEDERATION. CALIFORNIA
BOWMAN UNDERSTAND ARCHERY
ASSOCIATION FIVE OTHER WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION ORGANIZATIONS IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO AB TWELVE
TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU SIR. I
NUMBER ONE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR THE
STOMACH DOWN ON THE CHAIR OF
THE OF SOUTH SACRAMENTO CHAPTER
CALIFORNIA MY FOLDERS TO
ASSOCIATION AND ALREADY MEMBER
IN STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
I NUMBER NINETY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON KELLY HAWKINS AT THE
CONGRESSIONAL SPORTSMEN'S
FOUNDATION STARTED IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND AT THIS TIME IF THE CHAIR
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. GREAT
THANK YOU SO. OTHER WE'VE HAD
FULL. OPPOSITION AND- SUPPORT
OF BRINGING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE NOW YES. MISS WICKS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- SMM
LEVINE THANKS FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL UP- AS SOMEONE WHO EVERY
YEAR RUNS THE BUDGET ASK FOR
HELD UP- WHO SPENDS A LOT OF
ENERGY- JUST GET LEVERAGING
EVERY RELATIONSHIP AND
GRASSROOTS ACTIVISTS AND-
ANYONE WHO'LL LISTEN TO GET-
FUNDING FOR THESE PROGRAMS
WHICH WE KNOW WORK. STATE THEY
HAVE DEMONSTRATED SUCCESS IN
ACTUALLY SUB SAVING PEOPLE'S
LIVES FROM GUN VIOLENCE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES- I APPLAUD THE
BILL- I'M A STRONG SUPPORTER OF
THE BILL TO HAVE AN ONGOING
PERMANENT FUNDING MECHANISM FOR
CAL THE PROGRAMS WOULD BE HUGE
AND- TWENTY FIVE BUCKS. SEEMS
LIKE- SOMETHING THAT COULD BE-
COULD EASILY HAVE A HUGE IMPACT
ON PEOPLE'S LIVES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA SO. OBVIOUS TO BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY AND
WOULD LOVE TO BE AT AS A CO
AUTHOR AS WELL. THANK YOU
AGAIN. ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. YOU MAY CLOSE MISTER
LIVING. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU MEMBERS
YOUR ATTENTION TO THIS- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU- JURORS
RECOMMENDING IVOTE AND
PICTORIAL. ON AB TWELVE TWENTY
THREE BY SEVEN MEMBER LEVINE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
REVENUE AND TAXATION COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER. JONES SAWYER HI
LACKEY NO LACKEY NO BARRICADE
CAN BARRICADE HAD I WORK HARD
WORK I DIEGO. CAARE TO KNOW
THEY ARE TURNOUT WICKS WICKS I
LI LI I. THAT MEASURE PASSES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MUCH MISTER
CHAIR NUMBERS THANK YOU. NEXT
UP IS ITEM NUMBER TWO A. B.
SEVEN SEVEN NINE. MISTER
BIGELOW PEACE OFFICERS AND
DEPUTY CHIEF'S DEPUTY SHERIFFS-
EARLIER THEY PUT YOU ON THIS
COMMITTEE MR BIGELOW. IT'S DEJA
VU IS YES IT IS. YOU MAY BEGIN
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR. WHICH CHAIR I HAVE A
LENGTHY SET OF PRESENTATION
HERE BUT I KNOW MANY OF YOU
HAVE HEARD THIS BILL A COUPLE
OF TIMES BEFORE BUT THERE ARE A
COUPLE OF NEW MEMBERS SO IF
YOU'LL INDULGE ME I'D LIKE TO
GIVE THEM THE RESPECT OF
HEARING. THE INFORMATION SOLVE
READ THIS IN A PARED DOWN
VERSION THANK YOU TO THE MOTION
MAKER FOR THE QUICKNESS ON
THAT. TODAY I'M PRESENTING
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN SEVEN NINE
WHICH WOULD ADD DEL NORTE MONO
MADERA AND SAN MATEO COUNTIES
TO LIST OF COUNTIES NOTED IN
SECTION EIGHT THREE OH POINT
ONE C. OF THE PENAL CODE
ALLOWING DEPUTY SHERIFF TO
PERFORM THE DUTIES OF A PEACE
OFFICER. AS PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICERS THESE EMPLOYEES ARE
ALREADY IN UNIFORM AND
OCCASIONALLY HAVE ASSIGNMENTS
TO TAKE THEM OUT OF THE JAILS.
SETTING BUT THEY HAVE MORE
LIMITED. ABILITIES IN THEIR
CAPACITY TO PROTECT THE- PUBLIC
THIS WOULD GIVE THEM. THAT
ABILITY. OF THE NEW
CLASSIFICATION WOULD
ADDITIONALLY HELP PROVIDE MORE
VERSATILE AND LARGER STAFFING.
THIS WOULD COST SAVE FOR OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS I'M HERE TO ANSWER
THOSE BUT I DO HAVE. A COUPLE
OF FOLKS I BELIEVE ONLINE- THAT
ARE WITH ME TODAY- SHERIFF
INGRID. BRAUN FROM MODEL COUNTY
AND DAVID WAS NEXT- PRESIDENT
OF THE SAN MATTEO DEPUTY
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION. SO WHEN
IT'S APPROPRIATE I WOULD-
ENCOURAGES FOR AN IPHONE. SO
SURE BROWN AND- MISTER RODNEY
ACT YOU MAY BEGIN WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. AT&T. AND IF
YOU'RE ON THE LINE YOU HAVE TO
PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO. SO WE
CAN IDENTIFY YOUR LINE. THANK
YOU. HELLO DID WE LOSE YOU. NO
I'M STILL HERE WE JUST NEED A
MOMENT TO IDENTIFY THE LINE
OKAY THEY DIDN'T CALL IN AT THE
SPEAKER. SORRY TO HEAR ME YES.
YES WE CAN. IT'S BEEN GREAT
BRAUN- I DID CALL AND I'M SORRY
THAT IT IT DIDN'T RECOGNIZE
PROPERLY. YOU YOU I'M SURE IF
YOU MAY BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU CAN FIRE
COMMITTEE MEMBER THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF ASSEMBLY ITSELF SEVEN
SEVEN NINE WHICH PROPOSES TO AT
THE COUNTY DOWN NORT MADERA
MONO AND CAN MATTEO. TO THE
LIST OF COUNTIES NOTED
INFECTION EIGHT THIRTY POINT
ONE THREE OF THE CALIFORNIA
PENAL CODE. EINIGER BROWN
SHERIFF OF MONMOUTH COUNTY.
EIGHT THIRTY POINT ONE C.
OPERATIVE PEACE OFFICER STATUS
TWO CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
UNSPECIFIED COUNTY THOUGHT ON
DUTY AND ENGAGED IN THE
PERFORMANCE OF THEIR DUTIES.
WHEN PERFORMING OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT DUTIES DIRECTED BY
THE EMPLOYING AGENCY. OR IN A
LOCAL STATE OF EMERGENCY.
MARTIN CHANGE WOULD BE FOURTH
MULTIPLIER AND TO FOR THE OF
MONO MADERA DEL NORD AND
CANAKKALE. IT WOULD ALLOW
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS CAN BE
HARMFUL PERFORMING CORRECTIONS
RELATED PASSED. TO TRANSPORT.
BUT ALSO ALLOW THE SHERIFF
DEPLOYED CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
DURING A LOCAL STATE OF
EMERGENCY. INCREASING AVAILABLE
RESOURCES TO AFFECT AMERICAN TO
MANAGEMENT. AB SEVEN SEVEN NINE
HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS
DEMOCRAT AND REPUBLICAN CO
AUTHOR. IS CHANGING STATURE IT
WILL ALLOW EACH COUNTY TO
BETTER SERVE THEIR RESIDENT.
NOT A COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS I'M NOT A COUNTY
PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION. I'M NOT A COUNTY
DEPUTY SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION ALL
SUPPORT EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN
NINE. ALL OF MY CUSTODIAL STAFF
HAS UNDERGONE RIGOROUS
BACKGROUND INVESTIGATIONS PRIOR
TO BEING HIRED FOR THEIR
POSITIONS. PAYER HEALTH AT THE
SAME BACKGROUND STANDARDS AS A
DEPUTY SHERIFF. AUGUST
THIRTIETH STAFF UNDERGO EIGHT
THIRTY TWO PC TRAINING FOR
ARRESTING CONTROL AND FOR
FIREARMS. THEY ARE REQUIRED TO
REGULARLY QUALIFY WITH THEIR
FIREARMS. THE STANDARDS TO
WHICH THEY ARE HELD EXCEED
THOSE REQUIRED FOR CONCEALED
CARRY PERMIT. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU. MISTER BOSNIA. YES-
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK AND THAT FAVOR OF-
EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN NINE I'M
DAVID WALKING AT THE PRESIDENT
OF THE GAP INSURANCE
ASSOCIATION SAN MATEO COUNTY
REPRESENT FIVE HUNDRED OF THE
SHERIFF'S CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS. AND GET THE- FOLLOW
UP ON SURE. OF ON. THE MARKET.
MEMBERS HE A COLLECTION
BUILDING FIVE THIRTY FOUR ONCE
YOU. WILL HAVE THE SAME WERE.
RECEIVE THE. I MEAN AT THE TOP
OF A REGULAR THAT BE SURE OF.
IT WILL BE SUBJECT TO THE SAME
POLICY AND PROCEDURES AND THAT
OF THAT OF A DEPUTY SHERIFF IN
MAINE DISCIPLINARY PROCESS-
SEVEN SEVEN NINE GIVE THE
SHERIFF'S OFFICE MORE
FLEXIBILITY IN HOW THEY DID.
THE COURT STAFF ON A DAILY
BASIS AND IN CASES OF LOCAL.
EMERGENCIES ON BEHALF THE SHARP
ONE ELSE SANTA CLARA COUNTY
BOARD SUPERVISORS IN THE FIVE
HUNDRED MEMBERS OF THE SAN
MATEO COUNTY DEPUTY SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION. WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB SEVEN SEVEN NINE.
THANK YOU. NOT ANY WITNESSES IN
THE CHAMBER IN SUPPORT. ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON
TELECONFERENCING IN EIGHTEEN T.
EITHER ANY WITNESSES ON FARM
ROAD LIKE TO TEST BY MANY OF
THEM. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SHOW SUPPORT PRESS
THE ONE THEN ZERO NOW AGAIN ONE
AND THEN ZERO TO SHOW SUPPORT.
AND WE DO HAVE ABOUT FIVE IN
THE QUEUE WILL GO TO LINE ONE
EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS WHO SHALL MUCH FOR ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF AB SEVEN SEVEN NINE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AXOLOTL NINE
ONE FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AUDREY RETIRED CHECK ON BEHALF
OF THE SAN MATEO COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS IN THE PARK
THANK YOU THANK YOU. MAX THE
AUTO LINE A ONE EIGHTY EIGHT
PLEASE CALL I HAD. AND AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SHOW SUPPORT PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO NOW. IT'LL BE
JUST A MOMENT. AGAIN AS A
REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT PRESS
ONE THEN FERAL. GLOBAL TEL NINE
ONE FORTY PLEASE FIRED. AT THIS
TIME THERE'S NO ONE ELSE TO
MAKE YOU. THANK YOU ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. IN
THE ROOM ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- ANY RIGHT DO YOU
HAVE ANY BY TESTIFYING
OPPOSITION NO ABOUT IT NOT CO
HERNANDEZ. C. A. C. J. ON THE
PHONE AT&T. AND YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. EJF ALIGNED YOU CAN SPEAK.
HELLO THANK YOU MAXFIELD NOT ON
THE LINE AT THIS MOMENT. OKAY.
SO LET'S DO ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN THE
VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOM. AND
LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANY
WITNESSES ONLINE HE MAY SHOW UP
ONLINE. AT&T LET THE WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION AT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND I CURRENTLY HAVE THREE
LINES INTO YOUR GO TO LINE ONE
NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON- CHAIRS AND
MEMBERS ALBEMARLE CEMETERY
COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN SEVEN NINE.
THANK YOU. I THANK YOU RYAN ONE
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS YEAR 5% ON OUR COUNTY- I'M
JUST CALLING TO SHOW MY SUPPORT
FOR SEVEN SEVEN NINE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. LINE ONE NINETY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HOT HI
CHRIS RODRIGUEZ MADERA
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT- I'M
CALLING TO SUPPORT FROM
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN SEVEN NINE
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR. THANK
YOU AND I DO HAVE ONE LEFT IN
Q. IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR
THAT LINE. JUST BECAUSE- IT
MIGHT BE NICE YOU. HI MY NINETY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEMBERS
READY PERRY- WITH PARKINSON
COURT OF SEVEN SEVEN NINE THANK
YOU. THE THANK YOU. AS
DEFINITELY NOT THANK YOU I HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OPERATOR- I NOW BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE. ANY QUESTIONS.
LET'S SEE. IT'S BEEN
CONSECUTIVE THIRD. YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK
AN AYE VOTE COLORING YOUR
RECOMMENDATION I. THE BILL'S
BEEN PROBLEM HAVE BEEN SECONDED
ON EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN NINE BY
SOME MEMBER BIGELOW THE MOTION
IS TO PASS JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER I LACKEY. LACKEY I PARA
CAN. WORK BY CORK ACCENT JAGA.
C. A. R. TELL ARTSY ARE TOO
HIGH WICKS. LEE NOW WE KNOW
THAT MEASURE SOME CALLING.
MEASURES ARE CALL ME TOO AND
MARK. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
IS SO WE NOW HAVE. NO ONE IN
ROME I HAVE ARAMBULA. SB SIX
HUNDRED NUMBER THREE A. B. NINE
THREE SEVEN. NUMBER FIVE AB
THIRTY EIGHT NUMBER SIX AB TWO
SIX EIGHT IRWIN A. B. THIRTY
EIGHT COOPER. AND THEN AB SIX
FIVE FIVE KALRA. NUMBER TEN A.
B. THREE THREE THREE- COME
LONGER. AND IF YOU. I WILL WAIT
ONE MINUTE AND I MAY ALLOW. A
COMMITTEE MEMBER TO GO. I'VE
I'VE GONE THROUGH THE WHOLE
LIST OF MEMBERS THAT ARE BEFORE
MR LACKEY- JUST TO BE FAIR. MR
LACKEY MISTER LEE. LEVEL MR
LACKEY AND THEN. THESE MEASURES
IS SET MATHIS WITHDREW SO THE
ONLY ONES LEFT AFTER THAT WOULD
BE PATTERSON WALDRON AND WARD.
SO ANY OF THOSE THREE AFTER MR
LACKEY COULD. POSSIBLY TESTIFY.
TO HERE'S MISTER KALRA. WE SEE
HAVE MISTER CAR AB SIX FIVE
FIVE- CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT ACCOUNTABILITY
REFORM ACT. PLEASE. TAKE YOUR
TIME IS. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. EXTREMISM
RACISM ANIMUS HAVE NO PLACE
AMONG LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
CAN ONLY CONTRIBUTE TO THE
EROSION OF PUBLIC CONFIDENCE IN
LEGITIMACY. EMBARRASSED OF OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM. AB FIFTY BY THE
CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT
ACCOUNTABILITY REFORM ACT FOR
THE CLEAR OFF. FULL CLARA
COMMONSENSE REALLY LIMITED PRE
EMPLOYMENT SCREENING FOR KNOWN
PARTICIPATION WITH VIOLENT HATE
GROUPS. THAT IS AN EXTREMELY
SIMPLE TRADITIONAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES IS
ABUNDANT. ASIDE FROM THE
APPALLING INSURRECTION THE U.
S. CAPITAL. WITH THE
PARTICIPATION OF SOME IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT. CALIFORNIA'S OWN
PLEASE APARTMENTS HAVE BEEN
PLAYING WITH CANDLES OF
OFFICERS PRESSING. RACIST
HOMOPHOBIC OR THREATENING
MESSAGES OVER SOCIAL MEDIA.
OFFICERS HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED A
RALLIES ORGANIZED BY WHITE
SUPREMACIST GROUPS. AND
EXPRESSED VIEWS LATELY ON
SOCIAL MEDIA. AND IT FOR THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITIES THEY
ARE SWORN TO PROTECT. THIS
ISSUE HAS BEEN ON THE RADAR OF
THE FBI WHICH WAS IDENTIFIED
ORGANIZATIONS OVER THE PAST
FIFTEEN YEARS. HAS IDENTIFIED
ORGANIZATIONS COMMITTED TO
DOMESTIC TERORISM THAT INCLUDE
MILITIA EXTREMISTS. AND WHITE
SUPREMACISTS EXTREMISTS WITH
ACTIVE LINKS LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WITHOUT ANY COORDINATED BETTER
RESPONSES PROBLEM ISSUE STATE
ACTION IS LONG OVERDUE. THE
CLEAR RECOGNIZES NUANCES IN A
PEACE OFFICER'S AFFILIATION TO
HATE GROUPS AND OF A COMPLAINT
ALLEGING UP THREATENING OR
VIOLENT BEHAVIOR IS FILED.
AGAINST KERN OFFICER. AN
INVESTIGATION WILL BE TRIGGERED
A COULD BE GROUNDS FOR.
TERMINATION IF SUSTAIND. WE
WERE THOUGHT FOR PERSONAL
PROTECTION THIS BILL IN THE
CLEAR ACT BUILDS UP EXISTING
ABILITIES BY THE STATE TO LIMIT
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES
IF SOMEONE SPEECH COULD
INTERFERE THE DUTIES OF THE JOB.
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS PLAY A
CRITICAL ROLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND MUST HAVE THE
TRUST OF THE PUBLIC TO DO THEIR
JOBS SAFELY AND EFFECTIVELY.
HOWEVER THE IMPORTATION OF
VIOLENT EXTREMISTS AND LACK OF
FEDERAL OR STATE ACTION ON THIS
GOING ISSUE HAS LED TO A
SERIOUS OR RELIGION. PUBLIC
TRUST. TO ADDRESS CONCERNS OF
THE DEPOSITIONS COULD APPLY TO
A PERSON'S RELIGIOUS OR
POLITICAL AFFILIATIONS THE
BILL'S HATE GROUP DEFINITION
WAS AMENDED. TO REMOVE DENIAL
OF CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS. IT
WAS NEVER THE INTENT TO PREVENT
PEOPLE WITH FAITH BASED OR
CONSERVATIVE VIEWS FROM
BECOMING LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS. AND I AND I THINK
THOSE THAT RAISE THAT ISSUE AS-
WE ALL KNOW- THE FIRST VERSION
OF BILL B. HE KEPT INFORMED
WHEN ISSUES ARISE AND THAT WAS
CERTAINLY WHEN THERE'S WAS A
LEGITIMATE ONE. AND AGAIN WAS
NEVER THE INTENTION TO HAVE
THAT TYPE OF IMITATION.
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL WAS
AMENDED TO SET A LIMITED TIME
FRAME. FOR THE BACKGROUND
CHECKS TO NARROW THE SCOPE
THOSE OFFICERS THAT MAY POSE A
MORE IMMINENT DANGER TO PUBLIC
SAFETY. EVERYONE HAS A RIGHT.
TO REDEMPTION AND THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO SHOW AND TO
PROVE THAT- THEY HAVE CHANGED
THEIR VIEWS AND I THINK THAT
SHOULD APPLY TO THOSE THAT HAVE
AN INTEREST IN ENTERING THE
FIELD ALONG FOR SOME. RENDON
IDENTIFIES SPECIFIC GROUPS THE
BILL'S TRIGGERED BY DESTRUCTIVE
BEHAVIOR THAT CAN BE INDICATIVE
OF FUTURE VIOLENCE TOWARDS
NUMBER THE PUBLIC. MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC MEMBERS OF OTHER GROUPS.
BUT THE PROBLEM ISN'T LITERALLY
THE KKK HAVE NO PLACE. IN A LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND SHOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO ATTAIN A BATCH
OF THE AUTHORITY. AND POWER
THAT COMES WITH IT. THE CLERK
WILL PROPERLY SCREEN CANDIDATES
AND EMPOWER PEOPLE TO HOLD LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
ACCOUNTABLE. WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
FUNCTIONAL LANGUAGE AND
DISCUSSING HOW TO ACHIEVE THE
SHARED GOALS OF THIS MEASURE.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IS DR WILLIAM ARE MINE THE
DIRECTOR OF THE HUMAN RIGHTS
INSTITUTE AT CELLS ARE STATE
UNIVERSITY. AND RUN ROUTE THE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU. AT&T OPERATOR
WHENEVER THE WITNESSES ARE
READY TO TESTIFY. AIRLINES ARE
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS WILL ARLENE
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN GO
AHEAD PROFESSOR. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS WILL LIKELY
MARLENE ON THE FOUNDING
DIRECTOR OF THE SENATE THE
STATE UNIVERSITY HUMAN RIGHTS
INSTITUTE. WE WERE APPROACHED
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN BY OUR
COLLEAGUES THE CINEMA COUNTY
HUMAN RIGHTS COMMISSION FOR
HELP AFTER THEY RECEIVED
NUMEROUS REPORTS OF POLICE
BRUTALITY RACIAL PROFILING
ARBITRARY STOPS THERE WERE
OFTEN ACCOMPANIED BY RACIAL
SLURS. AND ALL PUBLIC
REFERENCES TO WHITE NATIONALISM
FORTUNATELY WE'RE ARE YOU
RESEARCHING AT LEAST FIFTEEN
YEARS OF REPORTS FROM THE FBI
OTHER FEDERAL AGENCIES
INVESTIGATIVE JOURNALIST
IDENTIFIED ORGANIZATIONS
COMMITTED TO DOMESTIC TERRORISM
THAT INCLUDE MILITIA WHAT'S
PROMISES AND SOVEREIGN CITIZEN
EXTREMISTS THAT HAVE ACTIVE
LINKS TO LAW ENFORCEMENT. THIS
INFILTRATION OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES SHOULD BE CONSIDERED A
HUMAN RIGHTS CRISIS IN UNITED
STATES. BRITAIN'S THE INTEGRITY
OF CRIMINAL INVESTIGATIONS AND
LEGITIMATE AUTHORITY OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT THAT THREATENS THE
PUBLIC SAFETY OF THOSE TARGETED
BY SUCH ORGANIZATIONS THAT ALL
BUT GUARANTEES DISCRIMINATORY
APPLICATION OF LAWS AND
PROVISION OF SERVICES IN
VIOLATION OF INTERNATIONAL
HUMAN RIGHTS TREATIES RATIFIED
BY THE UNITED STATES. AND
REPRESENTS A MANCHESTER UP TO
BE CONSTITUTIONAL AND HUMAN
RIGHTS EQUAL PROTECTION UNDER
THE LAW. ACCORDING TO AREA
EXPERT MICHAEL GERMAN FROM THE
FRONT AND CENTER OF JUSTICE AND
FORMER FBI SPECIAL AGENT ON
DOMESTIC TERROR AND COVERT
OPERATIONS MANY OF YOU ACTUALLY
SEE HIM ON TELEVISION AND
GIVING SORT CONGRESSIONAL
TESTIMONY ON THIS ISSUE. THE
MOST EFFECTIVE IN ASSISTANCE
QUOTE AND I QUOTE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAY FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO RESTORE
PUBLIC TRUST INTERNET RACES
WORKMAN PUBLISHING LAW
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS IS TO
PROHIBIT INDIVIDUALS WERE
MEMBERS OF WHITE SUPREMACIST
GROUPS TROUBLED REGISTRY THAT
SPLITS THE RACIST CONDUCT FROM
BECOMING LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS IN THE FIRST PLACE
ORANGE FOR WAR FROM REMAINING
OFFICERS ONCE DEMONSTRATED. AND
QUOTE THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT THE
CORRECTIVE DESIGNED TO
ACCOMPLISH IN ALL THE WAYS
DESCRIBED BY SOME MEMBER KALRA
MOMENT AGO. THE CORRECT WILL
NOT PRESENT A CHALLENGE THE
CIVIL LIBERTIES OF PEACE
OFFICERS OR BOARD OR OTHER
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES NORSE THE
CURBING OF ANY EXISTING
CONSTITUTIONAL HUMAN RIGHT THE
PURPOSE OF THE BILL. IN FACT
ACCORDING TO RESEARCH MORE
RESEARCH FROM THE BRENNAN
CENTER FOR JUSTICE QUOTE MOST
COURTS HAVE UPHELD DISMISSALS
OF POLICE OFFICERS TO
AFFILIATED WITH. RACES ARE
MILITANT GROUPS FOLLOWING
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE LIMITING
FREE SPEECH RIGHTS FOR. COOLEY
SOME MANNERS OF PUBLIC AND-
THANK ARE GIVEN LONG FOR.
AGENCY EVEN CALL A LOT OF
RESEARCH TEACHING SO. SENT A
QUOTE HI NEED FOR ORDER OF
CHANGE. AND HARMONY SHE SHOULD
FIND BE NOTED HERE THAT TALKS
ARE UNIQUE FROM ALL OF TYPES OF
PUBLIC AND- IN THEIR ACCESS TO
THE STATE. NOT ON THE USE OF
FORCE IN A PARTICULAR ROLE IN
EXECUTING THE RULE OF LAW. FOR
THIS REASON IS CRITICAL TO
PEACE OFFICERS BE HELD TO THE
HIGHEST POSSIBLE PROFESSIONAL
STANDARDS. IN THEIR ABILITY TO
RESPECT AND PROTECT ALL MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH COMMITTEE MEMBERS MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU NEXT. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
RON RAPP SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
SIX FIVE FIVE WE'RE PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR THIS IMPORTANT BILL
THAT WILL COMBAT THE
INFILTRATION OF EXTREMIST SOME
LAW ENFORCEMENT WE LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE THE IMPLICATION OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES BY
EXTREMIST ORGANIZATIONS
THREATENS THE INTEGRITY
INTEGRITY OF CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATIONS JEOPARDIZES THE
SAFETY OF ELECTED OFFICIALS
PEACE OFFICERS AND THE PUBLIC
AND INVITE BIASED AND
DISCRIMINATORY APPLICATION OF
LOG SERVICES. THE JANUARY SIXTH
INSURRECTION AT THE U. S.
CAPITOL BUILDING BY RIGHT WING
EXTREMISTS WITH THE APPARENT
COOPERATION PARTICIPATION AND
SUPPORT OF SOME LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND MILITARY PERSONNEL
UNDERSCORES THE THREAT THAT
EXTREMISTS AMPLE INFILTRATION
POSES TO EQUAL JUSTICE AND THE
RULE OF LAW CFA BELIEVES THAT
AB SIX FIVE FIVE WILL INCREASE
PUBLIC TRUST IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
BY ROOTING OUT THOSE WHO WOULD
JEOPARDIZE PUBLIC SAFETY WITH
EXTREMISM AND VIOLENT BEHAVIOR
IT IS FOR THESE REASONS THAT WE
ARE A PROUD CO SPONSOR OF
EIGHTY SIX FIVE FIVE. AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST. YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. UNDER ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT INDIE
HEARING ROOM ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT ON THE TELE
CONFERENCING. AT&T OPERATOR ON
BABY THINK THAT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY SIX FIVE
FIVE PRESS ONE THEN THERE ARE
NOW AGAIN ONE THEN ZERO NOW TO
SHOW SUPPORT. AT THIS TIME
THERE'S NO ONE ON THE LINE.
THANK YOU ARE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION HI I HAVE A KEVIN
SNYDER PACIFIC JUSTICE
INSTITUTE- OPERATOR DO YOU HAVE
THAT PERSON ONLINE. YES. IT
KEVIN SNYDER CAN YOU HEAR ME I
SURE CAN BEGIN. MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KEVIN
SNYDER OF PACIFIC JUSTICE
INSTITUTE CENTER FOR PUBLIC
POLICY WHERE I SERVED AS CHIEF
COUNSEL THIS AFTERNOON I SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO THE CALIFORNIA
LAW ENFORCEMENT ACCOUNTABILITY
REFORM ACT UNLESS FURTHER
AMENDED- FIRST WILL CALL THE
OFFICE RECENT AMENDMENT TO
STRIKE OUT THE LANGUAGE WHICH
STATES THAT AN APPLICANT FOR
POSITION. BUT LAW ENFORCEMENT
IS DISQUALIFIED FOR ADVOCATING
AND SUPPORTING THE DENIAL OF
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO PERSONS
BELONGING TO A PROTECTED CLASS.
THE IRONY IS THAT THIS LANGUAGE
THAT HE HAS JUST STRICKEN AIMED
AT PROTECTING CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS WHICH WOULD HAVE
EXPLICITLY DENIED RIGHT SECURED
UNDER THE FIRST AMENDMENT THE
AUTHORS CHANGE WAS ONE STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION. BUT
REGRETTABLY IN THE LAST THE
LATEST VERSION DOES NOT SURE
ALL THE DEFECTS AS CURRENTLY
DRAFTED THE BILL CLAIMS TO
ASSURE PROPER CANDIDATES TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND REMOVAL OF
THOSE UNFIT FOR SERVICE BUT THE
MEANS BY WHICH IS SIX THOSE
DANCES TO EMPLOY THE USE OF THE
TERM EXPRESSION OF HATE. TO
CREATE GUILT BY ASSOCIATION AND
IDEOLOGICAL. DISQUALIFICATION
BILL WOULD FURTHER THE OF JUST.
TO PROMULGATE RULES FOR THE
INVESTIGATION OF WHAT AMOUNTS
TO FIGHT CRIME. USE OF THE DOJ
FOR INVESTIGATING AND
ADJUDICATING EXPRESSIONS OF
HATE BUT IRONICALLY NOT PROMOTE
THE WILL OF LAW BUT INSTEAD
LAID THE FOUNDATION FOR POLICE
STATE. RELATED TO THIS IS THE
LIMITATION OF PROTECTIONS TO
PERSONS BELONGING TO CERTAIN
CLASSES RACE ETHNICITY
NATIONALITY. RELIGION GENDER
GENDER IDENTITY SEXUAL
ORIENTATION DISABILITY. OUR
POSITION IS THAT VIOLENCE OR
THE SOLICITATION OF VIOLENCE
AGAINST SUCH PERSONS BECAUSE OF
THE THEIR ACTUAL OR PERCEIVED
MEMBERSHIP IN SUCH CLASSES AS
GROUNDS FOR DISQUALIFICATION TO
SERVE IN LAW ENFORCEMENT. BUT
IN THAT SENSE THE CLEAR ACTORS
TO NARROW THOSE ARE NOT THE
ONLY PEOPLE WHO MERIT LEGAL
PROTECTION. ALL CITIZENS IN THE
STATE DESERVE TO BE PROTECTED.
LANGUAGE REGARDING HATE GROUPS
THE EXPRESSIONS OF HATE AND THE
LIKE SHOULD BE STRICKEN FROM
THE BILL AS WELL AS IDENTIFYING
CERTAIN GROUPS OF THE SOLE
BENEFICIARIES PROTECTION. WE
WOULD URGE THAT THE BILL BE
SIMPLIFIED IN BROADENED WITH
THE FOLLOWING LANGUAGE. NO
PERSON CAN SERVE IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHO ENGAGES AN
ADVOCATE OR THREATENED UNLAWFUL
VIOLENCE AGAINST. ANY PERSON.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR DELIBERATION ON THIS
MATTER AND FOR YOUR SERVICE TO
THE COMMUNITY. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR INPUT. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES WITNESSES IN THE ROOM
CURRENT OPPOSITION. ANY
WITNESSES ON THE VIDEO
CONFERENCING. AT EIGHTY T.
OPERATOR ARE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. ON THE PHONE THANK
YOU AND WE ACTUALLY HAD ABOUT
TWENTY THAT SHOWED UP FOR
SUPPORT OUR SYSTEM DIDN'T SHOW
IT RIGHT AWAY I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU WANTED TO GO TO THAT FIRST
SURE. OKAY WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHEROKEE MEDIA
INTO LAKE HERE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER- IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SIX FIVE FIVE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
ONE HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES THIS IS ERIC HARRIS WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT TWO THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU-
ALEX KEPPLER REPRESENTING A
QUALITY CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU RYAN ONE FORTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO NICOLAS
GONZALES FOR CALIFORNIA CIVIL
LIBERTIES ADVOCACY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT TO
OUR NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YVONNE MAXWELL- FROM SAN JOSE
CALIFORNIA FOR MAJIMA ADULT AND
FAMILY SERVICES AND WE ARE
SUPPORT. YOU'RE RIGHT TO
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS SERGEANT CON I AM FROM
SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA I'M A
PUBLIC DEFENDER HERE AND I
SUPPORT AB SIX FIFTY FIVE.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT YOU CAN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
CHRIS **** I'M FROM PANEL THEY
CALIFORNIA I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
AND I AM SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SIX
FIVE FIVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT TO ALIVE IN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS KAREN
JEFFREY ON THE MOUNTAIN VIEW
I'M WITH THEM AND I THINK
UNIVERSITY AND I'M IN CHARGE OF
THE PARK- FIVE FIVE. THANK YOU.
EXPLORE MORE ALIGNED ONE FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE CALL I HAD.
CANACCORD ARE MOUNTAIN HALF OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MAXIMAL
CAROLINE NINETY EIGHT IF I HAD.
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
NAKAMOTO LINE EIGHTY ONE YOU
ARE HAD. LINE EIGHTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MARGOT TOWARDS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. WITH MAXIMO CAROLINA ONE
NINETY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
KNOW ONE NINETY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS CAN
BE A LONG DO YOU HEAR ME I
CAN'T TELL ALIGNER MARKET THAT
ME YES YOU YEAH HERE YOU NAME
AN ORGANIZATION ANNOUNCED
MONDAY THAT IT. LONG I'M FROM
SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA AND WITH
THE PEOPLE GOT AFTER AND THE
BOOK ADVOCATE AND I SUPPORT. AB
SIX FAT GUY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. MAXIMO CAROLINE ONE FORTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIND ONE
FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MAXIMO CAROLINE SEVENTY THREE
THE FOREIGN. HELLO YES WE CAN
YES WE CAN HELLO. OKAY HI THIS
IS VERONICA REAL COLLEEN AND-
BEHALF OF UNITED BROWN
COALITION AND WE STRONGLY
BELIEVE THAT WHITE SUPREMACISTS
HAVE NO PLACE IN A LONG. THANK
YOU APART THANK YOU. AND THAT
MAXIMUM- ALIGNMENT TWO OH FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NO YES YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES YES. HI MY NAME THE
ANIMOSITY THAT IT AND I'M FROM
PETALUMA WITH CINEMA COUNTY
HUMAN RIGHTS COMMISSION AND I
CERTAINLY SUPPORT EIGHTY SIX
THANKS BYE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
BACK TO A MOTEL AND KILLED
SEVEN PLEASE WELL I HAD. BOTH
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MAXIMO
TIELINE TWO TWENTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SURE MEMBERS EARNING
A LOT OF REPRESENTING DEFERRED
IN SUPPORT OF AB. SIX THANK YOU.
AGAIN IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW. MATT
THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
IN THE QUEUE. THANK YOU. AND.
WE WERE DOING OPPOSITION TO
FINISH. DO NOT HAVE POSITIONS
OR BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. OUR ANY QUESTIONS.
YES MISTER TERLECKI. YEAH FIRST
OFF LET ME- ECKEL THE
APPRECIATION- THAT'S EXPRESSED
EARLIER- FOR TAKING. CLARIFYING
AMENDMENT THAT- INITIALLY
TRIGGERED NATIONAL ALARM AND
ALL TRUE. AND I THINK I KNOW. I
THINK YOU GOT THAT SO YEAH WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE IT- YOU
TAKING THAT AMENDMENT AND LET
ME ALSO STATE THAT THERE'S NO
ROOM FOR HATE GROUPS SUPPORTERS
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT SHE FULLY
HAVE MY SUPPORT ON THAT BUT I
STILL. WOOD RESERVE MY SUPPORT
ENTER YOUR MANAGE AS STATED BY
THE- EARLIER OPPOSITION. THE
THE EXPRESSION OF HATE IS TOO
BROAD TOO VAGUE. AND I THINK
COULD MISS BE MISINTERPRETED.
AND I THINK IT'S VERY VERY
DANGEROUS AND IT'S A THREAT TO
FIRST AMENDMENT- PROTECTIONS
AND SO I'M NOT FULLY READY TO
SUPPORTYOUR BILL IN ITS
CURRENT FORM. BUT I CERTAINLY
SUPPORT THE FACT THAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO GET RID OF. AND GET
IN STATUTE THAT THE THERE'S NO
ROOM FOR HATE GROUPS SUPPORTERS
LAW ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE YOU YOU
HAVE MY FULL BACKING ON THAT
FRONT. END TO THE CHAIR THANK
YOU SO MUCH AS A MEMBER A
LACKEY- AND YES IT CAN BE
CHALLENGING TO MAKE THOSE
DETERMINATIONS ARE COURSE
MICHAEL'S TERMINATIONS.
CONSTANTLY THERE IS HATE CRIME
LEGISLATION THIS HATE CRIME YOU
KNOW STATUES THAT GET
INTERPRETED BY PROSECUTORS GET
INTERPRETED BY COURTS BY JUDGES
BY JURIES BY PAUL COURTS AND SO
YES IT IS CHALLENGING CAN BE
CHALLENGING BUT- AT THE FBI'S
INDICATED DURING THEIR-
EXHAUSTIVE INVESTIGATION INTO
THESE ISSUES. THAT THERE IS A
WAY TO MAKE THAT DETERMINATION
BUT YOU'RE RIGHT YOU ALWAYS
MUST BE CAUTIOUS I DO
APPRECIATE ARMY YOU'RE YOU'RE
VERY VOCAL SUPPORT IN THE
OBJECTIVE. MR BURKE CHAU ON
WITH MR LACKEY I WON'T BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT IT NOW UNLESS YOU
AGREE RECENT CHANGES. MY
CONCERN IS THAT MERE MEMBERSHIP
IS GROUNDS FOR NOT BEING HIRED.
SOMETHING COULD HAVE HAPPENED
SIX YEARS EARLIER. FRANKLY
YOU'RE A DIFFERENT PERSON
BETWEEN EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY
FOUR. BUT EVEN BEYOND THAT THE
IDEA OF USING MEMBERSHIP. IS
JUST REPORTING THAT. THIS
SMACKS OF THE MCCARTHYISM YOU
PROBABLY ALL SEEN THE CLIP OF
MCCARTY BEING TOLD HAVE YOU NO
SHAME AT LONG LAST SIR HAVE YOU
NO SHAME THAT'S BECAUSE- KARTI
WAS GOING AFTER ONE OF WELCH'S
PERSON SAID THIS THE OTHER.
ARMY LAWYER. GOING AFTER
BECAUSE YOU BELONG TO THE
NATIONAL LAWYERS GUILD WHICH WE
ALL KNOW IS A NON PROFIT IT
HELPS IN THE GRAND SAID CETERA
ETCETERA. AT ANY RATE- BECAUSE
IT WAS ON THE LIST HI THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL- MCCARTHY WITH
JUST ONE AFTERNOON WHEN AFTER.
AND YOU KNOW I JUST THAT PART
OF THE BILL JUST DRIVES ME
CRAZY. SO IF YOU'RE WILLING TO
TAKE OUT THE MEMBERSHIP CARDS.
AND JUST GO ON HOW PEOPLE ACT.
THEN I'M OKAY I THINK THAT'S
PRETTY MUCH THE POSITION OF THE
OPPOSITION OF MR LANKY BUT WHEN
YOU GET INTO THE MEMBERSHIP
FIGHT I JUST CAN'T SUPPORT. I'M
OF THE APPRECIATE THE FEEDBACK
WE ARE WORKING WITH- GROUPS
INCLUDING DELIBERATE PLEASE
TACKLE IT WILL BE MEETING WITH
THEM BECAUSE THEY DO HAVE SOME.
ADDITIONAL CONCERNS THAT WE'RE
COMMITTED TO THESE TRYING TO
WORK ON I WILL SAY THAT LOOK
YOU KNOW THIS IS FOCUSED ON-
GROUPS- THAT ACTUALLY
THREATENED PHYSICAL VIOLENCE
LIKE I SAID THE FBI HAS BEEN
ABLE TO. IDENTIFY GROUPS- THAT
INCLUDES IT EXTREMIST GROUPS
THIS IS NOT. COMPLETELY YOU
KNOW JUST A- A SUBJECTIVE WHAT
TYPE OF MEASUREMENT AND I THINK
THAT THERE ARE. YOU KNOW
SOMEONE- IS A MEMBER OF THE KKK
I THINK THAT'S A PROBLEM IF
THEY WANT TO BE A LAW
ENFORCEMENT FRANKLY- AND AGAIN
THAT THERE'S A REASON WHY WE
ALSO GOT RID OF THE- DEBT THE%
TIMELESSNESS OF IT. AND MADE
SEVEN YEARS AND I THINK THAT
THAT AT LEAST GIVES A PERIOD OF
TIME WHERE. YOU KNOW THERE'S
SOME SEPARATION FROM ANY
AFFILIATION- UP BECAUSE TO YOUR
POINT I THINK THAT BEFORE THAT
IN THE ORIGINAL WRITING OF THE
BILL DIDN'T HAVE ANYTHING ON
THE TIMELINESS OF IT SO COULD
HAVE BEEN TWENTY YEARS EARLIER.
OR TEN FIFTEEN TWENTY YEARS
EARLIER EVERYTHING JUST LIKE
ALL THIS LIKE MANY OF US WORK-
AND BELIEVE IN REDEMPTION FOR
THOSE THAT. GET CAUGHT UP IN
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
SOME AT LEAST ONCE GOING TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT THEY HAVE THE RIGHT
FOR THAT REDUCTION AS WELL AS
US MNEY BUT THAT TIME I AM
WILLING TO CONCEDE THAT YOU CAN
DETERMINE WHAT I HATE GROUP IS.
I THINK MERE MEMBERSHIP.
DISQUALIFY YOU. ROOMS FOR
REASON FOR NOT BEING HIRED. IS
JUST. APPROPRIATE WHAT WAS YOUR-
OKAY AND THEN ITS GROUNDS AND
SO- IF THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY DOING THE HIRING. FEELS
THAT SIMPLY. JUST THE
MEMBERSHIP SIX AND A HALF YEARS
EARLIER. BUT THOSE ARE NOT
GROUNDS FOR TERMINATION OF FOR
NOT HIRING SOMEONE. THAT'S
UNDER DISCUSSION AS WELL. I
JUST SAY IT SHOULD NOT BE
CRITERIA. PERIOD THANK YOU JUST
A- ARE ANY MARK QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. YOU MAY
CLOSE OR WAS THAT YOUR CLOTHES.
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
FEEDBACK AND LIKE I SAID YOU
KNOW THE WE DID JUST TAKE A
MEDIA- AS IMMEDIATE AS POSSIBLE
AMENDMENTS- TO DEAL WITH THE
MOST OF. THE MOST ONEROUS
CONCERNS WHICH I AGREED WITH-
IN TERMS OF THE CONSTITUTIONAL.
ISSUES ARE AND AS STATED IN
THE- IN THE VERY WELL WRITTEN
BILL ANALYSIS. THAT THE
LIMITATIONS THAT NOW EXIST. IN
TERMS OF PERSONNEL IMITATIONS
AS- WRITTEN IN THE BILL ARE
WELL WITHIN THE POWERS OF. OF
GOVERNMENT PARTICULARLY FOR A
ROLE LIKE POLICE OFFICER
WITHOUT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE SO THANK YOU. WE NEED
A MOTION AND A SECOND. THANK
YOU. AND THANK YOU MISTER CARR
I DO BELIEVE THIS IS A
IMPORTANT I WISH YOU WILL
CLARIFY- BUT I THE ONLY WARNING
I WOULD GIVE IN THIS IS WHERE I
MAY DIFFER WITH SOME OF THE
MEMBERS HERE- IF YOU'RE A
MEMBER OF Q. ANON AND YOU
BELIEVE THAT PEOPLE OF JEWISH
FAITH HAVE A LASER FROM SPACE.
THAT HAS STARTED TO WILDFIRES
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE MAY WANT
TO REALLY TALK TO THAT
INDIVIDUAL ABOUT BEING IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT IF YOU DON'T
BELIEVE TO BE A MEMBER TO KKK
YOU DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE
HOLOCAUST EXISTED I THINK WE
HAVE TO HELP FURTHER DISCUSSION
WITH THAT INDIVIDUAL WHO IS A
MEMBER OF THAT BEFORE THEY
BECOME SO I I'VE I'VE I DON'T
THINK THEY DISAGREE WITH. THAT
IT'S IS WHETHER OR NOT YOU KNOW
YOU'RE USED TO LIKE WE HAVE
LAWS THAT IF USED TO BE A GANG
MEMBER YOU'RE NOT YOU'RE NOW
BEEN OUT FOR FIVE KID ELEVEN
YEARS WE WANT TO PAROLED
EARLIER BECAUSE THEY'RE NO
LONGER THAT. THEY GAIN MEMBERS
I'D BE IN THAT YEAH PROBABLY IN
THAT VEIN- IF YOU WORK THROUGH
THAT I THANK YOU YOU MAY EVEN
GET UNANIMOUS SUPPORT SO
TEXTURES RECOMMEND AND I BOTH.
THANK YOU. SB SIX FIVE FIVE
ISOMER KALRA THE MISSION IS TO
PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER HI BLACKIE NOPE LACKEY
NOW BARRICADE HAND BACKHAND HI
CORK CORK CONNEL SANTIAGO SEE
OUR TOWN NOW C. R. TEN NOW
WICKS. LI HI LEE I. THE
MEASURES ON CALL THANK YOU. AND
I THINK AND THANK YOU MR
ARAMBULA ROOM HELLO MISTER
COOPER TO COME IN WITH HIS
CHARTS AND GRAPHS AND FORTSON.
WE HAVE WE HAVE VISUAL. RIGHT
THERE ARE THERE'S FINE PRINT
ANYWHERE I. THAT I DON'T KNOW
IF WE CAN SEE IF I CAN
EVERYBODY SEE FROM THERE. HE
HAS ALSO. THANK YOU GUYS WHAT
WAS. MISTER COOPER MR LACKEY
MAY AFTER A CLOSE READING BRING
HIS GLASSES OKAY. ALL ALL ALL
REFORM. FROM. WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY READY A LOSS OF. A. B.
THIRTY EIGHT STATEWIDE SKI ITEM
NUMBER. THANK YOU MISTER SB
THIRTY EIGHT BRINGS BECAUSE IN
ORDER TO K. MESSY BILL SYSTEM
THE SAME TIME THE DRESSES ISSUE
OF BILLS STACKING BOTH OF WHICH
CAN BE DEVELOPMENTS BEING
INCONSISTENT UNREASONABLE AND
UNFAIR. EVERY YEAR SUPERIOR
COURT JUDGES IN EACH COUNTY
PREPARE AND ADOPT A UNIFORM
COUNTYWIDE BILL SCHEDULE FOR
ALL FELONY AND MISDEMEANOR
OFFENSES THIS CREATES FIFTY
EIGHT DIFFERENT BILL SCHEDULES
WHICH ROUTINELY TO DIFFERENT
BILL AMOUNTS FOR THE SAME
CHARGES EVEN IN NEIGHBORING
COUNTIES. AS AN EXAMPLE THE
NEIGHBORING COUNTIES OF ALAMEDA
AND SAN FRANCISCO HAVE
DIFFERENT BILL SCHEDULES FOR
THE CHARGES OF LEWD ACTS ON A
CHILD HUNDRED KILOMETER UNDER
FIFTY K. IN SAN FRANCISCO SELL
THE DEADLY WEAPON THIRTY K. AND
ALAMEDA FIFTY K. AND- SAN
FRANCISCO ARMED ROBBERY FIFTY
K. IN. ALAMEDA THIRTY FIVE K.
IN SAN FRANCISCO HEY THREATS.
FIFTY K. AND- ELAM. FIFTY FIVE
K. SAN FRANCISCO AND CHILD
ABANDONMENT TWENTY KILOMETER
INSTANCES GO TEN K. FOR BIGGER
COUNTIES- WITH LIKE
POPULATIONS- FOR RELAX ON
CHILDREN SAN DIEGO TWO HUNDRED
K. SAMBAR DEALS TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS- I'LL
TELL YA IF YOU LOOK AT THE
BIGGEST THING ON HERE THAT THE
GLARES AT ME AS ROBBERY. ARMED
ROBBERY IS THE TAKING OF
PERSONAL PROPERTY TO THE USE OF
FORCE OR FEAR SO ON THE BEACH
UP I'VE GOT A GUN I'M GONNA ROB
YOU SO RODRIGUEZ ROBIN ABOUT-
WHAT THE PENAL CODE AND IT GOES
FROM TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
SAMPOERNA DINO. ALL THE DATA
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
ALAMEDA IT'S THE SAME CRIME
THAT'S WE'VE BEEN A BIG ISSUE
AND I KNOW A LOT OF FOLKS HAVE
IDEAS ABOUT THIS BILL OF STUFF
IS ACTUALLY PROGRESSIVE BUT
THERE REALLY SHOULD BE A
UNIFORM BELL SCHEDULE ONE. YOU
FOR BILLS BECAUSE IN CALIFORNIA
WERE SET AT ONE BILL THE MATTER
WHAT. THAT'S REASON I
INTRODUCED THIS BILL- THIS IS
AN EQUITY PROBLEM THAT JUDGES
WILL FIX IN AB THIRTY EIGHT
DOES FIX SB THIRTY EIGHT ALSO
ALLOWS THE STATE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL TO REDUCE EXISTING BILL
ON EVERY OFFENSE UP TO HALF OF
THE EXISTING MONETARY VALUE TO
PROMOTE EVEN MORE FAIRNESS OF
CAST BILL AB THIRTY EIGHT
REPLACE THE CURRENT PRACTICE OF
BILLS STACKING. IN SOME
COUNTIES BILL US DIRECTLY
PERSONS ACCUSED OF MULTIPLE
OFFENSES OR STACK BECAUSE OF
ENHANCEMENTS LIKE PRIOR
CONVICTIONS THIS MEANS ALL
SCHEDULE BILL AMOUNTS FOR EACH
CHARGE. ARE ADDED TOGETHER.
TOGETHER JAIL PRE TRIAL THE
ACCUSED POST MUST POST A SOME
OF ALL THESE AMOUNTS WHICH CAN
BE EXORBITANT. SB THIRTY EIGHT
WILL LIMIT BILL STACKING TO
MAKE IT FAIR AND MORE EQUITABLE
ESPECIALLY WITH THOSE DO NOT
HAVE THE RESOURCES OTHERS.
THESE ARE NOT STATUS QUO
REFORMS.THERE IS A REAL
REFORMS THAT WILL LOWER BILL
IMMEDIATELY AND NOT BE
DEPENDENT ON THE SUBJECT OF
PROCESS. OF A BILL HEARINGS.
AND THAT'S THE END OF MY
PRESENTATION MISTER CHAIR. I DO
HAVE A WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
THAT I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE I
DON'T I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING ON
HERE IS TO MAKE SURE I DIDN'T
MISS ANYTHING THAT'S CORRECT
THERE ARE NONE GETTING IN THE
ROOM RT. ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. ON THE
TELECONFERENCING ARE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. AND NOW
ON THE AT&T TO THE PHONE ARE
YOU CALLING WITNESSES TO A. B.
THIRTY EIGHT. WE DO HAVE A
COUPLE THAT HAVE. CUED UP- ONE
MOMENT THIS OUR FIRST ONE COMES
FROM THE LINE SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE SEVENTY
THREE- MY COULD OPEN.
HELLO
CONNECTION COMES FROM THE LINE.
ONE THIRTY SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON
THE FACT THAT THE HAWKS
RESOLUTE AND ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BAIL AGENTS
ASSOCIATION BOARD THE PART OF
THE STATEWIDE BAIL SCHEDULE IN
AB THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU. OUR
NEXT ONE COMES FROM THE LINE
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS THIS IS CALLED OUR ON
BEHALF OF ALL PRO BAIL BONDS.
WE SUPPORT AB THIRTY EIGHT
THREE- THE STATEWIDE BILL
EDGELL AND ELIMINATING OF
STACKING OF BAIL BONDS THANK
YOU. THEIR NEXT ONE COMES
ONLINE IT TO FORTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS JUST PUT IT IN FROM THE
AMERICAN BELT COHERENCE BIRTH.
AB THIRTY EIGHT- PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR I'M
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND
EXCELLING CONSERVE LINE ONE
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NEXT ONE THAT COMES FROM LINE
ONE EIGHTEEN. GO AHEAD. YOU MAY
BEGIN. IN THE MEANWHILE. FIRST
CHECK JACKSON THEN COMES FROM A
LINE OF. ONE FORTY SEVEN. HELLO
GERMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS ISN'T
AND YOU ARE CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER AND WE CAN SUPPORT SB
THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND WE DO HAVE ONE OTHER
THAT HAS QUEUED UP ONE MOMENT
WATER GIVEN THE LINE NUMBER.
THEIR NEXT ONE COMES FROM THE
LINE TWO FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS THIS IS
LARRY MORSE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY EIGHT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND THERE
ARE CURRENTLY NO OTHERS IN THE
QUEUE THIS TIME ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU NOW HEAR FROM WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- I HAVE MARGO GEORGE
SHE PDA. M. D'AMICO ROSARIO SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
MARCO GEORGE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION REGRETTABLY WE MUST
OPPOSE AB THIRTY EIGHT AB
THIRTY EIGHT S. MOST LIKELY
UNCONSTITUTIONAL BECAUSE IT
KEEPS PEOPLE IN JAIL MERELY
BECAUSE THEY ARE POOR IT IS
FUNDAMENTALLY UNFAIR AND HARKS
BACK TO THE FAILED PUBLIC
POLICY THAT RESULTED IN MASS
INCARCERATION. AT THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT NOTED
LAST WEEK IN THE HOUSE THE
HUMPHREYRELYING ON A HARVARD
LAW SCHOOL STUDY GROWTH IN PRE
TRIAL DETENTION WAS RESPONSIBLE
FOR ALTERNET JAIL POPULATION
GROWTH IN THE LAST TWENTY YEARS.
HIGHLIGHTING THE COST TO THE
COMMUNITY THE HUMPHREY COURT
ALSO NOTED THAT JUST SIX
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES ALAMEDA
FRESNO OUR INTEREST SACRAMENTO
SAN BERNARDINO AND SAN
FRANCISCO SPENT OVER THIRTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS ON IT OVER
TWO YEAR PERIOD HOUSING AND
FEEDING PRE TRIAL DETAINEES WHO
WERE NEVER CHARGED OR HAD THEIR
CASES DISMISSED. THE UNITED
STATES DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ESTIMATE FOR KEEPING THE PRE
TRIAL POPULATION BEHIND BARS
COST AMERICAN TAXPAYERS ROUGHLY
NINE BILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR.
AB THIRTY EIGHT WON'T WASTE
CALIFORNIA'S ALREADY HIGH BAIL
AMOUNTS FOR MOST PRINTOUT
DETAINEES AND WILL
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT POOR
PEOPLE PRIMARILY BROWN OR BLACK
OR ALREADY MOST LIKELY TO BE
ARRESTED FOR MINOR OFFENSES.
BECAUSE IT'S A BILL SCHEDULE
INTO SENDING MONEY BAIL THAT IS
MORE THAN ZERO WHEN THE
INDIVIDUAL IS FIRST ARRESTED.
THEY ARE POTENTIALLY GOING TO
LOSE THEIR HOUSING THEY'RE JOHN
PERHAPS SENDING THEIR FAMILY
ANNOUNCED INTO THE STREET. THE
HUMP RECORD ALSO NOTEDTHAT
BLACK ADULTS IN SAN FRANCISCO
ARE ONLY ELEVEN TIMES AS LIKELY
AS WHITE ADULTS TO BE BOOKED
INTO THE COUNTY JAIL PRIOR TO
TRIAL. I WAS A PUBLIC DEFENDER
FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS I HAD
NUMEROUS CLIENTS SIMPLE YEARS I
CALLED TRYING TO STATE THEIR
JOBS WHILE MY CLIENTS COULDN'T
AFFORD. FIVE THOUSAND TEN
THOUSAND FIFTEEN THOUSAND OR
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLAR BAIL FOR
MISDEMEANORS. EVEN LOSING A
WEEK'S PAY THAT DEVASTATION AND
HOMELESSNESS FOR MANY OF MY
CLIENTS. WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR NOTEBOOK THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF HIS D'AMICO
REGARD KNOWLEDGE STATE POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR THE SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER THOUGHT THAT.
PRIOR TO MY CURRENT POSITION I
ESTABLISH THE MALE CLINIC AT
LAWYERS COMMITTEE FOR CIVIL
RIGHTS WHICH PIONEERED THE
APPLICATION OF CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER PROTECTION LAWS THE
BAYLON IMMIGRATION BOND
INDUSTRIES. AND PROVIDED FREE
LEGAL SERVICES PEOPLE WITH
CONSUMER JUSTICE SESSION
STEMMING FROM THEIR USE OF BAIL
AND IMMIGRATION BOND SERVICES.
AB THIRTY EIGHT MAY APPEAR TO
BE IN ALIGNMENT WITH THE
AFRICAN BAIL REFORM IN THE
STATE. BUT AS USUAL THE DEVIL'S
IN THE DETAILS. FIRST NOTHING
IN AB THIRTY EIGHT PROTECTS
AGAINST UNAFFORDABLE BAIL
AMOUNTS CONTINUING TO BE FAT A
WIDE. HAPPY EVEN MORE NOTABLY
THE MOST LIKELY TO BENEFIT FROM
THE CHANGES PROPOSED BY AB
THIRTY EIGHT IS THE BAIL BONDS
INDUSTRY. THE BAIL INDUSTRY HAS
ADVOCATED FOR A STATEWIDE BAIL
SCHEDULE BECAUSE LOWER AVAIL
AMOUNTS ARE ACTUALLY IN THEIR
FAVOR. DUE TO CALIFORNIA'S
EXTREMELY HIGH BAIL AMOUNTS
BAIL BOND COMPANIES HAVE BEEN
FORCED TO SHIFT THEIR ENTIRE
BUSINESS MODEL AND NOW
ROUTINELY OFFER CREDIT BAIL
BECAUSE PEOPLE CANNOT AFFORD TO
PAY THE 10% PREMIUM VIA THE
BAIL BONDS INDUSTRY CHARGES UP
FRONT. THEREFORE THE BAIL BOND
INDUSTRY FREQUENTLY FINANCES
THEIR BAIL BOND AGREEMENT
BREAKING UP THE DEBT AND THE
PAYMENTS TO BE MADE OVER TIME.
THIS IS PUT THEM IN THE
POSITION OF BECOMING DEBT
COLLECTION AGENCIES AND THEY
OFTEN HAVE DIFFICULTY FULLY
COLLECTING OUTSTANDING DEBT
BECAUSE THE AMOUNTS ARE SO
ASTRONOMICALLY HIGH. BUT PEOPLE
DIFFERENTLY CANNOT AFFORD TO
PAY THEM. SO IN THE INDUSTRY
BACK IN A STATEWIDE BAIL
SCHEDULE THAT ESTABLISHES
SLIGHTLY LOWER BAIL AMOUNT
MEANS MORE PEOPLE WILL BE ABLE
TO POST BAIL. USINGTHEIR
SERVICES THE INDUSTRY WILL
SPEND LESS TIME COLLECTING
OUTSTANDING DEBT AND THEREFORE
THEY MAY EVEN EARN A HIGHER
PROFIT IN THE END. THIS IS
EXACTLY WHAT THE INDUSTRY WANTS
TO SEE. AB THIRTY EIGHT
THREATENS TO MORE DEEPLY
ENTRENCHED THE BAIL BONDS
INDUSTRY IN THE STATE WHEN
INSTEAD WE MUST CONTINUE TO
ENSURE THAT PRIVATE INDUSTRY
PLAYS NO PART IN OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM WHATSOEVER. FOR
ALL THESE REASONS I URGE A NO
VOTE ON. AB THIRTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ALREADY HAVE ANY
WITNESSES AND ROOMS THAT ARE IN
OPPOSITION. ANY WITNESSES ON
THE TELECONFERENCE GREEN IN
OPPOSITION. AND EIGHTEEN T. A
TELEPHONE OPERATOR COULD YOU
BRING IN ANY ONE ON THE LINE
IT'S IN OPPOSITION. OF COURSE
OUR FIRST ONE COMES FROM THE
LINE CHIU FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CHRISTIAN
RESPONSES POLICY OF YOUR
LESSONS ON MOM PROBABLY OUR
SPEC FRIEDMAN POSITION. THANK
YOU. AND AS A REMINDER FOR ANY
THAT NEED- THAT WISH TO DO SO
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO TO
QUEUE UP OUR NEXT ONE COMES
FROM LINE TO FIFTY FOUR. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO. NOW I SEEM TO
HAVE BEEN REFINED OUR NEXT ONE
COMES A LINE OF EIGHTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS ANTHONY DIMARTINO
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE RESPECT
OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTY EIGHT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OUR NEXT
ONE COMES FROM THE LINE TO
FORTY NINE. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AS
FUNDING IS WITH ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION- RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU. ANNEXING COMES FROM
A LINE ONE FORTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBER SIDE
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
OCTOPUS EACH OF SOCIAL WORKERS
HELPING CHAPTER WANTED TO
CORRECT OUR STANCE ON THE- IF
YOU THIRTY EIGHT WE ARE AT THIS
CURRENT TIME NOT IN SUPPORT AND
WE ARE CONTINUING TO EVALUATE
MODERN. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. CONNEXXION CULTURAL
LINE UP ONE TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE JOBS BEING WITH
KNOWLEDGE AND THEN BAKER STILL
AND WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU. OUR NEXT ONE COMES
FROM A LINE ONE EIGHTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THE
NAY THAT HARD WITH LITTLE CON
BALAJI BURKE AND WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB THIRTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU. AND THERE ARE
CURRENTLY NO OTHERS IN THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
WE'LL BRING YOU BACK TO
COMMITMENT MEMBERS AND
QUESTIONS MR LACKEY. YEAH FIRST
OF ALL LET ME THANK OF THE
AUTHOR FOR ADDRESSING THE LONG
TIME PROBLEM AND BRING FORTH
WHAT WHAT I SEE IS A REASONABLE
REMEDY. BUT THERE ARE A COUPLE
POINTS THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
JUST TOUCH ON REAL QUICKLY IF
THAT'S OKAY SURE I WOULD LIKE
TO FIRST OF ALL. HOW DOES YOUR
BILL ADDRESS THREAT ASSESSMENT.
THERE'S A STILL IN THERE
BECAUSE YOU HAVE A BILL HEARING
AND- OBVIOUSLY SOMEONE'S DOING
THREATS YOU CAN ENHANCE THE
BILL THAT THE BILL IS STILL
THERE FOR THE OFFICERS. THANK
GOD THE DANGER THE PUBLIC. THE
JUDGE JUST OTHER BUILDING SO IT
DOESN'T TAKE THAT ABILITY AWAY
SO IT'S ALWAYS BEEN THERE. I
APPRECIATE HEARING THAT THE
OTHER ISSUE WAS BROUGHT FORWARD
BY- MR ARJUN IT'S A- LEGIT.
CONCERN THE RECENT US SUPREME
COURT DECISION- AND I. JUST
ANT TO GIVE YOU A CHANCE TO
TRY TO MITIGATE AND- EXPLAIN
HOW IT'S STILL CONSISTENT WITH
THAT COURT FINDING WHAT I
BELIEVE THEY'RE A LITTLE BIT
DISINGENUOUS BOTTLES ATTORNEYS
WHAT HUMPHREY SAID IS THAT NO
PERSON. SHOULD LOSE THE RIGHT
TO LIBERTY SIMPLY BECAUSE THAT
PERSON CANNOT AFFORD TO POST
BAIL. IT DID NOT MAKE CAST BILL
IN CONSTITUTIONAL JUST REAFFIRM
THAT MUST BE FAIR THAT THE
INABILITY TO POST BAIL ALONE.
CANNOT BE THE SOLE FACTOR
SETTING BILL. SB THIRTY
ACTUALLY SUPPORTS HIS DECISION
IN THIS LANGUAGE AND INTENT.
THEY CAN VIRTUALLY LOWER BILL
US BASED ACROSS THE STATE AND
LARGELY PROHIBITS BILL
STACKING. AND NO ONE WE TALKED
ABOUT THE BILL STACKING AND
WHAT IT DOES WHEN YOU'RE BOOKED
FOR TWO OR MORE FENCES. BILL
SHOULD BE SETTLED FOR THE
CHARGE WITH THE HIGHEST AMOUNT
SUCH AS ONE CHARGE. IS NOT THAT
WAY RIGHT NOW CALIFORNIA. YOU
CAN ONLY HAD HIS MEN'S ONE TIME
PER PERSON. AND ONE TIME FOR
PRIORS IT'S NOT THAT WAY RIGHT
NOW. THIS BILL WOULD NOT
PROHIBIT THE COURTS FROM
STACKING BILL IN WHICH THERE
ARE MULTIPLE VICTIMS. THEIR
SEPARATIST WAS THE CRIME OCCURS
OR SEPARATE SEX ACTS AGAINST
THE SAME VICTIM. SO IT REALLY
ACCESS RIGHT NOW WAFFLES ONE
ZERO BILL WE DON'T HAVE ZERO
BILL IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW.
IT'S CONFLICTING SOME FOLKS
WANT TO SOME FOLKS DON'T. BUT
WE DON'T HAVE IT RIGHT NOW
PRESENTLY. THANK YOU FOR THOSE
SECTION THEY JUST FOLLOWING UP.
IN THIS THIS IS. I JUST THE
REASON I MADE THIS IS. FOR
THOSE THAT FOR THOSE PUBLIC
DEFENDERS. ROBERT STILL ROBBERY
BUT IT SHOULDN'T BE. A HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS MORE
SOMEWHERE ELSE. THE ANOTHER
COUNTY THAT THAT IT THAT IS
ASININE THAT IS THAT WAY AND IT
WILL CONTINUE TO BE THAT WAY
WE'RE THIS POSITION BECAUSE OF
JUDGES AND WE'RE THE START THAT
YOU WANT TO GO BACK IN HISTORY
THE START OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
BECAUSE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WAS
TAKEN OFF AND THEY STARTED
INCREASING BILL FOR DIFFERENT
THINGS THAT'S WHEN WE SAW THE
BILL SCHEDULE INCREASED
DRAMATICALLY BECAUSE OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IT CAUGHT UP
A LOT OF OTHER THINGS AND
THAT'S THE ISSUE AND THAT
REGARDLESS IF WE IF WE STAY
STATUS QUO RIGHT NOW. AND YOU
DON'T GET A ZERO BELL. YOU'RE
STILL GONNA HAVE THE BILL MUCH
HIGHER ON THESE CHARGES THAT'S
NOT GOING TO CHANGE SO FOR SOME
OF THE CALLS A CALL THEN THAT
WERE DISINGENUOUS ABOUT THAT IT
DOES ACTUALLY CHANGE THAT PART
OF IT THAT THAT IS AN ISSUE
THAT NEEDS TO BE CHANGES SHOULD
BE FAIR NO MATTER WHAT THE OF
ROBBERS ROBBIE ABOUT RE COMMIT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU COULD- ANY.
SHARE TURKEY THANK YOU ARE WILL
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING A COMMONSENSE- REFORM
MEASURE TO THE CURRENT BAIL
SYSTEM. AND YOU KNOW WHETHER
YOU ARE FOR OR AGAINST- THE
BAIL SYSTEM. BUT HE WON
ELIMINATED COMPLETELY OR DO YOU
FEEL THAT- IT JUST NEEDS TO BE
TWEAKED- FIXING THE INHERENT
INEQUITIES IN THE CURRENT
SYSTEM OR ARGUING THAT IT. FOR
YOU CAN'T SUPPORT AN
IMPROVEMENT TO THE CURRENT BAIL
SYSTEM IT KIND OF MAKES NO
SENSE- WHAT YOU TALKED ABOUT
THERE IS AN INEQUITY WHERE IT
IT. ACTUALLY IS MORE LUCRATIVE
TO DO SOME- SOME OF CRIME- IN
ONE COMMUNITY THAN IT IS IN
ANOTHER BECAUSE OF THE BAIL
SYSTEM WE HAVE. AND THIS IS A
COMMON SENSE APPROACH TO FIXING
THAT- OTHERS WHO WANT TO HAVE
THAT OTHER GUY ARGUMENT CAN
HAVE THAT- BUT- I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THIS BECAUSE THIS MAKES
SENSE. AND THAT IT MAKES IT
EQUAL PARTS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THANK YOU. YES MISTER
MARKAY HAND THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- AND IF YOU CAN HER EIGHT
AM THANK YOU MISTER COOPER FOR
ENGAGING IN THIS IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION THAT IS MENTIONED
BY MY COLLEAGUES IT'S HAPPENING
TOO MANY BILLS THIS- THIS
LEGISLATIVE SESSION. AND YOU
KNOW. PERSONALLY I DON'T
BELIEVE IN THE MONEY WILL
SYSTEM I THINK THAT DECIDING
WHETHER SOMEONE STAYS IN JAIL
BASED ON WHETHER THEY HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO PAY BAIL ISN'T
WHAT KEEPS OUR COMMUNITIES
SAFER. I THINK IT SHOULD BE A
QUESTION OF SAFETY AND RESCUE
WHICH TO YOUR POINT IS A PART
OF THIS BUT ONLY A PART OF IT-
IT STILL COMES DOWN TO WHETHER
OR NOT ONE CAN PAY. THE BILL
THAT IS SET AND SO. I HEAR YOU
I THINK THE INEQUITY YOU
PRESENT IT IS COMPELLING AND I
pTALK ABOUT JUDICIAL DISCRETION
A LOT IN THIS COMMITTEE AND
OTHERS AND I THINK IT MAKES
SENSE FOR THE- FOR. THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO BE HAVING A
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT OUR
BELL SCHEDULE SHOULD BE ACROSS
THE STATE- MY CONCERNS WITH THE
BILL- OBVIOUSLY. TESTERS ACTORS
POINT AS WELL THAT OTHER
CONVERSATIONS HAPPENING ABOUT
WHETHER WE SHOULD HAVE MANY
BELL AT ALL AND IT'S- I BELIEVE
THE MOVE TOWARD. CONTINUING BUT
MY CONCERN IS ALSO THIS PART
WHERE YOU ARE SENDING IT AS THE
MAXIMUM OF THE TO WHICH YOUR
POINT DOES REDUCE IT FROM
STOCKING BUT IT STILL SAYS. A
LIMIT RIGHT IT'S AT THE HEIGHT
LIMIT POTENTIALLY FOR BALANCE
SO AGAIN WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
THIS SYSTEM WHERE WE SET IT AT
THE HIGHER COST OF THE CRIMES
CHARGED IN HERE SOMEBODY WHO
CAN'T PAY AND NOW THEY'RE
INCARCERATED NOT BECAUSE THE
JUDGES DECIDED. NECESSARILY
THAT THEY ARE SOMEBODY WHO
NEEDS TO BE HELD WILL BE
ARRESTED SOCIETY AND AS POINTED
OUT BY PUBLIC DEFENDERS THAT
CAN LEAD TO. THEM LOSING THEIR
JOBS AND THEIR HOMES WHILE
PENDING TRIAL EVEN IF THEY
DON'T POSE A RISK TO THE
COMMUNITY. AND SO I PERSONALLY
THINK THAT WE NEED TO GET TO A
POINT WHERE THE QUESTION BEFORE
THE COURT. ISN'T ABOUT MONEY
BUT IT IS ABOUT THE SAFETY OF
OUR COMMUNITY THE CRIMES
COMMITTED WHETHER WE BELIEVE IF
WE LET THIS PERSON ON THE
STREET OUR COMMUNITY IS LESS
CARE- AND SO I CAN'T SUPPORT
THIS TODAY BUT I DO APPRECIATE
THE CONVERSATION ANY IMPORTANT-
THE IMPORTANT PART OF THE
CONVERSATION THAT YOU RAISED
ABOUT THE INEQUITIES ACROSS
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU IN RESPONSE WHAT IT DOES
THOUGH INSISTED THAT THE YOU.
KNOW THE HIS BILL SO IT. A
WON'T BE THE HIGHEST. GOING TO
SET UP THE LOWER. SO IF THERE
IS THEY'RE SICK OF. BILL WHAT
THE- COUNCIL CAN DO. THEY CAN
SAID THAT LOWER BILL SCHEDULE
SO IN ESSENCE. IT WOULD BE
LOWER BILL SCHEDULE SO. I GUESS
PART OF THIS IS ALSO. IF ZERO
BILL DOESN'T PASS. THEN THE
OPTION IS WE'RE GONNA. REMAIN
STATUS QUO. AND IN WITH THE BIG
ISSUE IS. THE WHO'S POLICING
THE JUDGES. THE REASON WE'RE IN
THIS SITUATION. IS NOT. BECAUSE
THE PUBLIC DEFENDER'S NOT
BECAUSE DISTRICT ATTORNEYS. NOT
BECAUSE A LAW ENFORCEMENT
BECAUSE THIS LEGISLATURE. IS
BECAUSE THE JUDGES. AND JUDGES
ARE MAKING THAT DETERMINATION
EVERY YEAR THEY MAKE THAT VISIT
THAT. THE NORTH MAIN ISSUE. THE
DIFFICULTIES AWARE OF THIS IT'S
BEEN DISCUSSED. AD NAUSEAM. BUT
THE NUMBERS ARE STILL HERE SO.
IF YOU GUYS ARE OKAY WITH LIKE
I SAID ZERO STILL A LONG WAYS
AWAY FROM FROM HAPPENING. SO
THIS IS GONNA BE THE DEFAULT
RIGHT HERE AND REMAIN THE
DEFAULT. THANK YOU ENTER ANY
OTHER. COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. YOU MAY
CLOSE MISTER COOPER THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME COMMITTEE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
AND THANK YOU I'M I'M I'M
GETTING READY TO HELP YOU RIGHT
NOW MISTER COOPER- BECAUSE
YOU'RE THE FIRST ONE EVER
BROUGHT UP. I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
REMEMBER YOU BROUGHT UP THE
INEQUITIES IN THE BILL
SCHEDULES TO MEET STATEWIDE.
AND I DIDN'T REALLY EVEN KNOW
ABOUT BAIL HOW IT WAS DONE
LUCKILY- AND WHEN YOU TOLD ME
THIS AND NOW THAT I'VE SEEN IT
HERE- IT KIND OF FORCED ME TO
THE POINT WHERE I WAS AT ZERO
BAIL. WE SHOULD GET THAT'S WHEN
I WAS FOR A LONG TO GET RID OF
MONEY BAIL BECAUSE OF WHAT
YOU'VE TOLD AND NOW TO ACTUALLY
SEE IT WHERE I'M LOOKING AT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ACROSS THE
BOARD IS OFF FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS. BUT SPOUSAL BATTERY
WHAT THE HECK IS LIKE FIVE
GRAND IN SAMPOERNA DINO. I MEAN
YOU AND I MUST GOT TO AGREE TO
SOMETHING WRONG WITH THAT YES
AND THEN YOUR DOING IT AND IN
RESULT IT I AGREE WITH WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO. I JUST
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THE
METHODOLOGY. LIKE YOU TALK
ABOUT THE JUDGES BUT YOU WANT
TO SET UP A- A GROUP OF WHAT IS
IT. FOR A REPRESENTATIVE FROM
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
OF REPRESENTATIVE APPOINTED BY
THE PUBLIC DEFENDERS AND IN THE
STATE SHERIFFS THE KIND OF
OVERSEE LOOKING AT BELL
SCHEDULE UNDER YOU JUST WITH
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL I WOULD I
WOULD SUBMIT TO YOU TO
JUDICIARY DISCUSSES PROBABLY
WORST AND THE JUDGES AS FAR AS
MAKING THESE DETERMINATIONS AND
SO IS THAT METHODOLOGY THAT
DEBT THAT I HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
THE IN CROWD. I WOULD LOVE TO
CAN. I THINK WE ALL NEED TO
HAVE A SIT DOWN ON ALL OF THESE
BILL IDEAS. BECAUSE I YOU ARE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT. WE HAVE TO
FIX THE BAIL SCHEDULE AND HAVE
A FORMAL BAIL SET YOUR SCHEDULE
BEST SAYING THROUGHOUT EACH.
COUNTY CITY. BOROUGH STREET
LEVEL WHATEVER BECAUSE- THIS
IS. THIS IS JUST INSANE INSANE-
YOU KNOW FIFTY THOUSAND ALAMEDA
AND TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
SAMPOERNA DINO. FOR ARMED
ROBBERY WHY IS IT SO
SIGNIFICANT- AND SO I'M I'M
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS I'M
SORRY I CAN'T SUPPORTERS TODAY
BUT I DO BELIEVE YOU HAVE A
BALLOT. JOINT ABOUT THIS BILL
SCHEDULE AND WE DO NEED TO HAVE
FURTHER DISCUSSION BUT
UNFORTUNATELY CAN'T SUPPORTED
TODAY SIR IN JUST ONE POINT FOR
VERIFICATION THAT WOULD NOT.
THIS IS YOU KNOW WHAT AS A
COURTESY BECAUSE WE CAME INTO
USUALLY ON THE LAST ONE I'LL
LET YOU. IT ALLEGES THE COUNCIL
JUST CONSULT WITH NOT. THEY'LL
MANDATE WITH THAT A DIFFICULT
DISGRACED LOS ASIAN ABOVE
DEFENDERS OKAY CONSULTING WITH
THEM. THANK YOU FOR THE
CLARIFICATION IF YOU. THERE WE
HAVE A MOTION MOVED WELL. THE
MOTION SECOND. THE CALDERON ON
AB THIRTY EIGHT BY MISTER
COOPER THE MOTION IS TO PASS
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER UNFORTUNATELY NO
JONES SAWYER NO LACKEY LACKEY I
PARA QUE HAN PARA QUE HAN NO
COURT NO CORPS CANAL SANTIAGO
C. R. TELL YES THEY ARE TELL I
WICKS. WEEKS NOW LEE LINO. I'M
SORRY MEASURE FAILS THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU MISTER RANDALL FOR
WAITING. THANK YOU. SB SIX
HUNDRED ARAMBULA HATE CRIMES
IMMIGRATION STATUS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS BEFORE
I BEGIN MY PRESENTATION LET ME
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS TO MAKE
THIS BILL DECLARATIVE OF
EXISTING LAW AS PROPOSED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. MEMBERS AB
SIX HUNDRED PROTECTS OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL CIVIL RIGHTS BY
REITERATING CALIFORNIA'S
POSITION TO PROHIBIT CRIMES
AGAINST A PERSON COMMITTED
BECAUSE OF THE PERSON'S ACTUAL
OR ERCEIVED IMMIGRATION
STATUS. DESTRUCT THIS BERMAN
NATION AGAINST IMMIGRANTS IS
NOT A NEW PHENOMENON IN
CALIFORNIA THE STATE'S HISTORY
REVEALS AN UGLY CYCLE THAT
OFTEN REPEATS ITSELF IN PERIODS
OF NATIONAL ANXIETY PROVOKED BY
ECONOMIC RECESSION BY
UNEMPLOYMENT OR PERCEIVED
EXTERNAL THREATS. THE CHINESE
EXCLUSION ACT OF EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY TWO AND THE INTERNMENT
OF JAPANESE AMERICANS DURING
WORLD WAR TWO ARE TWO SUCH
EXAMPLES. IN THE NINETEEN
THIRTIES REPATRIATION DRIVE
SUPPORTED BY THE HOOVER
ADMINISTRATION SUBJECTED
CITIZENS AND NON CITIZENS OF
MEXICAN ANCESTRY TO
INDISCRIMINATE MASS
DEPORTATIONS. THIS SENTIMENT OF
INTOLERANCE IS ON THE RISE ONCE
MORE. WITH DAMAGING IMPACTS TO
OUR COMMUNITIES A PANDEMIC THAT
HAS TAKEN THE LIVES OF MORE
THAN FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
AMERICANS HAS SPARKED A
BACKLASH AGAINST ASIANS WHO
HAVE BEEN BLAMED FOR THE SPREAD
OF CORONAVIRUS RESULTING IN A
MARKET UPTICK IN HATE CRIMES.
IN ASIAN AMERICAN COMMUNITIES
IN THE UNITED STATES. HATE
CRIMES HAVE ALSO INCREASED IN
CALIFORNIA BY 11% SINCE TWENTY
SIXTEEN. LATINOS HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED THE MOST WITH AN
INCREASE OF MORE THAN FIFTY
PERCENT. THIS TREND IS
CONSISTENT WITH REPORTS IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WITH REPORTED AN
INCREASE OF HATE CRIMES OF 36%
BETWEEN TWENTY THIRTEEN AND
TWENTY NINETEEN. APPROXIMATELY
FORTY FOUR MILLION IMMIGRANTS
LIVE AND WORK IN THE UNITED
STATES MAKING UP THIRTEEN POINT
7% OF THE NATION'S POPULATION.
DESPITE CLEAR PROTECTIONS FOR
THESE IMMIGRANTS POP RELATIONS
FROM CRIME IN FEDERAL LAW AND
INTERNATIONAL LAW THESE
PROTECTIONS ARE NOT ALWAYS
INTERPRETED PROPERLY. INSURING
THESE IMMIGRANT POPULATIONS DO
NOT FACED HATE BASED
DISCRIMINATION WITHOUT REPRISAL
IS A KEY STEP TO SUPPORTING
THOSE ALREADY SHOULDERING
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS FROM
THIS PANDEMIC. THE RALPH CIVIL
RIGHTS ACT CIVIL CODE SECTION
FIFTY ONE POINT SEVEN CURRENTLY
INCLUDES IMMIGRANT STATUS AS A
PROTECTED CLASS IN ADDITION
MANY JURISDICTIONS IN THE STATE
INTERPRET CURRENT HATE CRIME
LAW TO COVER IMMIGRANT STATUS
AS A PROTECTED CLASS. HOWEVER
SOME JURISDICTIONS CONCLUDE
THAT THE STATE'S EXISTING HATE
CRIME STATUTE DOES NOT COVER
IMMIGRATION AND CITIZENSHIP
STATUS AS EVIDENCED BY THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN LEGISLATIVE
AUDIT REPORT ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE STATE'S
HATE CRIME STATUTE. IT IS
CRITICAL TO ENSURE THAT ALL
JURISDICTIONS UNDERSTAND THE
STATE'S POSITION WITH CRYSTAL
CLARITY THAT DISCRIMINATION
VIOLENCE OR THE THREAT OF
VIOLENCE TOWARDS ANOTHER BASED
ON IMMIGRATION STATUS IS A HATE
CRIME. HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS JOSEPH V. A. R. WITH
CHIRLA AND NO WELL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION. OF
HUMAN RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS. MR
THE AREA CONTROLLER AND- MISS
NO. WHENEVER YOU'RE READY TO
BEGIN. ALL RIGHT- GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRPERSON JONES
SAWYER VICE CHAIR LACKEY AND
MEMBERS AND STAFF OF THE
COMMITTEE I WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ARRIVAL- AND ALL
OF YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY IN FAVOR OF AB SIX
HUNDRED. MY NAME IS ANNA WELL
AND I'M NOT ON THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HUMAN RELATIONS
ORGANIZATION CAIRO A COALITION
OF THE STATE'S HUMAN RELATIONS
COMMISSION AND SIMILAR SOCIAL
JUSTICE ORGANIZATION. ONE OF
THE TASKS THAT ARE LARGER
COUNTY HUMAN RELATIONS
COMMISSION TO PERFORM IS TO
TRACK HATE CRIMES AND ISSUED
YEARLY HATE CRIMES REPORT MOST
NOTABLY THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
HUMAN RELATIONS COMMISSION
ORANGE COUNTY HUMAN RELATIONS
AND THE. SAN FRANCISCO HUMAN
RIGHTS COMMISSION. THE
STATISTIC THAT THEY- ECHO A LOT
OF WHAT DOCTOR BANGALORE JUST
SAID. FOR THE PAST FOUR YEARS
HATE CRIMES INCIDENTS HAVE
INCREASED IN CALIFORNIA. FOR
EXAMPLE HATE CRIMES REPORTED IN
L. A. COUNTY INCREASED TWO
POINT 6% IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
BALL RACIAL HATE CRIMES ROSE
11% AND COMPRISED 52% WELL HE
CRIMES IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN. L.
A. COUNTY TWENTY NINETEEN HATE
CRIMES REPORT DOCUMENTS THAT
HATE CRIMES AGAINST LATINOS.
CONSTITUTED 25% OF ALL RACIAL
HATE CRIME. AND THAT LATINOS
WERE THE MOST LIKELY OF ANY
RACIAL ETHNIC GROUPS TO BE
VICTIMS OF VIOLENT RACIALLY
MOTIVATED CRIME EIGHTY EIGHT
PERCENT. AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN
SUSPECTS USED SPECIFICALLY ANTI
IMMIGRANT WORKERS IN FORTY
EIGHT LAT CRIMES CASES. AND
ANTI ASIAN CRIME GROUPS 32% AND
ANTI MUSLIM EASTERN CRIMES ROSE
A HUNDRED AND 42% SIMILARLY A
RECENT CSU SAMBAR DINO CENTER
FOR THE STUDY OF HATE AND
EXTREMISM STUDY SHOWED AN
INCREASE IN ANTI ASIAN HATE
CRIMES REPORTED TO POLICE. IN
EIGHTEEN LARGE AMERICAN CITY
INCLUDING OURS IN CALIFORNIA.
FROM TWENTY NINETEEN TO TWENTY
TWENTY. EXPERTS HATE CRIMES ARE
WIDELY UNDER REPORTED AND EVEN
WHEN THEY ARE POLICE OFFICERS
SOMETIMES FEEL TO DOCUMENT
INCIDENTS INVOLVING BIAS IS THE
HATE CRIME. AB SIXTEEN HUNDRED
IS NEEDED AS A CLARIFIED THAT
THE CURRENT HATE CRIME STATUTE
IS INCLUSIVE OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS. THE BILL WILL
EXPLICITLY CONFORM THE CRIMINAL
LAW AND PENAL CODE SECTION FOR
TWENTY TWO POINT FIVE SIX. WITH
A COMPARABLE CIVIL LAW UNDER
THE REST OF A RIGHTS ACT THAT
CIVIL CODE SECTION FIFTY ONE
pTHAT THEM. STATUS IF COVERED.
WE BELIEVE A. B. B. SIX HUNDRED
IT'S IMPORTANT TO PROVIDE
PROTECTION FOR IMMIGRANTS WHO
ARE HATE CRIMES VICTIMS AND
HESITANT TO REPORT CRIMES AND
FOR PEACE OFFICERS THAT MAY BE
UNSURE IF AN ATTACK OF AN
INDIVIDUAL BASED ON AN ACTUAL
OR PERCEIVED NOTION OF
CITIZENSHIP COUNTY OF THE HATE
CRIME. WE RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU
TO VOTE YES ON EIGHTY SIX
HUNDRED. THANK YOU. BANK ACTION
ALL AND CARE. A MENTAL OKAY
COMMITTEE I WAS JUST OF GEL
ADDRESS OUR POLICY ADVOCATE TO
CHECK OUT THE COALITION HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS. WE APOLOGIZE
MAYBE MAYBE HUNDRED AND WE-
ALIGN OUR I SENT WITH THE
PREVIOUS- THAT'S BECAUSE MOST
OF WITH THE IF STATEMENT SO- A
DOCTOR HAVE A LOT. ADDING TO
THAT IS GOOD TO KNOW THAT AIM
TO THINK TWENTY TWENTY THAT
SOUTHERN POVERTY LAW CENTER
INDICATED AND TRACK SEVENTY TWO
ORGANIZED HATE GROUPS IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS INCREASE FROM
PREVIOUS YEARS APPLE WAIT THEY
LACK OF TRANSAMERICA ALL
REPORTING CRIMES IN ADDITION TO
ATTEMPT A LACK OF CLARITY. SB
SIX HUNDRED IT'S IMPORTANT TO
PROVIDE PROTECTIONS FOR
IMMIGRANTS. WHO MIGHT BE
VICTIMS OF CRIME BUT THEN ALSO
INSURANCE THAT I OWE FIFTY
COUNTY HAVE A UNIFORMLY ON
SEPARATE CARRILLO AFTER ALL
THOSE REASONS RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST. YOUR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY. I ANY WITNESSES. AND
THE HEARING IT'S A- ANY
WITNESSES ON THE- VIDEO-
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATE COULD YOU
UP- ABC HUNDRED SUPPORT. ON THE
PHONE- AND MIGHT EVEN GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR
EIGHTY SIX HUNDRED PRESS ONE
THEN THERE ARE NOW AGAIN FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF. EIGHTY SIX
HUNDRED ONE THEN ZERO NOW. AND
WE DO HAVE TO AND MAKE YOU LOOK
FOR GOAL TO LINE SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE CALL HAD. HELLO HELLO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY MY NAME
IS TARUN CURRY I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF UNITED BROWN
COALITION AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF AB SIX HUNDRED. THANK YOU
SIR. AND AXOLOTL NINE ONE FORTY
TWO PLEASE CALL I HAD. HELLO
I'M NICHOLAS GONZALEZ YOU THE
CALIFORNIA CIVIL LIBERTIES
ADVOCACY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE ONE MORE
IN THE QUEUE OF ALL TRYING TO
SIXTY THREE PLEASE CALL I HAD.
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES CAN HI MY
NAME IS MEGAN HEALY I'M FROM
SAN JOSE WITH SOME OF THE STATE
AND I SUPPORT EIGHTY SIX. FIFTY
FIVE. THANK YOU. RIGHT PRESS AT
THAT TIME. GO AHEAD IF NO ONE
ELSE THANK YOU PRESENTLY I
THINK MAYBE I'LL AND I'LL THANK
YOU OKAY RIGHT NOW I SEE NO
OPPOSITION WITNESSES- BUT I
WILL GO AHEAD MASS ORDER ANY
OPPOSITION. IN THE ROOM ANY
OPPOSITION ON THE
TELECONFERENCING MONITOR AND
AGAIN AT&T ARE THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO AB SIX HUNDRED
THAT ARE ON THE PHONE. AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO OPPOSE AB THAT KINDER
IT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW
AGAIN TO UPHOLD AB. SIX HUNDRED
ONE AND THEN ZERO NOW. AND
THERE'S NO ONE IN THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU WE'LL BRING YOU BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE OUR ANY
QUESTIONS OF FOR MR ARAMBULA.
SEEING NONE- YOU MAY CLOSE
MISTER RAMYA. TACTFULLY ASK FOR
AN ITEM THANK YOU CHAIR
pTO BILLS AND PROBABLY WITHIN
SECONDS SO WE CAN GO AHEAD AND
VOTE ON AB SIX HUNDRED BY SOME
MEMBER ARAMBULA. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER HI BLACKIE
BLACKIE I BARRICADE HAND THERE
CAN I A CORK ALL RIGHT QUICK I
SAN DIEGO SAN DIEGO I SEE ARE
TO. C. R. TURNOUT VOTING WICKS.
WICKS I'D LI. LI I. M. THANK
YOU THE MEASURE PASSES THANK
YOU MISTER. TO AND. I DON'T
KNOW THREE MISTER CARILLO AB.
NINE SEVEN. THAT WOULD BE
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT I'D
ITEM NUMBER THREE. THANK YOU
MAY BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
MISS KOREA. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I AM PROUD TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
THREE SEVEN THE VISION ACT
WHICH WOULD PROTECT REFUGEE AND
IMMIGRANT CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE
BEEN TO DEEMED ELIGIBLE FOR
RELEASE FOR BEAN FROM BEING
FUNNELED INTO IMMIGRATION
DETENTION BY CALIFORNIA. LOCAL
JAILS AND PRISONS THESE ARE
CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE COMPLETED
THEIR TIME EARNED PAROLE OR
HAVE THEIR SENTENCES COMMUTED
BY THE GOVERNOR AFTER A CLOSE
REVIEW OTHER CLEMENCY
APPLICATION WHEN LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION ASSIST WITH
TRANSFERS OF THESE INDIVIDUALS
TO ICE. THE IGNORE THEIR RECORD
OF REHABILITATION STABLE
REENTRY PLAN AND THEIR NETWORK
OF COMMUNITY AND FAMILY
SUPPORT. MANY CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES INCLUDING LOS ANGELES
SANTA CLARA SAN FRANCISCO AND
CONTRA COSTA HAVE RECOGNIZED
THIS AND HAVE HALTED OR CUT
BACK ON TRANSFERS TO
IMMIGRATION OFFICIALS ONCE
SOMEONE HAS SERVED THEIR TIME.
MEMBERS IF NOT IF NOT FOR WHERE
THESE INDIVIDUALS WERE BORN
THEY WOULD BE ALLOWED TO RETURN
HOME TO THEIR FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES AB NINE THREE SEVEN
WILL MOVE OUR STATE CLOSER TO
FULFILLING ITS COMMITMENT TO
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS AND CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM. WE RECOGNIZE
THAT OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM IS
DISPROPORTIONATELY AND HAS
DISPROPORTIONATELY HARM BLACK
LATINO INDIGENOUS AND AAPI
COMMUNITIES IN RECENT YEARS THE
LEGISLATURE IN CALIFORNIA
VOTERS HAVE DEMONSTRATED A
COMMITMENT AND A WILLINGNESS TO
REFORM OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM AND END MASS
INCARCERATION. HOWEVER FOR
IMMIGRANTS WHO HAVE EARNED
THEIR RELEASE THIS JUST MEANS
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE HANDED
OVER TO ICE AND FACE PERMANENT
SEPARATION FROM THEIR FAMILIES
AND COMMUNITIES ONE MAY SAY
THAT THIS BILL WOULD INTERFERE
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S
EXCLUSIVE ABILITY TO REGULATE
IMMIGRATION HOWEVER. THE TENTH
AMENDMENT OF THE UNITED STATES
CONSTITUTION UNEQUIVOCALLY
GIVES CALIFORNIA THE AUTHORITY
TO NOT ALLOW OUR STATE
RESOURCES TO BE USED IN
ASSISTING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WITH ENFORCING.
IMMIGRATION LAW JUST LAST WEEK
A WOMAN FROM ALL MONEY NAME
GABBY SOLANO WAS TRANSFERRED BY
THE DIFFERENT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
TO ICE. GABBY CAME TO THIS
COUNTRY WHEN SHE WAS JUST TWO
YEARS OLD AS A LAWFUL PERMANENT
RESIDENT SHE IS A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SURVIVOR AND SPENT
HALF HER LIFE BEHIND BARS. FOR
A CRIME COMMITTED BY HER EX
ABUSIVE PARTNER. AFTER SERVING
TWENTY YEARS IN STATE PRISON
GOVERNOR BROWN COMMUTED HER
SENTENCE IN RECOGNITION OF HER
DEMONSTRATED RECORD OF
COMMITMENT TO SERVICE.
MENTORSHIP AND REHABILITATION
HOWEVER. RATHER THAN ALLOW
GABBY TO RETURN HOME TO HER
FAMILY IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA A
PRIVATE COMPANY CONTRACTED WITH
ICED PICKED HER UP FROM THE CDC
OUR FACILITY IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. AND TRANSPORTED HER TO
A DETENTION CENTER IN COLORADO
WHERE SHE REMAINS TODAY.
IMMIGRANT CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE
SERVED OUT THEIR SENTENCES OR
HAVE OTHERWISE BEEN DEEMED
ELIGIBLE FOR RELEASE SHOULD NOT
FACE A SECOND PUNISHMENT. WE
SHOULD NOT FUNNEL TEM INTO A
FEDERAL IMMIGRATION DETENTION
AND DEPORTATION SYSTEM. THE
VISION ACT WILL AND ICE
TRANSFERS FROM OUR LOCAL JAILS
AND CDCR A PRACTICE THAT TREATS
PEOPLE DIFFERENTLY. BASED ON
WHERE THEY WERE BORN. I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFFER WORKING WITH MY OFFICE
ON THIS BILL AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AS THIS MOVE
FORWARD. AVAILABLE TO TESTIFY
OVER THE PHONE IT SUPPORT OUR
TO INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE BEEN
DIRECTLY IMPACTED JOE MAKE HERE
WHO WAS TRANSFERRED TO ICE
AFTER SERVING TEN YEARS AND
EARNING PEARL. AND MUDDIER LUNA
WHO WAS FOUND SUITABLE FOR
PAROLE AND GRANTED RELEASE
AFTER SERVING TWENTY THREE
YEARS BUT WAS TRANSFERRED TO
ICE IN HER RELEASE DATE AND
SPENT ANOTHER SEVEN MONTHS. AND
AN ICE DETENTION. ADDITIONALLY
AND CHAN THE SENIOR POLICY
DIRECTOR AND SENIOR STAFF
ATTORNEY WITH THE ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE ARE
BILL SPONSOR IS ALSO ON THE
LINE TO ANSWER ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND WITNESSES HAVE DISTRIBU
HAVE FIVE MINUTES- COMBINED
SOFTWARE WHERE YOU WANT TO
SPLIT IT UP WE WILL GO WITH
THEM- MISTER ME HE A AND MISS
LUNA FOR THEIR TESTIMONY PLACE
THANK YOU AND MISS CHANNELS
AVAILABLE JUST TO SIMPLY ANSWER
QUESTIONS AS NEEDED. PERFECT.
AT&T YOU LET THE MEN. HAVE A
MASTER NEAR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GREETINGS MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JOE
MEDIA I WAS RECENTLY RELEASED
FROM DETENTION IN JULY TWENTY
TWENTY I'M AN INSTRUCTOR IN
SALINAS AND EACH BUILDING
MAINTENANCE THE FARMWORKERS
INFORMALLY INCARCERATED
STUDENTS WHO ARE SEEKING A
BETTER FUTURE I AM ALSO
STUDYING TO BECOME A SUBSTANCE
ABUSE TREATMENT COUNTER
HARTNELL COLLEGE. MY PARENTS
FLED FROM THE CIVIL WAR IN EL
SALVADOR AFTER ONE OF MY UNCLES
WAS KILLED BY THE GOVERNMENT
AND THE REST OF MY FAMILY WAS
THREATENED WHILE FLEEING TO THE
U. S. MY PARENTS WERE ROBBED
THE MEXICAN FORCE TO RECUPERATE
FOR A FEW YEARS MY SISTER AND I
WERE BORN IN MEXICO WHEN I WAS
FOUR I ARRIVED IN THE U. S.
WITH MY FAMILY. GROWING UP IN
WAKANDA CALIFORNIA WE HAD IT
ROUGH MY PARENTS WORK MULTIPLE
JOBS JUST TO MAKE ENDS MEET THE
ABSENT THAT ONE CREATED A BOY
WHICH WAS EVENTUALLY KILLED BY
FRIENDS WHO WERE INVOLVED IN
GANGS AND DRUGS IN THE
NEIGHBORHOODS AT THE AGE OF
TWENTY FOUR I WOULD GO TO
PRISON FOR ARMED ROBBERY.
DURING MY INCARCERATION I
FOCUSED ON MY EDUCATION AND
REHABILITATION I ATTENDED MANY
SELF HELP GROUPS THAT PAINT MY
GED AND GRADUATED FROM COLLEGE
AS A PARALEGAL I DID THIS WHILE
MAINTAINING STEADY JOBS FOR THE
END OF MY SENTENCE AFTER
SERVING TEN YEARS I'VE LEARNED
THAT C. T. R. WOULD BE HANDING
OVER THE ITEMS THAT HAVE BEEN
IN THE RETURN HOME TO MY FAMILY.
THEY SHOT ME I HAD NO IDEA WHAT
WOULD AWAIT ME AND I AM JUST
FOR NEARLY THREE YEARS THAT
WOULD BE LIVING IN THREE
DIFFERENT I THINK JESSICA
SEVENTY AND CAL. WELL DETAINED
IN ICE AND YUBA COUNTY JAIL I
NOTICED THE INHUMANE CONDITIONS
AT ITS WORST GROSS NEGLECT IN
EVERY ASPECT WE COULD EVEN GET
BASIC CLEANING SUPPLIES OR
PERSONAL HYGIENE PRODUCTS FIRST
TREATED I BEGAN TO ORGANIZE THE
HUNGER STRIKE ONE OF THE FIRST
OF MANY STATEWIDE HUNGER STRIKE
IN HOPES OF BETTER CONDITIONS.
ON JULY TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY
TWENTY I WAS GIVEN BACK MY
FREEDOM WITH THE HELP OF
ADVOCATES WHO FOUGHT FOR ME THE
VISION ACT EIGHTY NINE THIRTY
SEVEN IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT TO
ME AND SO MANY OTHERS WHO ARE
HANDED FROM CDC ARE TOO
HORRIFIC I THINK PENSION PLANS
I WOULDN'T WANT ANYONE TO ENJOY
THE HUMID CONDITIONS THAT GIVE
ME NIGHTMARES TO THIS DAY MANY
OF US HAVE MADE. AND HAVE PAID
OUR THIS BY MAKERS PAY TO
PLEASE VOTE YEAH. ON VISION ACT
AND- ICE TRANSFER STOP SEPARATE
FAMILIES AND STUFF. HUMAN TOLL
OF THE- AND CAL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO. AND SO LUNA
YOU'RE ON THE LINE PRESS STAR
THEN. YOU DON'T CHILL THEIR ON
THE CALL AS A SPEAKER AGAIN IF
YOU ON THE LINE SORRY FERAL MS
LUNA IS ON SAME LINE AS MISS-
OKAY. HELLO WE'RE ALL TO THE
NEXT- RIGHT NOW THIS BILL.
HELLO IT IS FROM HERE I'M HERE
YES. GREAT HELLO. ARE YOU ARE
YOU SHARE YOUR MONEY YEAH. GOOD
AFTERNOON CAN EVERY HEAR ME YES
WE CAN. HELLO OKAY SORRY- GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE SAY
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS. I'M NOT
THE- MY MOTHER IMMIGRATED TO
CAL. FROM THE TO HAVE A BETTER
LIFE WITH ME AND MY FATHER WHO
IS NATIVE HAWAIIANS I GREW UP
IN A VIOLENT AND IMPOVERISHED
NEIGHBORHOODS IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND WITHOUT ADEQUATE FAMILY
SUPPORT BECAUSE MY PARENTS
WORKED LONG HOURS. ALSO WAS
MOLESTED A FAMILY FRIEND AS A
CHILD AT NINETEEN YEARS OLD I
FIND MYSELF ARRESTED. AND TO
SERVE LIFE IN PRISON DURING MY
INCARCERATION I PARTICIPATED IN
VARIOUS SELF HELP GROUPS TO
CHALLENGE MYSELF TO GAIN
INSIGHT AND AWARENESS TO CHANGE
MY THOUGHT PROCESS. THE GROUP
HELP THE GROUP THE GIVING SELF
WORK I'VE DONE FOR MANY YEARS
HAS ALLOWED ME TO GROW INTO THE
WOMAN I AM TODAY I GRADUATED
FROM THE FENDER MENTOR
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM AND
BECAME A CERTIFIED SUBSTANCE
ABUSE COUNSELOR. AFTER TWENTY
THREE YEARS OF INCARCERATION
OUTCOMES SALUDABLE AND GRANTED
PAROLE HOWEVER ON WHAT WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE OUR FIRST DAY OF
FREEDOM. ABC ARE INSTEAD
TRANSFERRED ME TO AYE. DESPITE
ENTERING THE U. S. AS A
PERMANENT RESIDENT AND ISSUED A
GREEN CARD I WOULD BE PAYING
FOR ABOUT SEVEN MONTHS AT
ADELANTO DETENTION FACILITY AND
SAMPOERNA DINO COUNTY. WHILE I
WAS HEALTHCARE I CAN ONLY
DESCRIBE THE EXPERIENCE THAT I
ENCOUNTERED AS MOST DEGRADING
AND INHUMANE. IF IT WASN'T FOR
MY STRONG FAITH IN MY HIGHER
POWER I WOULD HAVE TAKEN MY OWN
LIFE BECAUSE I FIGURED IF I WAS
TO BE DEPORTED I'D BE DEAD.
ANYWAY TODAY ON THE COURT
MEMBER AT HOMEBOY IN THIS LAST.
I WORKING ATTACK TO REMOVE A- I
AM ALSO WAITING CLEARANCE I CAN
PAY. START WORKING I AM FOUNDER
WHICH AT THE COW. CERTIFY
SUBSTANCE ABUSE. I HAVE ALL
BONTA TO CAN BOTH. OUTREACH FOR
A PAIR. THE BIG ACT EIGHTY NINE
THIRTY SEVEN SIX AND TO ME
BECAUSE NOT ONLY WOULD IT HELP
IMMIGRANTS AND REFUGEES TO
REUNIFY WITH OUR FAMILY. IT
WILL ALSO ALLOW TO BE OF
SERVICE TO OUR COMMUNITY IN
CALIFORNIA. SO MANY PEOPLE LIKE
MYSELF HAVE SPENT DECADES
DECADES WORKING ON OURSELVES TO
HEAL AND GROW AND EARN
VOCATIONAL CERTIFICATION.
LICENSES AND AGREED SO THAT WE
CAN ONLY SO NOT ONLY CAN WE
PROVIDE STABILITY FOR OURSELVES
IN OUR FAMILY BUT ALSO BE AN
ASSET. TO AND PRODUCTIVE.
MEMBERS IN OUR COMMUNITIES I
URGE YOU TO VOTE YES. FOR THE
VISION ACT WHICH WILL ALSO
ALLOW SO MANY OF US TO HAVE
THIS SECOND CHANCE TO MAKE
AMENDS ARCHIMEDES. AND REUNIFY
WITH OUR FAMILIES. AS WELL
START A NEW LIFE. THANK YOU FOR
HEARING MY CAT TODAY HI. THANK
YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN. IN THE
R. FORTY TWO OH TWO IN
OPPOSITION C. NINE ANY
WITNESSES ON THE
TELECONFERENCING VIDEO LINE
HEARING NONE RECEIVE NONE- AT&T.
THE LINE IS NOW OPEN FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. AND MAYBE
EVEN GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR A BI NINE
THIRTY SEVEN PRESS THE ONE THEN
ZERO NOW AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT
FOR AB NINE THREE SEVEN ONE
THEN ZERO NOW. ONLY DO YOU HAVE
ABOUT TWENTY EIGHT AND LIKE YOU
GLOBAL CAROLINE NINETY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS ERIC MORTON SMITH
AND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
PAUL BLAKE AND THE ALLIANCE
REPORT MEN OF COLOR WE ARE
COSPONSORED THE BILL AND OUR
STRONG SUPPORT OF IT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. MAXIMO TO LINE ONE
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MAXIMO CAROLINE ONE SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE CALL I HAD. ALSO WITH
THE ADJUSTERS COLLISION
DIRECTLY IMPACTED STRONG
SUPPORT AS A CO SPONSOR. THANK
YOU BACK NO MORE TO LINE ONE
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE DANGER CALLING ON BEHALF
NATIONAL OF SOCIAL CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MAXIM OF TRYING
Q. SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE CALL I
HAD. HAPPY SHARONDA HAPPEN YOU
FEEL YOU CALIFORNIA ACTION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
MAXIMO'S TO LINE TWO SEVENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS CLARISSA FACT
TODAY ON BEHALF OF RESTORE
JUSTICE ONE OF THE CO SPONSORS
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. MAXIM OF THE LINE ONE
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THERE THIS IS PAM CALLING ON
OUTLOOK ASIANS AND THEIR
SUPPORT COMMITTEES WHERE
COSPONSORED WITH STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE VISION THAT. THANK YOU
MAXIM OF TIELINE TWO SEVENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MAXIMO
CAROLINE TO SEVENTY SEVEN
PLEASE WELL I HAD. HI THIS IS
POLITICALLY LIBERAL WITH THE
ORANGE COUNTY EQUALITY
COALITION SUPPORTING
ORGANIZATION IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MAXIMO CAROLINE SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE CALL HAD. HELLO YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU HELLO. OKAY HI
THIS IS HOW LONG CARILLO AND-
BEHALF OF UNITED BROWN
COALITION IS STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. MAXIMO TIELINE TWO
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE CALL I HAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ALLISON TANNER PASTOR OF LAKE
SHORE AVENUE BAPTIST CHURCH AND
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MAXIMO CAROLINE Q. EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE CALL I HAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS SALLY CHAIN
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
SOUTHEAST ASIA RESOURCE ACTION
CENTER SHE WRAPPED IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NOT THE ONE MOTEL NINE ONE OH
NINE PLEASE WELL I HAD. YES
THIS IS TRACING CHRISM BURKE
CALLING ON BEHALF OF OAKLAND
PRIVACY TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR A BI NINE THREE
SEVEN. THANK YOU. MAXIMO
CAROLINE TO NINETY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS NEED NOW WITH
CENTRAL COAST ALLIANCE UNITED
FOR A SUSTAINABLE ECONOMY ****
A CO SPONSOR AND STRONG
SUPPORTER THE VISION THANK YOU.
MAXIMAL TIELINE ONE FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE CALL I HAD. CANACCORD
ARE MALE ON THE HAPPENED SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE PROUD CO SPONSORS IN
STRONG SUPPORT. MAXIMO TIELINE
TO NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS JIM
LINDBERG ON CALLING ON BEHALF
OF A FRIEND COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION TO CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB NINE THREE
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR
MAXIM. TWO NINETY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD- CAL POLY WITH COURAGE
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MAXIMO CAROLINE TO
TWENTY FIFTEEN IF I HAD. M.
THIS IS PAM FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR WOMEN PRISONERS
WE ARE CO SPONSORED. AB ONE
NINE NINE SEVEN AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. SIX MAXIM OF
TIELINE TWO EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON VERY
LITTLE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
DRESSES IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MAXIM OF TIELINE ONE SEVENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO RYAN
ONE SEVEN SIX CAROLINA OPEN.
ONE WEEK HEAR YOU. ALL RIGHT.
ANYTHING ELSE THAT'S THAT WE
HAVE WOULD BE BUT SOMEONE THEIR-
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU MISTER. MATT
MULTILINE AB THREE WHAT. THIS
IS LISA BENNETT ON BEHALF OF
ICE OF MARIN A CLOSE BY OF THE
BILL WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
DIVISION ACT. YEAH MAX CAROLINE
Q. THIRTY ONE CLEAVED AHEAD.
HELLO YOU MAY BE ADDING LINE IS
OPEN. THIS IS A FULL GRAYSON ON
BEHALF OF THE YELTSIN CENTRE
ALKYL FINANCES AND STOP THE
PORT OF THE VISION- THANK YOU.
DORMA GOING TO CLAW BACK SOME
OF TIMELINE. ONE FORTY NINE
PEOPLE HAD. HI THIS IS CRAIG
SCOTT WITH DESERT SUPPORT FOR
THAILAND SPEAKERS AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE VISION
ACT. MAXIMO CAROLINE ONE SIXTY
PLEASE CALL HAD. COOLEY DEALS
MARKING FROM I THOUGHT A
CALIFORNIA LOS ANGELES NINE
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
MAXIMO TO LINE THREE OH ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HE LINE THREE
OH ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS LEON OR TO ME ADVOCATE
WITH THE ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING AGE THE ROCKET THERE
ARE A PART BECAUSE SPONSOR OF
THE VISION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND ACCESSIBLE TO LINE TO AB
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MANY MCCARTY
NOT ALREADY YES I WITH THE LONG
BEACH EMIGRATE RIGHT COALITION
AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORTER OF
THE VISION ACT. NOT SOME OF THE
LINE THREE HUNDRED PLEASE CALL
HAD. HI THIS IS THE LARGEST
SOME CALLING FROM THE CENTER
CON IN POWERING REFUGEES AND
IMMIGRANTS WE ARE PROUD PULSE
MONSTERS FOR THE VISION THAT.
THANK YOU. MAXIMAL TIELINE ONE
ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE
ONE ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ON BEHALF OF NATION'S FASTEST
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THAT WILL MULTI LINE EIGHTY ONE
LEAVE BEHIND. ALL POLL MARCO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDER CHESTERFIELD SHANNON
FONG THE FOURTEENTH CONVENTION
AT. MAXIMAL CAROLINA ONE
THIRTEEN PEOPLE HAD. HI THIS IS
DIRECTO WHEN THE ORANGE
REGISTER SPONSOR NETWORK AND
RESILIENCE ORANGE COUNTY IN
SUPPORT OF THE VISION ACT.
MAXIMO TO LINE ONE TWELVE LEAVE
BEHIND. HI THIS IS TAMMY FROM
THE JUSTICE REINVESTMENT
COALITION OF ALAMEDA COUNTY IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
MAXIMO TIELINE THREE OH SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS OFFENDER DOWN BOBBY HAUCK
OF THE FUTURE TO FUND A CALLING
TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THE VISION ACT THANK YOU.
MAXIM OF THE LINE THREE OH NINE
PLEASE CALL I HAD. INTERAC
AMERICAN CALLING ON BEHALF OF
FREEDOM FOR IMMIGRANTS HAD CO
SPONSORED DIVISION. THANK YOU.
MAXIM CAROLINE THREE TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
GREAT MAY ARE CALLING ON BEHALF
OF HUMAN RIGHTS WATCH A
PASSCODE FOR YOUR BUSINESS.
THANK YOU. STE MAXIMAL TIELINE
THREE THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS BATTLING
COOPER FROM NIELSEN MARKET MAR
ON BEHALF OF COUNTY OKAY. GO IN
PART TOWARD. YEAH OKAY RIGHT.
BUT HOUSE MAX IN LINE THREE
TWENTY PLEASE WELL I HAD A SURE.
SEVEN WE'VE BEEN ARE GOING IS
ANYTHING THE THIS PROBLEM IN
THE BOARD OF THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. MAXIM TIME THIRTY
TWO THREE PLEASE CALL HAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LOOK I'M
WITH WHEN THE NO IN VENTURA
COUNTY CALLING TO OF FOR THE
THAT. MAX MORE ON THREE FIVE
PLEASE CLASS. MAXIMO TO LINE
THREE EIGHT PEOPLE ARE SORRY
ONE EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
AGAIN ONE EIGHTEEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME BACK HARD
WITH SILICON VALLEY DE BUG AND
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE VISION THAT. MAXIM OF
CAROLINE THREE THIRTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
MIA THIRTY SON OF CORA AND I AM
AND WITH COMMUNITY LEGAL
SERVICES THEY NEED ALL ALSO AND
WE'RE STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
RIGHT NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RIGHT NINE EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU RYAN
THREE TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE THREE EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LEVINE TO WRITING CHIU
FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SHARE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
AT FUNDING YES WITH ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M NINE ONE SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
CHARLES JOSEPH ON BEHALF OF
INTERFAITH MOVEMENT FOR HUMAN
INTEGRITY WE ARE PROUD CO
SPONSORS OF THE VISION THAT.
THANK YOU THANK. ZERO NINE
THREE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BACKSTOPS MEN ON BEHALF
OF BEND THE ARC CALIFORNIA
JEWISH PARTNERSHIP FOR JUSTICE
AND YOUR AND STRONG SUPPORT
ADDITION ACT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT THREE FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE THREE
FOUR ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
THREE FORTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FIVE THE END FOR THAT
THE JUSTIFICATION MARKAKIS WE
WANT TO MENTION THAT ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY SUPPORTS
IT'S A JOINT EFFORT OF THE
BANKING ACCOUNT SECOND LET LOS
ANGELES. AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THREE FORTY PLEASE
AHEAD. HI THIS IS CHRISTMAS
UPON MEMBER MIDDLE RESOURCE
CENTER AND STRONG SUPPORTER
DIVISION NOT. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT ONE TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE ONE TWO ZERO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUR OTHER
ANY. IN OPPOSITION I THINK I
HAVE- COREY SELVES ELLO
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION AND JONATHON
FELDMAN CALIFORNIA POLICE
CHIEFS ON THE PHONE IN
OPPOSITION. NEARLINE THEY'RE
OPEN. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CORY CELLS- ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION
REGRETTABLY HERE IN OPPOSITION
TO AB NINE THREE SEVEN- WE WERE
CONCERNED THAT THIS BILL WOULD
FURTHER IMPEDE LAW ENFORCEMENT
COORDINATION- WITH OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT- THIS AGENCIES WHEN
IT COMES TO MATTERS OF PUBLIC
SAFETY AS WE STATED IN THE
CONTEXT OF THE DEBATE ABOUT SB
FIFTY FOUR SHARES DO NOT
UNDERTAKE IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT. THAT SAID MANY
COUNTIES MAKE PUBLIC
INFORMATION ABOUT PERSONS
DETAINED IN JAILS FOR SEVERAL
REASONS ALSO STATE AND LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES MAY BE
ASKED TO PROVIDE SAFETY SUPPORT
FOR ARRESTS UNDERTAKEN BY OTHER
AGENCIES MAYBE NINE THIRTY
SEVEN WOULD ELIMINATE THE
ABILITY OF LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
DO EITHER OF THOSE THINGS IF
THE ACTION HAPPEN TO INCLUDE AN
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT PURPOSE.
FURTHER ELIMINATING THE
REQUIREMENT THAT OFFENDERS
PLACE OF BIRTH BE INCLUDED IN
BASIC INFORMATION STORED IN
STATE OR LOCAL CRIMINAL
OFFENDER RECORD INFORMATION
SYSTEMS. WILL MAKE THAT
INFORMATION LESS ACCURATE AND
LESS USEFUL TO THE STAKEHOLDERS
WHO RELY UPON THAT INFORMATION.
THE RESPECTIVE OF WHETHER THE
PERSON IS SUBJECT TO ANY
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT ACTION.
FOR THESE REASONS PLUS THE FACT
THAT THIS BILL UNDER AS MANY OF
THESE NEGOTIATED PROVISIONS. OF
THE FINAL VERSION OF SB FIFTY
FOUR. WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE
BILL THANK YOU. OUR NEXT. YEAH
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
JONATHON FELDMAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN OPPOSITION
AS MY COLLEAGUE STATED THE
VISION ACT EXPLICITLY
UNDERMINES THE COMPROMISE
REACHED IN SB FIFTY FOUR THE
SANCTUARY STATE LAW I THAT WAS
TRAPPED IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN- AB
NINETY SEVEN DALY TAKES US BACK
TO DAY ONE. AND THAT DEBATE AND
FOR THOSE EITHER REMEMBER THAT
DEBATE IT WAS A VERY THOROUGH
COMPREHENSIVE DISCUSSION ABOUT
SETTING RULES. AND RESTRICTIONS
ON LAW ENFORCEMENT ENGAGEMENT
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT
PURPOSES- THAT DEBATE IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN ENDED WITH THE POLICE
SHE'S BEEN THE ONLY LAW
ENFORCEMENT GROUPS THAT GO
NEUTRAL. NEGOTIATE A COMPROMISE
THAT SET PRETTY CLEAR LIMITS
ON. RESPONDING TO ICE REQUESTS
FOR HOLDS- SHARING INFORMATION
ON LOW LEVEL OFFENSES ARE YOU
CANNOT DO IT FOR ANY- LOW LEVEL
MISDEMEANOR ANY PROP FORTY
SEVEN CRIMES- WE AGREED TO A
FIFTEEN YEAR WASHOUT PERIOD FOR
JAIL FELONIES BUT YOU STILL ARE
ABLE TO SHARE INFORMATION ON
SERIOUS AND VIOLENT FELONIES-
WE ALSO AGREED TO PRETTY- THE
SIGNIFICANT PROVISIONS THAT
ALLOWED. LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES TO PARTICIPATE IN TASK
FORCES WITH OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS AS LONG AS THE PRIMARY
PURPOSE OF THE JOINT. TASK
FORCE IS NOT IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT- THROUGHOUT THIS WE
HAVE LOCAL AND STATE AGENCIES
PARTNERING WITH FEDERAL
AGENCIES ON. ANTI TERRORISM
TASK FORCE- I WAS GOING AFTER
MAJOR INTERNATIONAL CARTELS AND
HUMAN TRAFFICKERS THEY DO USE
IMMIGRATION- VIOLATIONS TO GO
AFTER SOME OF THE SHOCK COLLARS
IN THE MAJOR CRIME SYNDICATES-
THE EXAMPLE WE ALWAYS GIVE A
SIMILAR TO YOU KNOW HOW THE IRS
WENT AFTER CAPONE. THEY USE
THOSE TYPES OF VIOLATIONS TO GO
AFTER SOME OF THE REALLY BAD
ACTORS- THOSE AMENDMENTS WERE
ALL AGREED TO AND YOU KNOW LIKE
I SAID IT'S- ABOUT NINE MONTH
PERIOD NEGOTIATIONS AND
DISCUSSIONS- AND UNFORTUNATELY
THIS BILL EXPLICITLY UNDERMINES
ALL OF THAT- MINUTES FIRST
PARAGRAPH- WE WOULD LIKE. TO
CONTINUE CONGRESS WITH THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REGARDING THE
BILL- WE'VE REACHED OUT TO OUR
OFFICE WE HAD A- FINANCIAL
DISCUSSION EARLIER THIS WEEK.
I'M TRYING TO FIND OUT EXACTLY
WHAT THE PROBLEM IS WHERE THE
IN EFFECT INEFFICIENCIES ARE
WITHIN SB FIFTY FOUR- AND IF
THERE ARE AREAS THAT NEED TO BE
IMPROVED- CLEANED UP- WE'RE
HAPPY TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS BEEN TRYING. TO
WORK COLLABORATIVELY. TOWARDS
THE IN ABOUT SIMILAR GOALS
ACTUALLY I'M REALLY BEING CLEAR
WITH OUR BOUNDARIES BETWEEN
LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
PARTNERS- BUT UNFORTUNATELY AS
DRAFTED. AS I SAID THIS REALLY
TAKE THIS BACK- THE SQUARE ONE
IN THE IN THE INITIAL DEBATES
ON SB FIFTY FOUR IN THE
SANCTUARY STATE LAWS- AND WE
HAVE SERIOUS CONCERNS WITH THE
LANGUAGE IN PRINT. AND ARE
THEREFORE OPPOSED. THANK YOU MR
FELDMAN- ARE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ON THE
VIDEO CONFERENCING LINE. AT T.
R. ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
ON THE PHONE. YEAH LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE
AB NINE THREE SEVEN PRESS THE
LONDON ZERO NOW AGAIN TO OPPOSE
AB NINE THREE SEVEN PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO NOW. AND WE'RE
SHOWING Q. AND THE Q. LOCAL TO
LINE TO SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE Q. SIXTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YEAH ACTUALLY
WITH THAT I'M ACTUALLY IN
SUPPORT MY NAME IS DONNA MAUGER
NOT REPRESENTED LEGAL SERVICES
FOR PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN AND
NOW WE ARE CO SPONSORS IN
STRONG SUPPORT. AT THANK YOU
SIR MAXIMOFF CAROLINE THREE
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
YOUR MEMBERS RANDY PARA THEIR
REDUCE HAS AS HOW THE HOUSE
WILL ACT IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND THAT TIME
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE TO MAKE YOU.
THANK YOU ARE BRING BACK TO
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS MR LEE
HAS A QUESTION. ASSEMBLY
BAKERY- THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
ASSEMBLY MACRI ALLEGED I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS AND BRING
FOR THE VISION ACT I THINK IT'S
INCREDIBLY TIMELY RIGHT NOW
GIVEN. THE RISE IN RESURGENCE
OF ANTI RIGHT NOW IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT THIS BILL IS OF
COURSE BENEFITING A LOT OF OUR
COMMUNITY DOES HURT RIGHT NOW I
THINK A COMMON REFRAIN THE MOST
MEMBERS OF ASIAN AFRICAN
COMMUNITY YOU'LL HEAR TALK
ABOUT IS GO BACK TO YOUR
COUNTRY RIGHT OBVIOUSLY NOT
UNIQUE TO OUR COMMUNITY. BUT
SOMETHING CERTAINLY YOU HEAR
ALL THE TIME WELL THIS BILL IS
TRYING TO ADDRESS SOMETHING WE
STRUCTURALLY THAT WE ARE ALL
AND FORTUNATELY- PAYING FOR IS
THEY LITERALLY DEPORTING PEOPLE
BACK TO THEIR COUNTRY EVEN
THOUGH. A FORTUNE A LOT OF
PEOPLE GET COULD DROP BACK IN
VIETNAM OR LAOS HAVE GROWN UP
IN CALIFORNIA GROWN UP IN THIS
COUNTRY THE DROPPED IN A
COUNTRY THAT IS JUST AS
FOREIGN. TO US PERHAPS THE AS
THEM AND I WOULD ALSO POINT OUT
THAT EVEN DURING THE BINDING
RESTORATION FEBRUARY THIRTY
THREE VIETNAMESE AMERICANS WERE
PUT ON ONE FLIGHT BACK DEPORTED
BACK TO AMERICA I DEFERRED BACK
TO VIETNAM. AND THERE HAS BEEN
A- TWO HUNDRED OR 210079% SPIKE
IN DEPORTATIONS OF CAMBODIAN
AMERICANS JUST IN TWENTY SEVEN
TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN ALONE. SO
DEPORTATIONS WHILE THIS AFFECTS
EVERY COMMUNITY OF COLOR IN
FORTUNE EVERY COMMENCEMENT
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY IS
STRUCTURING ALSO SOMETHING THAT
HAS BEEN WEAPONIZED TOWARDS API
COMMITTEE AND SOMETHING THAT
HAS FRANKLY TORN ALL OF OUR
COMMITTEES APART AND BUILDS
MISTRUST IN OUR COMMUNITY. WHEN
AND I THINK A LOT ABOUT MY
CONSTITUENTS TO HAVE FLED. WAR
TORN BATTLEFIELDS OF VIETNAM
LAOS AND CAMBODIA WITH NOTHING
BUT A VAGUE VISION OF A BETTER
LIFE FOR THEIR KIDS I'M SURE
THEY WILL BE COMPLETELY
HEARTBROKEN TO THINK THAT THEIR
KIDS THAT THEY BROUGHT OVER ON
THE BOATS OR PLANES OR EVEN
EVACUATING WAR ZONES. COULD BE
PLUCKED FROM THE COMMUNITY
GROWN THAT THEY RISKED THEIR
LIVES TO GET THEM TO JUST
BECAUSE A MISTAKE THAT DECADES
AGO IN THEIR YOUTH SO IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT I THINK AND
ESPECIALLY NOW THAT WE'RE
ADDRESSING SYSTEMIC VIOLENCE IN
THE FOR DEPORTATIONS AND FAMILY
SEPARATION. ESPECIALLY FOR ANTI
FOR OUR ASIAN AMERICAN CAN. NOW
SO I REALLY HOPE THE EVERYONE
WILL BE SO. THIS BILL I I'M
HAPPY BE A CO AUTHOR ON IT AS
WELL. THANK YOU MR CLARK. SO
CERTAINLY- I SUPPORT THE
WITNESSES THAT THE- AUTHOR
BROUGHT FORWARD AND I WOULD
CERTAINLY SUPPORT THEY'RE
GETTING HOT THE ABILITY TO STAY
HERE AND I ALSO SUPPORT. A MUCH
OF WHAT- ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE
HAD TO SAY MY CONCERN IS THAT
NOT EVERYBODY'S LIKE THAT. SO
THERE ARE VIOLENT FELONS WHO
NEVER GET- ANY GOOD TIME ARE
THEY SERVE THEIR TIME AND THEY
COME OUT AND THEY'RE STILL LAW
HELPED- THE NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT. PRESIDENTIAL ELECTIONS
WAS LOST BECAUSE IN
MASSACHUSETTS THEY ALLOWED A IN
MAY HAVE A WEEKEND LEAVE WILLIE
HORTON. WAS IT TERRIBLY RACIST
AD THAT IT WORKED REALLY HARD
AND WENT OUT AND KILLED
SOMEBODY REALLY WAS ON LEAVE
AND THAT WAS USED AGAINST.
GEORGE BUSH'S OPPONENT THE
GOVERNOR OF MASSACHUSETTS
DUKAKIS. TO WIN AN ELECTION AND
YOU KNOW IF WE ALLOW SOMETHING
LIKE THAT TO HAPPEN. WE COULD
LOSE ALL OF THIS WE COULD LOSE
THE VALUES ACT WHICH OF COURSE
I VOTED FOR MOST OF THE PEOPLE
HERE WE HERE AT THE TIME VOTED
FOR. SO WHAT WE NEED IS TO BE
ABLE. TO IF SOMEBODY HAS DONE A
SERIOUS AND VIOLENT FELONY.
EITHER WE EXCLUDE THEM FROM
THIS PROGRAM OR IF WE'RE GOING
TO ALLOW THE MEN THAT WE HAVE
TO HAVE SOME SORT OF PROOF.
THAT THEY'VE IN FACT REFORM
THAT COULD COME UP AND I DON'T
KNOW ENOUGH ABOUT THIS TO SAY
WHETHER. YOU KNOW WE COULD LOOK
AT THE PAROLE BOARD OR
SOMETHING ELSE BUT- I CANNOT
SUPPORT EVERYONE'S GETTING THIS
PRIVILEGE. I AM THANK YOU FOR
THE COMMENT TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK I DO WANT TO ADDRESS
MAJOR CONCERNS REGARDING THE
PAROLE BOARD IN AND COMMIT TO
CONTINUING TO WORK TO GET THIS
LEGISLATION CORRECT IN
ADDRESSING THE ISSUES THAT
YOU'RE BRINGING UP- THE BOARD
OF PAROLE HEARINGS IN AN EFFORT
TO IF AN INDIVIDUAL IS TO GO IN
FRONT OF THE- ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
RELEASE THEY MUST DEMONSTRATE
SATISFACTION TO THE BOARD OF
PAROLE HEARINGS THAT THEY ARE
REHABILITATED. THAT THEY ARE
REMOTE REMORSEFUL FOR THEIR
CRIME HAVE A REENTRY PLAN ARE
NOT A DANGER TO THE PUBLIC OR
SAFETY- THROUGH THE ASSISTING
ABILITY HEARING PROCESS AND
DURING THE REVIEW PROCESS
INDIVIDUALS MUST UNDERGO A
THOROUGH PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSESSMENT THAT INCLUDES A
REVIEW OF THEIR LIFE BEGINNING
FROM WHERE THEY WERE US
CHILDREN ANY SUBSTANCE ABUSE
HISTORY ANY MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES- PAROLE PLANS
ADVANCEMENT FOR RHYS FIRELANDS
AND OTHER RISK CONDITIONS AND
RISK FOR FUTURE VIOLENCE
ADDITIONALLY. THE PAROLE BOARD
CONSIDERS THE PRESENCE OR
ABSENCE OF INSIGHT AS A
SIGNIFICANT FACTOR OF
DETERMINING WHETHER THERE IS A
RATIONAL NEXUS BETWEEN THE
INDIVIDUALS PAST BEHAVIOR AND
THE THREAT TO- CURRENTLY
PERCENT THAT THE INDIVIDUAL
CURRENTLY POSSESSES TO THE
PUBLIC SAFETY THE BOARD OF
PAROLE HEARINGS SUSTAINABILITY
HEARINGS ARE CONDUCTED BY A
CONDEMNED A COMMISSIONER
APPOINTED BY THE GOVERNOR
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS FROM
PROSECUTING COUNTY SUBMIT
STATEMENTS ON THE QUESTIONS ARE
WHETHER. AS WELL AS A
REPRESENTATIVES MAY ATTEND THE
HEARING AND PROVIDE A STATEMENT
THERE IS A LOT MORE THAT I CAN
SHARE WITH THE U. S. I'M ALSO
LEARNING THE PROCESS- BUT I AM
COMMITTED TO ENSURING THAT WE
FIND A PATH FORWARD- AND THAT
ULTIMATELY WE ARE WORKING
TOWARDS A JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT
IS PALATABLE THAT NO MATTER
WHEREYOU COME FROM IF YOU ARE
NOT BORN IN THE US AND YOU
COMMITTED A CRIME. YOU SHOULD
SERVE YOUR TIME AND IF YOUR
TIME IS SERVED AND YOU ARE NOW
ELIGIBLE TO BE RELEASED. THAT
SHOULD BE THE CASE THAT IS A
JUST. JUSTICE SYSTEM. WHERE WE
ARE DOING EVERYTHING WE
POSSIBLY CAN TO ENSURE. THAT WE
PROVIDE THE NECESSARY RESOURCES
FOR REHABILITATION. THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS IT'S
NOT JUST THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS. IT'S A DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION. AND WE ARE
ENSURING THAT THE DEPARTMENT
HAS THE FUNDS AND RESOURCES
NECESSARY. TO ENSURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE COMMITTED
A CRIME. ARE ABLE TO GO TO
SCHOOL LEARN A TRADE. COME BACK
INTO SOCIETY BE REUNITED WITH
THEIR FAMILIES. AND LET'S NOT
USE THIS IDEA OF FEAR. AS A WAY
TO NEGATE THE FACT THAT PEOPLE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
ABILITY. IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT
THE OPPOSITION TESTIMONY BRINGS
UP. L. CAPONE AND IRS AND THE
IRS AS A WAY TO DETERMINE.
WHETHER THERE IS A FEAR
MONGERING AMONG. IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE ALREADY.
SERVED THEIR TIME AND PAID
THEIR DEBT TO SOCIETY. SO AGAIN
I WILL JUST SHARE I TO I'M
LEARNING MORE ABOUT THE PAROLE
BOARD. AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT COMMUNITIES ARE SAFE. THAT
PEOPLE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REUNITE WITH THEIR FAMILIES AND
BE ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS YOU
KNOW WHAT I HEARD IS YOU'RE NOT
CHANGING THE BILL. BECAUSE WHAT
YOU SAID AS WELL IF THEY'RE ON
PAROLE THEY'RE FINE. LOOK IF
SOMEONE HAS SERVED. THEIR FULL
TIME. THEY CAN'T KEEP THEM IN
JAIL ANY LONGER THAN THAT.
WHETHER OR NOT ANY OF THOSE
CONDITIONS ARE. FOR FELT. NOW
FOR ALL OF THOSE CONDITIONS YOU
MENTIONED- FOR FILLED. I'M FINE.
BUT WE HAVE A HUGE RECIDIVISM
RATE. SO CLEARLY NOT EVERYONE
LET OUT FROM THE PRESENCE. IS
NOT GOING TO OFFEND AGAIN. I
NEED SOMETHING STRONGER THAN
SIMPLY THE PERSON HAS GONE ON
PAROLE I NEED TO HAVE AN M. WE
SHOULDN'T TRYING TO TERMINATE
HERE NOW AGAIN BUT YOU
DESCRIBED AS THE PAROLE FOLKS
BEING LEFT OUT AND THEY FILL
ALL THESE CONDITIONS THAT'S
FINE BUT NOT EVERYBODY GOES OUT
DOES. AND LOTS OF PEOPLE
PROBABLY I THINK IT'S THE
MAJORITY DO RESET AVE AND ALL
WE NEED IS ONE MURDER BY
SOMEONE WILL FLAT OUT. CAN WE
LOSE THE WHOLE PROGRAM CELLS
SURE ME THAT YOU WILL FIND A
WAY. THAT YOU KNOW IT'S NOT
JUST THAT THEY WERE LET OUT OF
PRISON. BUT THAT THERE IS
ADEQUATE EVIDENCE. THAT THEY
WILL IN FACT. THERE'S A HIGH
PROBABILITY NOTHING IS PERFECT
NOT REALLY A FAN THAT'S WHAT I
NEED OKAY I CAN ASSURE YOU THAT
WE WILL WORK TOWARDS THAT AND
IN IF I MAY CAN WE CALL ON
MISS ANGELA CHAN TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THOSE CONCERNS AS WELL.
WHAT I'M SATISFIED WITH WHAT
SHE HAD TO SAY I DON'T KNOW
ANYONE ELSE OKAY I JUST A LOT
LESS GRAVERT MISS WICKS I'M
FINE THURMOND THANK. IN A
MISTER SANTIAGO I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL THANK-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COREY
ADVOCATING GOING TO. YOU NEXT
TIME ADVOCATING THAT. I'M SORRY
MISS BAUER K. YES THEY CHERISH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CLEAR THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL UP AND
FOR YOUR CONTINUED ADVOCACY ON
SOCIAL JUSTICE ISSUES I WOULD
JUST LOVE TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR AND I'M- HAPPY TO VOTE
FOR THE BILL TODAY. THANK YOU.
MAYES FOR BACKUP R. K. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- THANK YOU
MISS CRABB YOUR PRESENTATION
TODAY- I DO HAVE CONCERNS WITH
SOME OF THE SERIOUS AND VIOLENT
FELONS BETTER DRESSED IN THIS
BUT I ACTUALLY WANT TO GIVE YOU
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS-
WIFE MR FELDMAN TOUCH ON TODAY
BUT WHAT I THINK WAS LAID OUT.
AND IN HIS LETTER- VERY WELL
WHICH IS THIS WHAT I BELIEVE
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION TODAY IS
AN UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE- BUT
THAT THE LANGUAGE AS WRITTEN
COULD STAND IN THE WAY OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT PARTNERSHIP ON FOR
EXAMPLE- ANTI TERRORISM TASK
FORCE THAT HAPPENED BOTH AT THE
FEDERAL AND THE LOCAL LEVEL AND
YOU KNOW THEY SAY THE LANGUAGE
IN SB FIFTY FOUR THAT ENSURE
THAT THAT WORK WAS NOT FOR
IMMIGRATION PURPOSES BUT WAS
FOR ANOTHER PURPOSE AND THAT.
I'M I'M CONCERNED THAT THAT
WORK THAT I BELIEVE IS CRITICAL
TO OUR SAFETY WOULD BE-
POTENTIALLY AN UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE OF THAT LANGUAGE
IT'S PRESENTED TODAY TO MY
DRESSING. SEVEN THE SO YOU WANT
TO DRESS TO ISSUE OF THE TASK
FORCE YES AND THE LETTER THE
LETTER LOCAL PARTNERSHIPS THAT
ARE HAPPY AND WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT NOT FOR IMMIGRATION
PURPOSES BUT FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
SO REGARDING THE CALIFORNIA
POLICE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION
LETTER THEY SIDE THE CHANGING
LIMITATIONS ON JOINT TASK
FORCES OF THE BASIS FOR THEIR
OPPOSITION. RIGHT SB FIFTY FOUR
PROHIBITS JOINT TASK FORCE
OPERATION WENT IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT IS THE PRIMARY
PURPOSE RIGHT. DIVISION ACT
WILL PROHIBIT JOINT TASK FORCE
OPERATION ON IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT IS A PURPOSE OR THE
ONLY PURPOSE. DIVISION ACT
INCLUSIVE TO FORM BECAUSE IT
HAS BEEN NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE. TO
ENFORCE THE PROVISIONS OF SB
FIFTY FOUR S. SOME LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WOULD
SIMPLY JUST CLAIM THE PURPOSE.
TO BE H. ASK- TASK FORCE WAS
CRIMINAL ENFORCEMENT EVEN
THOUGH THE IMMIGRATION ARRESTS
WERE ALSO CONDUCTED. HAS ALSO
JUST CONCERNING THAT IN THEIR
LETTER THEY ADMIT THAT THEY USE
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT TO
DETAIN. PEOPLE BECAUSE THEY
BASICALLY CAN'T MEET THE BURDEN
OF PROOF TO ARREST OR PROSECUTE
PEOPLE FOR CRIMINAL ENFORCEMENT
PURPOSES. THIS IS THE LINE THAT
ICE HAS BEEN PUSHING FOR AT
LEAST A DECADE BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT. AN ICE OFFICIAL
TOLD ATTENDEES AT THE POLICE
FOUNDATION NATIONAL CONFERENCE
THAT IF THEY DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH
EVIDENCE TO CHARGE A PERSON
CRIMINALLY. AND THAT THEY THINK
THE PERSON IS UNDOCUMENTED- TO
JUST HAND THEM TO ICE TO MAKE
THEM DISAPPEAR. SO WHAT I. WHAT
I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR ON. IS
THAT REGARDLESS OF WHERE AN
INDIVIDUAL IS BORN. THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS SHOULD NOT
CONTINUE A PERPETUAL
PUNISHMENT. THEY HAVE SERVED
THEIR TIME. SOME ARE ACTUALLY
IN THE PROCESS OF TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS THE- EXAMPLE THAT I GAVE
EARLY IN MY TESTIMONY WAS ABOUT
A PERMANENT RESIDENT. WHO IS
POTENTIALLY ARE BEING DEPORTED
AND IS CURRENTLY IN AN ICE
DETENTION FACILITY. I WOULD
HATE THAT THIS BODY CONTINUES
TO FEAR MONGERING OF IMMIGRANTS
JUST SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY ARE
SEEN AS THE OTHER. THE
TESTIMONY SAY YOU HEARD TODAY
ARE EXAMPLES OF WHO ARE GOING
TO BE HELPED WITH THE VISION
ACT AND I'M SORRY TO SAY THAT.
EVEN THOUGH SB FIFTY FOUR IS IN
EFFECT RIGHT NOW AND
TECHNICALLY AND LAW IT
PROHIBITS- ASKING IMMIGRATION-
QUESTIONS REGARDING A TASK
FORCE IT'S STILL BEING USED.
AND WE NEED TO CLARIFY THAT AND
ENSURE THAT THAT'S NOT THE CASE
IN CALIFORNIA SO I LOOK FORWARD
TO HAVING INITIAL CONVERSATIONS
WITH YOU I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH BOTH
THE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION OF
POLICE CHIEFS AND PARK AS WE
MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD. I'M NOT
SOMEONE THAT IS CLOSED OFF TO
HAVING CONVERSATIONS I WANT TO
HAVE THE RESOLUTION NECESSARY
TO ENSURE THAT WE MOVE FORWARD-
AND LOOK FORWARD TO ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY HAVE. THANK YOU. AND YET
ANOTHER PUSH. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR COMMENT AND I DO LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS WITH YOU
PERSONALLY BUT ALSO WITH- YOU
KNOW THE POLICE TO BECAUSE I DO
THINK THAT- I APPRECIATE YOUR
ANSWER I DON'T KNOW IF WE CAN
HAVE MISTER FELDMAN GIVE HIS
PERSPECTIVE ON IT BUT I THINK-
TIER POINTS RIGHT THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN TASK FORCE
SET UP FOR NOT IMMIGRATION
PURPOSES WHICH WHAT IS. IS WHAT
A LOT OF SB FIFTY FOUR AND
THOSE THAT ARE IN- AND YOU'RE
CORRECT YOUR LANGUAGE FOCUSES
ON THAT ISSUE OF IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT SO- AGAIN I HOPE
YOU GUYS CAN COME TOGETHER SO
THAT THERE IS NOT AN UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE OF AFFECTING THOSE.
NOT INTEGRATION. INVESTIGATION
THANK YOU MR SANTIAGO- THANK
TAKE ONE LAST CALL FOR PURPOSES
SPEAKING. DOUBLE MAST YEAH SO
APOLOGETIC MR THANK YOU FOR-
FOR THE ROBUST DEBATE AND I'M
ON IT TOTAL MAYBE CARVE A
COUPLE THINGS YOU KNOW I
APPRECIATE THE- THE EXAMPLE OF
THE- WILLIE HORTON TECH AND
THAT PERSON WAS NOT
UNDOCUMENTED- SO IT'S VERY
CLEAR OF WHO WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT- BECAUSE I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CLEAR THEY'RE A
LITTLE BIT BECAUSE- IN THE
NATIONAL RHETORIC RHETORIC.
OVER THE LAST FOUR YEARS THERE
WAS LOTS OF THE TAX- ON
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS IN FACT
WE HAD A PRESIDENT WHO STARTED
OFF A CAMPAIGN BY CALLING.
MEXICANS MY CUT MY FAMILY'S
COUNTRY OF ORIGIN- RAPISTS
CRIMINALS AND THE SUCH I THINK
THAT TEAMS THE WAY WE TAKE A
LOOK AT- SOMETIMES A DIFFERENT
CULTURE SO- AND I THINK LIKE.
WE HADN'T YET AND WE HAD ICE
WHO BECAME- A DEPORTATION
MACHINE. AND I'M I'M GONNA SAY
THIS BECAUSE I HAVE TO GET OFF
MY CHEST THAT YOU CAN'T HAVE IT
BOTH WAYS YOU CAN'T FEEL
SYMPATHETIC- FOR THE IMMIGRANT
WHO'S SITTING IN A CAGE IN
CHILDREN HER SIT IN CAGES AND
THEN NOT FEEL- SYMPATHETIC- FOR
THE ACTIONS THAT CAUSED THAT.
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
LOOK IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE.
ANY SPECIAL TREATMENT FOR
ANYBODY WHO IS INCARCERATED. IT
UP AND I WILL SAY ON A SIDE
NOTE THAT I THAT I THAT I
UNDERSTAND THE ISSUE OF
REHABILITATION AND MAKING SURE
THAT THAT PERSON DOESN'T COMMIT
THE SAME CRIMES BUT THE THING
THAT'S THE SAME ISSUE WE FACE
WITH ANY RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
POLICIES THAT WE DEBATE. WHICH
IS THAT THE PERSON.
REHABILITATES THEMSELVES FINDS
A BETTER. A BETTER THEMSELVES.
AND BECOMES A PRODUCTIVE- A
PERSON A SOCIETY WE HOPE THAT
FOR EVERYONE THAT'S WHY WE'RE
HERE THAT'S THE WORK OF PUBLIC
SAFETY HAS DONE. THAT SO WE
PUSH VERY STRONGLY FOR. AND WE
CROSS OUR FINGERS AND WE HOPE
IT WORKS BECAUSE WE KNOW WHEN
OUR SOULS THAT IT'S A BETTER
WAY OF. OF DOING A CRIMINAL
JUSTICE- A CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM ARGUMENT JUSTICE
SYSTEM'S JUST BROKE BUT JUST
FACE SOME OF OUR IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM IS BROKEN. BUT WHAT IS
THE COR ROUTE IS THIS. IS IF
WE'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT EQUALITY
EQUITY- FOR EVERYONE. AND IF
WE'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT FIXING A
BROKEN- CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
THEN WE HAVE TO ALSO TALK
ABOUT. MAKING IT FAIR FOR
EVERYONE. AND BUT I MEAN BY
THAT IS IF YOU WERE DOCUMENTED
OR UNDOCUMENTED- YOU YOU HAVE
TO HAVE A THE SCENE PLAYING
FIELD FOR FOLKS. I KNOW IT'S
HARD BECAUSE I'VE TALKED TO
PEOPLE WHO STRUGGLED WITH THIS
CONCEPT AND CERTAINLY WHAT WE
TALKED ABOUT SB FIFTY FOUR THE
WITH A LOT OF HEATED DEBATE
ABOUT. A LOT OF HEATED DEBATE
ABOUT THIS. THE PERSON TO STILL
SERVE THEIR TIME. NOTHING IN
THIS BILL SUGGEST ANY DIFFERENT.
BUT THAT PERSON ALSO HAS IT
COULD POTENTIALLY HAVE A FAMILY.
ONCE SAID THAT AND I SAID A
VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE I I'M
GONNA SHARE SOME A LITTLE BIT.
ONCE A PERSON TO SERVE THEIR
TIME. WHETHER YOU'VE THROWN THE
WHOLE BOOK I DON'T FOR HALF THE
BOOK ADAM. THEY SERVE THEIR
TIME SO SHOULDN'T THAT PERSON.
MALE OR FEMALE BE TREATED
EQUALLY TO ANYONE ELSE. WHO HAS
SERVED THEIR TIME. WHICH MEANS
GO BACK TO COMMUNITY. AND TRY
TO BE A BETTER SELF. THAT'S
REALLY WHAT ABOUT. BUT A LOT OF
EARLY ONSET YOU CAN'T HAVE IT
BOTH WAYS YOU HAVE TO SEE THE
OTHER SIDE- A WHAT THIS DOES
IMMIGRATION DEBATE IN THIS
COUNTRY. NOW MOST OF US HAVE
NEVER HAD- I HAVE NEVER HAD THE
EXPERIENCE OF LIVING WITH
UNDOCUMENTED PARENTS BUT I CAN
TELL YOU I HAD. AND D. A. V. IT
AND I KNOW MY COLLEAGUE HAS AS
WELL. THE FEAR AND YOU CANNOT
IMAGINE. THE NO THEIR PARENTS
PROBABLY WON'T COME HOME EVERY
TIME TO LEAVE THE HOUSE IS REAL.
AND WHAT WE SAW HAPPEN FOUR
YEARS AGO WITH FAMILIES PICKED
UP ON THE STREETS AND- THE
FOLKS THROWN OUT WE'VE HAD IN
OUR COMMUNITIES OR CONSTANTLY
UP AT WORK- PARENT LEAVE THE
KID AND I SAW SONORA THAT
THAT'S NOT A HIGH SCHOOL WE SAW
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. FOLKS
HIDING AND NOT SENDING THEIR
KIDS TO SCHOOL BECAUSE THEY
DON'T WANT TO LEAVE. BUT YOU
CAN'T HAVE IT BOTH WAYS IF
YOU'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT
FAIRNESS AND EQUALITY GOTTA
TALK ABOUT FEAR- IF YOU'RE IN A
QUALITY LAWS. WHAT HAPPENS WHAT
WHAT WITHOUT WITH THOSE PEOPLE
ONCE YOU'VE GONE THROUGH THIS
FRAMEWORK. THAT IS GOING TO BE
IRONCLAD BUT NOTHING IS. A
FRAMEWORK OF A PAROLE BOARD
THAT PERSON HAS THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO RESTART AND BILL
THAT'S THAT SORT COMMUNITY
THAT'S OUR FAMILY. BUT IF YOU
TAKE UP PERSONAL WAY. AFTER
THEY'VE SERVED THEIR SENTENCE.
AND APART TO KNOW WHAT YOU'VE
DONE BECAUSE WHAT WE'VE DONE. A
SENTENCING AND HIRE OTHER
FAMILY WITHOUT A DAD WITHOUT A
MOM BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY. THAT'S
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE CAN'T
HAVE IT BOTH WAYS EITHER THERE
WITH WITH THE START OF JUSTICE
OR YOU'RE NOT EITHER BELIEVE
THE RESTORATIVE JUSTICE. OR YOU
DON'T. YOU TO JUST BELIEVE AND
SOME PEOPLE HAVE A RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE. AND NOT EVERYBODY
ELSE. AND I DON'T SEE THE NOTES
COMES UP A LITTLE BIT STRONGER.
BUT THAT'S THE ARGUMENT WE FACE
ABOUT WHAT WHEN IT COMES DOWN
TO UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS. ALL
WE COULD DO IT FOR EVERYBODY
ELSE CAN'T DO A FOR SOMEBODY
WHO'S BEEN DOCUMENTED BECAUSE A
LITTLE DIFFERENT. THEY CAME IN
A LITTLE DIFFERENT. THEY SMELL
DIFFERENT THEY WORK A LITTLE
DIFFERENT. WITH ALL KINDS OF
NAMES ALL KINDS OF FLOWERS. AT
THE END OF THE DAY. A HUMAN IS
A HUMAN IS A HUMAN I HAVE A
FRIEND A FRIEND OF MINE HE'S TO
JOKE AROUND. AND YOU SAY NO THE
ONLY DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THAT
PERSON OVER THERE WHO IS A
CITIZEN. AND MY PARENTS WERE
UNDOCUMENTED WAS A BURST LOW
BUT THAT REALLY IS IT. SOME
PERSONAL BURNOUT WHAT BORN ON
ONE SIDE OF THE BORDER THE
OTHER ON THE OTHER. AND MY
STORIES GOT IT MY STORY IS NOT
DIFFERENT THAN ANYBODY ELSE'S.
MY PARENTS CAME HERE HAD ME.
YEAH THEY GOT THE PORTED. THAT
HAPPENS. AND WE END UP BACK IN
NEXT. THEY CAME BACK AND HAD MY
BROTHER. YEAH BUT HAD NOT BEEN
FOR THEM TO COME HERE. THANK
KALINKA BABY AND WE'VE HEARD
ONE YOU KNOW IT'S UP FINE
WHATEVER YOU KNOW. BUT BUT THE
POINT IS YOU HAVE TO THINK
ABOUT JUSTICE AND FOR ANYBODY
WHO MIGHT BE CONCERNED. AND I
THINK ANYBODY SAID HERE. ABOUT
NOT BEING ABLE TO GO AFTER AN
INDIVIDUAL ONES ARE BEING
RELEASED LET ME BE VERY CLEAR
THE BILL ALLOWS FOR WARPED.
IT'S SEXIST IT SETS A STANDARD
FOR THE BAR YOU GOT TO GO
THROUGH JUDGE GOTTA GET A
FEDERAL ONE IF I'M NOT
MISTAKEN. AND THAT WARRANT
WOULD ALLOW FOR ANY OF THE
CONCERNS THAT ANYONE HAS ABOUT
GOING FOR THE PICKING UP ANY
PERSON- ONES ARE BEING
RELEASED. SO IF THERE IS A
BONAFIDE CONCERNS. ON THAT
INDIVIDUAL. THAT THAT THAT IS
OUTSIDE OF THEM SERVING THEIR
TIME. ALL THEY HAVE TO DO IS A
BILL TO GET A WARRANT ONCE I
GOT THAT WARRANT TAKE PICKING
UP LIKE ANYBODY ELSE SAME WAY
THE SAME WAY AS I READ I
BELIEVE IN SB FIFTY FOUR. ALL
WE'RE SAYING IS. IT JUST CANNED
IT JUST CAN'T BE GAME ON ANY
TIME SOMEBODY GETS OFF. AND GO
PICK PEOPLE UP IN COURT IN
COURT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
FOR ALLOWING ME TO TAKE HIM TO
MAKE THAT COMMENT. YOU SEE VERY
MUCH BUT I WOULD URGE EVERYBODY
TO SUPPORT IT BECAUSE IF YOU'RE
GOING TO BE IF YOU GO SUPPORTER
STARTED JUSTICE GOT SUPPORT FOR
ALL. LET ME. MAKE A SUGGESTION
IN THIS KIND OF CLARIFICATION
AND MAY EVEN HELP- DOES THAT. I
JUST HAVE SOME CONCERNS BOB
WHEN THIS BILL OR THIS IDEA
CAME TO ME LAST YEAR I HAD THE
SAME CONCERNS AND- WHEN I
CALLED DAN RALPH DEUS. WHO IS
SECRETARY OF CDCR AND I SAID
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
EVERY IMMIGRANT DASH RELEASED
OUT OF CDCR CDC ARE ACTIVELY
CALLS BODIES. TO HAVE THEM SIT
OUTSIDE PICKED THEM UP AND TAKE
THEM TO WHICH HE SAID THAT IS.
ABSOLUTELY NOT TRUE. HE SAID
THE PROCESS IS. EVERYBODY HAS
TO BE RELEASED HOWEVER. A
FEDERAL WARRANT SUPERSEDES
ANYTHING WE WANT TO DO SO I
SUPPORT FBI CIA ANTI TERRORIST
GROUP IF THEY CAN COME IN WITH
A FEDERAL WARRANT WHICH
INCLUDES GETTING A JUDGE
INTERNAL. THAT PERSON THEN THEY
HAVE TO GIVE THAT OVER TO TODAY
IT'S SO WHITE I THINK WE
PROBABLY NEED TO CHECK FOR
HOPEFULLY HE GIVES SOME
ASSURANCE. TO MEMBERS HERE THAT
IF THAT IS THE CASE THAT NO
MATTER WHAT YOU MAY THINK WE'RE
DOING IN THIS BILL IT COULD BE
SUPERSEDED BY FEDERAL LAW THAT
WE HAVE TO TURN A PERSON OVER
EVEN WITH A FINAL. WARNING FOR
WHATEVER SO I WOULD LOVE FOR
THIS TO GET OUT TO MEET AND GET
SOME OF THOSE QUESTIONS
ANSWERED. I WOULD SAY NOT TO
FURTHER CONFUSE YOU. BUT TO LET
YOU KNOW THAT. NCDC ARE THEY
DIDN'T BELIEVE. THAT PEOPLE WHO
HAVE SERVED THEIR TIME.
FOURTEEN YEAR OLD WHO GOT
INVOLVED IN GANGS THERE NOW
FORTY FOUR YEARS OLD TOTALLY
REPENTANT DID GO OUT TO ALL
EVERYTHING THEY BELIEVE THAT
PERSON GENERALLY IS NOT
HAMPERED BUT NOW I'M HEARING
FROM THE AUTHOR. WE MAY NEED
SOME CLEAN UP LANGUAGE TO
ENSURE THAT INDIVIDUALS WHO NO
LONGER PRESENT. A RISK TO
SOCIETY HAVE GONE THROUGH ALL
OF THE PROGRAM AND NOW ALSO
LEAVE YOU WITH THIS. GIVING
PROBATION AND OUT OF PRISON
IT'S HARD I LIKED IT YOU HAVE
NO CLUE WHAT HOOPS YOU NEED TO
GO THROUGH TO GET OUT OF PRISON
THROUGH THESE PROGRAMS THESE
ARE NOT. CAKEWALK IT IS
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT AND I'VE
HEARD THAT FROM EVERY. EVERY
PART OF THEM. OF THE
CORRECTIONS GROUP IT IS IT IS
NOT A CAKE WALK DRIVE I DON'T
WANT PEOPLE TO BELIEVING THAT
THAT PEOPLE JUST **** NILLY
LETTING PEOPLE OUT THAT IS DEAD
THERE IS A PROCESS AND MAYBE
THAT MAY BE PART OF THIS
EDUCATING. EVERYBODY ON HOW
DIFFICULT THIS PROCESS IS-
BECAUSE CDCR DOES NOT. WANT TO
LET SOMEBODY LOOSE. AND THEN
THEY FIND OUT LATER DO
SOMETHING REALLY HORRENDOUS
BECAUSE GUESS WHERE THAT COMES
BACK ON TO THE INSTITUTION AND
SO THEY PROBABLY GO A LITTLE
OVERBOARD TO ENSURE THAT-
NOBODY JUST GETS OUT. IN FRONT
FOR NOTHING. SO I THOUGHT. IF
THERE'S NO MORE QUESTIONS YOU
MAY CLOSE AND THAT'S KIND OF MY
CLOSE TO THAT THAT WE- THAT WE-
THAT WE MOVE ON AND THAT YOU
KNOW WITNESSES GO AFTER THIS.
SO THERE'S PEOPLE GET. HOW MANY
MORE THAN THAT. OKAY SO THIS
WILL GO THROUGH JUDICIARY WHICH
PROBABLY HAVE EVEN MORE
QUESTIONS. AND THROUGH- TO
APPROACH SO WE CAN HAVE MORE
DEBATE WE CAN BRING GIVE YOU
TIME TO ALLOW THE POLICE CHIEFS
SHERIFFS AND ANYONE ELSE WHO IS
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS SO WE CAN
CLARIFY HOPEFULLY HOPEFULLY
WHAT WE'RE DING IS CLARIFY-
THAT WERE THIS IS NOT A PROGRAM
TO ALLOW. PEOPLE TO STAY IN
THIS COUNTRY WHO ARE. WHO COULD
BE POTENTIAL. POTENTIALLY
DANGEROUS WHICH IS WHAT. MR
QUIRK IS CONCERNED ABOUT. AND I
MOVED TO BILLS THANK SIX ON. MY
CLOSE. YES THANK YOU- AND THANK
YOU FOR THE ROBUST CONVERSATION
I JUST I WANNA CONTINUE TO
CLARIFY A COUPLE OF THINGS THE
VISION ACT WILL CONTINUE TO
ALLOW THE JOINT TAX TASK FORCES
IF THEY ARE CRIMINAL-
ENFORCEMENT IF THEY'RE FOR
CRIMINAL ENFORCEMENT PURPOSES
NOT AN IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT
PURPOSE THAT IS A KEY
DIFFERENCE THE VISION ACT WILL
ALSO CONTINUE TO ALLOW FOR
CRIMINAL WARRANTS I THINK THAT
WAS A QUESTION THAT WAS ASKED
THE BILL DOES NOT STOP ICE FROM
DOING THEIR JOBS AS THEY DO ON
AN EVERYDAY. ULTIMATELY THIS IS
ABOUT JUSTICE AND AN EQUAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM FOR ALL. THE
QUESTION IS DO YOU BELIEVE IN A
JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT. IF AN
INDIVIDUAL HAS SERVED THEIR
TIME SHOULD THEY BE ALLOWED TO
COME BACK INTO SOCIETY THAT IS
THE BASIC FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION
ABOUT THE JUSTICE SYSTEM. I
BELIEVE THAT WE ARE TRYING TO
CREATE A CALIFORNIA FOR ALL NOT
A CALIFORNIA FOR SOME. WERE
BASED ON THE COLOR OF YOUR SKIN
OR YOUR NATIONAL ORANGE ORIGIN
YOU ARE JUDGED DIFFERENTLY.
THAT IS NOT THE PILLAR OF THE
STATE. MEMBERS I HAVE SAID
BEFORE AND I'LL JUST SHARE
AGAIN. I AM A FORMALLY
UNDOCUMENTED CHILD IN THIS
COUNTRY. MY FAMILY FLED A CIVIL
WAR. THERE WERE MANY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ME TO DO
WRONG WHEN I WAS GROWING UP AND
I DID BUT I WAS FORTUNATE TO
HAVE A LOT OF SUPPORT WHERE I
WAS GROWING UP. AND I BELIEVE
THE REPRESENTATION MATTERS. WE
MUST ENSURE. THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS THAT HAVE SERVED
THEIR TIME. WON'T BE DENIED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REUNITE WITH
THEIR FAMILIES AND HAVE A
SECOND CHANCE OF LIFE SIMPLY
BECAUSE- THEY DID SOMETHING
WRONG. PAID THEIR DEBT TO
SOCIETY OR BECAUSE OF WHERE
THEY WERE BORN. AB NINE THREE
SEVEN DIVISION ACT WILL HELP
ACHIEVE THAT. I AM GRATEFUL FOR
THE CONVERSATION AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PERCENT. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AS WE CONTINUE TO MOVE
THIS BILL FORWARD AND GET IT
RIGHT THANK YOU. AND SAID CALL
THE ROLL. ON AB NINE THREE
SEVEN BY SOME MEMBER CARILLO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER. JONES SAWYER HI LACKEY.
LACKEY NO BARRICADE HAND CORK.
QUARK HI SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
SEE ARE TO KNOW THE R. TEN
WICKS. LEE HI LEE I. THE
MEASURE ON CALL ME AND MARK
THANK. AND I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN
PATIENTLY WAITING MISSOURI.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY ALL RIGHT
THANKS TO- MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I HEARD YOU
CALL MY NAME. AND I MISSED IT
SO THAT COST ME THREE HOURS
RIGHT. TODAY I'M HERE TO
PRESENT- AB TWO SIX EIGHT WHICH
WILL PROTECT THE PRIVACY OF MY
MURDERED CONSTITUENTS WHO DIED
IN THE BORDERLINE MASS
SHOOTING. AB TWO SIX EIGHT IS
BASED ON EXISTING LAW. THAT
ALLOWS FAMILIES TO PROTECT THE
PRIVACY OF THEIR MURDERED LOVED
ONES AND IS BALANCED WITH THE
VAST MAJORITY OF RECORDS THAT
WILL REMAIN IN PUBLIC. AFTER
THE EVENTS OF THE BORDERLINE
MASS SHOOTING THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT DESICCATION THE
PUBLISHED REPORTS BY THE DA AND
SHERIFF. AND MULTIPLE NEWSPAPER
STORIES THESE FAMILIES CONTINUE
TO BE TORMENTED BY CONSPIRACY
THEORISTS. REQUESTING AUTOPSY
RECORDS. THERE AND TEND TO OR
DISTORTING THE MEMORY OF THESE
VICTIMS THROUGH HURTFUL AND
OUTRAGEOUS CLAIMS ON MESSAGE
BOARDS. CLAIMING THAT THE
VICTIMS OF MASS SHOOTINGS ARE
CRISIS ACTORS AND ARE ALIVE AND
LIVING OVERSEAS. WE'VE SEEN IT
WITH THE CHILDREN OF SANDY HOOK
ELEMENTARY AND THE PAYTON'S
WROTE. THE PATRONS OF THE PULSE
NIGHTCLUB BASELESS THEORIES
THAT TWIST THE LAST MOMENTS OF
A CRIME VICTIM'S LIFE INTO
CLICK BAIT. AB TWO SIX EIGHT
AMENDS AN EXISTING LAW THAT
ALREADY ALLOWS FAMILIES OF
MURDERED CHILDREN. TO PETITION
A COURT TO HAVE THEIR CHILD'S
AUTOPSY SEALED. ALLAWI PASS
AFTER THE KIDNAPPING RAPE AND
MURDER OF A SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD
TELLS YOU CAME. OVER THE PAST
DECADE THAT LAW WITH ITS
IMPORTANT SAFEGUARDS HAS NOT
RESULTED IN THE BERING ABOUT
BARRING OF ACCESS TO THE VAST
MAJORITY OF CHILD'S AUTOPSY
RECORDS. IT WOULD ONLY APPLY IF
A CRIMINAL ACT CAUSES THE DEATH
OF THE VICTIM. AND THE
PERPETRATOR IS CONVICTED OR
THEY ARE ALL DEAD. I WANT TO
STRESS THAT AB TWO SIX EIGHT
ONLY APPLIES TO A DEATH THAT IS
THE RESULT OF A CRIMINAL ACT
NOT OF NATURAL CAUSES AN
ACCIDENT. OR ONE THAT IS SELF
INFLICTED. SIMPLY EXTENDS THE
OFTEN ALREADY OFFERED TO FAMILY
MEMBERS OF CHILD VICTIMS WHO
DIED OF A CRIMINAL ACT TO
VICTIMS OF ALL AGES. THIS BILL
RISK RETAINS THE CRUCIAL
SAFEGUARD- FROM THE EXISTING
LAW THAT IS STILL COULD NOT BE
REQUESTED UNTIL AFTER A
CRIMINAL CONVICTION IS SECURED.
HOWEVER IT ADDS THE IMPORTANT
ALTERNATIVE THAT IS STILL TO BE
SOUGHT AFTER CASES CLOSED BY
PROSECUTORS DUE TO ALL SUSPECTS
BEING DECEASED. AFTER ALL NO
CONVICTION WILL EVER BE SECURED
AGAINST THE MASS SHOOTER WHO
TAKES HIS OWN LIFE AS WAS THE
CASE AT BORDERLINE. I AM
HONORED TO HAVE JOINING ME IN
SUPPORT BY PHONE TODAY
ELIZABETH ESPINOSA REPRESENTING
VENTURA COUNTY. AND MARK OR FUN
AS THE FATHER OF TELEMARKETER
FINEST. WHO WAS KILLED IN THE
BORDERLINE MASS SHOOTING IN MY
DISTRICT. ALONG WITH ELEVEN
MOSTLY COLLEGE AGE YOUNG PEOPLE.
MOVE THE BILL. OKAY DO WE- TO
HAVE A SUPPORT WITNESSES
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR. WE DO
HAVE THE WITNESSES YOUR LINE
THEY'RE OPEN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS
IS A LIST OF AT ASPEN US ON
BEHALF OF THE VENTURA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS THE
SPONSOR OF AB TWO SIX EIGHT AS
OUTLINED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
IRWIN THIS BILL OFFERS AND
NARAL EXPANSION TO EXISTING
LAW. GIVING QUALIFIED FAMILY
MEMBERS OF MURDER VICTIMS AN
AVENUE TO ENHANCE PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS WITH RESPECT TO
AUTOPSIES AND RELATED EVIDENCE
THE COUNTY'S INITIAL INTEREST
IN SEEKING A CHANGE IN LAW GREW
OUT OF THE COUNTY MEDICAL
EXAMINERS EXPERIENCE WORKING IN
OTHER JURISDICTIONS INCLUDING
THE STATE OF OREGON. AND HIS
OBSERVATIONS ABOUT DIFFERENCES
IN THE LEVEL OF PRIVACY
PROTECTION POST DEATH. AS
DISCUSSED IN THE COMMITTEE'S
ANALYSIS THE RIGHT TO PRIVACY
EXPIRES AT DEATH IN CALIFORNIA
BUT THAT'S NOT THE CASE AND
DOZENS OF OTHER STATES WHERE
THE BALANCE TIPPED IN THE FAVOR
OF THE DECEDENT AND THEIR
DIPPED SURVIVING FAMILY MEMBERS.
DEFINITENESS ADDITION REPORTS
CONTAIN EXPENSIVE PRIVATE AND
HIGHLY SENSITIVE INFORMATION.
MUCH OF WHICH MAY ULTIMATELY
HAVE NO BEARING ON THE CAUSE
AND MANNER OF DEATH BUT IS
INCLUDED. TO PROVIDE A
COMPREHENSIVE PROFILE OF THE
DECEASED. ITEMS THAT ARE
CONFIDENTIAL IF FOUGHT WHEN THE
PERSON IS LIVING ARE NOT
PROTECTED WHEN A PERSON HAS
DIED AND AN AUTOPSY CALLED FOR.
VENTURA COUNTY POLICE THIS
DISPARATE TREATMENT OF RECORDS
IS WORTHY OF THE LEGISLATURE'S
CONSIDERATION. AND THE
BORDERLINE CASE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE UNDERSCORE
THAT THE FULL DEPTH
INVESTIGATION RECORDS HAVE
ALREADY BEEN RELEASED. BOTH FOR
CERTAIN HE WAS AND THE
BORDERLINE SHOOTER. NEITHER
RECORD WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR
ENHANCED PRIVACY PROTECTIONS
EVEN IF AB TWO SIX EIGHT S.
PROPOSED WERE ALREADY ENACTED.
IT'S ALSO CRITICAL TO NOTE WHAT
REMAINS EXPLICITLY ACCESSIBLE
TO THE PUBLIC UNDER EXISTING
LAW AND UNDER THE PROVISIONS OF
AB TWO SIX EIGHT. SPECIFICALLY
THE INFORMATION CONTAINED IN
THE DEATH CERTIFICATE INCLUDING
THE DECEDENT'S NAME AGE GENDER
RACE. AND OF COURSE IMPORTANTLY
THE CAUSE AND MANNER OF DEATH
AMONG OTHER DETAILS. ALSO ONE
CHANGE THIS ACCESS BY SPECIFIC
AGENCIES AND INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE A LEGAL OR INVESTIGATORY
NEED TO ACCESS THE RECORDS.
INCLUDING VENTURA COUNTY COUNTY
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THIS
COMMITTEES POSITIVE
CONSIDERATION OF A MODEST BUT
NECESSARY CHANGE TO RESISTING
LAW. A CHANGE THAT DOES NOT AS
SOME OPPONENTS SUGGEST THROW
THE DOOR OPEN TO A WHOLESALE
EXEMPTION TO THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT. THE NARROW
IMPACT OF THE BILL HAS BEEN
VASTLY OVERSTATED IN VARIOUS
ADVOCACY PIECES AND OPPONENTS
OF OFFERED EXAMPLES WHERE IT'S
CRYSTAL CLEAR THAT AB TWO SIX
EIGHT WOULD NOT AND COULD NOT
APPLY. INCLUDING COVERT RELATED
DEATHS AND DRUG OVERDOSES. A
COUNTY VENTURA SINCERELY
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLYMEMBER OWENS
LEADERSHIP. AND WE STAND WITH
THE BORDER LINE FAMILIES AND
SEEKING THIS NARROW BUT
IMPORTANT CHANGE TO LOS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY DO WE ALSO HAVE
A MARKER FINALS ON THE LINE AS
A WITNESS. YES YEAH THIS IS
SEEKING HEARING YES PLEASE
PLEASE PROCEED YEAH. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MARCO
FINALS. I'M FROM THOUSAND OAKS
CALIFORNIA AND IS FORTY BE TWO
SIXTY EIGHT I THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT BILL THE WILL PROVIDE
A DEGREE OF PRIVACY AND
PROTECTION TO VICTIMS OF
VIOLENT CRIMES. THIS
PROTECTIONS ALREADY AFFORDED OF
VICTIMS UNDER AGE EIGHTEEN AND
THIS BILL WILL EXTEND THAT
PROTECTION TO VICTIMS EIGHTEEN
AND OVER. MY SON TELEMARKETER.
HELLO WITH ELEVEN OTHERS WITH
CHILDREN BASH HERE ON NOVEMBER
SEVENTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN AT
FORTY ONE BORN GIRL HAS
PREVIOUS PREVIOUSLY STATED AND
SINCE THAT DAY WE HAVE STRUGGLE
WITH CONSTANT DEPRESSION
ANXIETY AND DESPAIR AS OF TODAY
THERE'S BEEN EIGHT HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY ONE DAYS. SINCE I WAS
LAST TO HUG MY SON'S HERE IS
VOICE AND SEE YOUR SMILE SMITH
EIGHT HUNDRED AND SEVENTY ONE
DAYS OF CONSTANT HEARTACHE AND
TORMENT. IT IS A NIGHTMARE THAT
DOES NOT END AND BECAUSE OF THE
VERY PUBLIC NATURE OF MY SON'S
DEATH WE SUFFER ADDITIONAL
TRIBULATION WE HAVE BEEN
SUBJECTED TO MALICIOUS AND
CALLOUSED LETTERS. EMAILS
INTERNET POSTS FROM PEOPLE WHO
HAVE ACCESS TO OUR INFORMATION
ONLINE THIS IS A CRITICAL
REASON TO PROTECT CERTAIN
AUTOPSY RECORDS. ONE CERTAIN
INFORMATION BECOMES PUBLIC IT
BECOMES FODDER FOR TROLLS
CONSPIRACY THEORISING COPY CATS
AND IT SERVES NO PUBLIC GOOD.
PLEASE CONSIDER THE IMPACT THIS
HAS ON VICTIMS FAMILIES MY
YOUNGER SON DID NOT GO TO SEE
HIS. BODY AS IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
TOO DRAMATIC MANY OF THE
FAMILIES OF BORDERLINE VICTIMS
HAVE DELIBERATELY AVOIDED THE
DETAILS OF THEIR LOVED ONES
DEATHS. AS THE SPECIFICS YOU TO
HORRIFIC. AND CONSIDER. THE
HUNDREDS OF OTHER PEOPLE THAT
WERE THERE THAT NIGHT. THEY ARE
TRAUMATIZED THEY ARE SUFFERING
AS IS OUR COMMUNITY AT LARGE IF
THIS INFORMATION IS ARBITRARILY
RELEASED. IT WILL ENDANGER THE
MENTAL HEALTH. OF COUNTLESS
PEOPLE NOW I UNDERSTAND THERE
MIGHT BE CIRCUMSTANCES WHEN
ACCESS TO THIS INFORMATION IS
NECESSARY. AND AS PREVIOUSLY
STATED AB TWO SIXTY EIGHT
ACCOMMODATES THOSE CONCERNS.
PLEASE REMEMBER WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT HUMAN BEINGS PLEASE DON'T
REDUCE OUR LOVED ONES IT'S JUST
A STATISTIC OR PIECE OF
EVIDENCE MY SON IS NOT JUST A
NAME ON THE PAGE. DESPITE HIS
BEING KILLED HE IS STILL A
PERSON HE'S STILL MY SON AND
ALWAYS WILL BE HE DESERVES
PRIVACY AND PROTECTION AND
DIGNITY. SLASH I THINK WE HAVE
SUFFERED ENOUGH I IMPLORE YOU
RESPECT OUR DEAD HELP MITIGATE
OUR SUFFERING AND DIVORCE AB
TWO SIXTY EIGHT. TO ALLOW US IN
THOUSANDS OF OTHER PEOPLE LIKE
US WHO SUFFERS SIMILAR
CIRCUMSTANCES PLEASE ALLOW SOME
MODICUM OF THESE. THANK THANK
YOU SIR- WHERE DOES ALL THE
WITNESSES PREMATURE IRWIN. DOES
THE AT THIRDS EITHER WAY YES
NOW WITNESSES IN THE IN THE-
ASSEMBLY ROOM. SEEING NONE ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES ON THE
VIDEO CONFERENCING. HEARING
NONE- EIGHTY TWO YOU CAN NOW
OPEN UP THE TELEPHONE FOR
SUPPORT OF MR WENT BILL. AB TWO
SIXTY FIVE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR
AB Q. SIX EIGHT PRESS ONE THEN
THEY'RE ON NOW AGAIN TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR A BI. TWO SIX EIGHT
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO NOW.
NOW LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE ONE IN
THE QUEUE ARE WE ACCEPT THREE
NOW WELL FIRST SCHOOL TRYING
THREE FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WHO SHALL
MUTCHLER HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS THEY
CALIFORNIA STATE CORONERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY TWO SIXTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND ACCESSIBLE
TO LINE THREE FIFTY NINE PEOPLE
HAD. GOOD AFTERNOON REBEKAH
MARKETS ON BEHALF OF THE BRADY
CAMPAIGN IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SIX EIGHT. THANK YOU. AND I
VERY MINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT
PRESS THE ONE THAN THEIR OWN
NOW. DID YOU COMPLETED NOW AND
THAT. YEP THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
IN THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU BYE. NEXT BERNIE. WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION I THINK I HAVE
BRITNEY PART SAUDI IN C. N. P.
A. AND MARGARET GEORGE CD
EIGHT. YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR HAVE ON
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS FOR A BAR
SAUDI AND I AM GENERAL COUNSEL
FOR THE CALIFORNIA PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION AND- WE MUCH WE'RE
ACTUALLY OPPOSE EIGHTY THREE
FIFTY FIVE ASSEMBLY WOMAN I
WENT- FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO
BEGIN BY OFFERING MIGHT BE
INVOLVED WITH THE FAMILIES OF
THE VICTIMS OF THE BORDERLINE.
SHOOTING THE- CHECK A BAG AND-
NOTHING CAN REALLY TAKE A POINT
AND I'M SORRY FOR THAT-
LEANDER'S THEM RESPECT FEELINGS
OF THIS BUDGET. TO PROTECT THE
PRIVACY OF THE BIKINI THE LAST
ONE I A FIFTY LAW ALL PROVED
SAFEGUARDS TO THOSE. UNDER THE
CURRENT SHARE. I WILL COR IT
THANK SEE AND COMING THAT
SHOULD BE ONE- THE HOLDER OF
THE FOR AS THE CALL OR THE AGE.
WILL WITHHOLD COURSE OF THESE
AND THEY USE THAT- THE
PROVISIONS THAT. IT'S HERE A
PROVIDER PROBABLY BALANCE
BETWEEN THE RIGHT CANNELLA
OTHER INTERESTS. SUCH AS
PRIVACY. DOES NOT X. WITH OF
CODE THAT WAS ONLY IN TO APPLY
TO. ABOUT HOW TO REPORT- THAT
PARA REQUEST BPO I JUST TO NOTE
THAT WRECKED THE WAY IT'S-
ESSENTIAL IN OUR WAY. TREATED
THROUGHOUT. OUR SYSTEM AND I
THEY SHOULD BE THIS WILL TAKES
A LIMITED. AND EXPERIENCE TO
INCLUDE ALL ADULTS WHO DIED AS
THE RESULT A CRIMINAL ACT. THE
CARD PERPETRATOR THINKING BACK
TO THEIR BAG. UNFORTUNATELY
THERE ARE REPORTERS REGULARLY
RELY ON THE AUTOPSY REPORT
AGAINST. WILL TURN PASADENA
BECAUSE MEREDITH- ARE AMERICAN.
PUBLIC IT WAS NOT HEALTHY FOR
THAT WOULD BE A HOW COME BUT
ARE HARD BY PARTS MY BRUSH TO
MEET. TO FOR OUR BREAK. IN ALL
IN. WITH THE ABILITY TO CLOSE
HE SAID THAT THAT SESSION THAT.
RECORD WILL HELP SIGN A LIGHT
ON THE EXAM OFFICE AND COUNTY
WHERE THE SIGNED OFF ON ON TOP
FROM ASSISTANCE WOULD NOT
SURPRISE TO PROVIDE FOR MY MOM
WAS ON THE BIG CASE. THE FACT
MAY NOT HAVE BEEN A FAMILY
MEMBERS YEAH ARE TOP. AND
SECULAR A PERSON DIES BUT- I
THOUGHT RECORD HELP THE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR AGE. TO BRING
LIGHT PREVIOUS UNDER FACTORS
LEADING TO OF COURSE INSTEAD
FOR EXAMPLE- BOB FAMILY MEMBERS
MAY NOT REQUEST DEAL RECORDS-
AUTOPSIES PERFORMED FROM.
PEOPLE SHOULD BE- OTHER
EXAMPLES I MENTIONED. IS
IMPORTANT AND- IMPORTANT
BELIEVE ACCESS ACCESS TO THESE
RECORDS ACHIEVED GREAT ON THE
BUYERS THE PUBLIC CONCERT. OUR
WOULD GIVE THE- IT WAS.
FAMILIES AND HE'S YET GREAT.
THREE MINUTE RAPID THAT. I IT-
I LIKE TO KNOW A LOT- THERE
FORTY MINUTES UNDER BETWEEN THE-
WHEN PERSON OR I AT THE BAR AND
THE BOARD JUDY HAS THAT CAN
FULLY ACCOUNT CORD THE TOP
RECORDS NOT THERE RELEASED
THERE'S ELEVEN THAT WERE. BEING
HELD BECAUSE- AND REGARDLESS OF
WHAT THE RECORDS SHOWED PUBLIC
HAVE THE OP TO MAKE AN THE
EFFECT HOUSING NEGATIVE OR
INCLUDES EARLY BILLS IF THE
BILL WERE EVERY ON- AND- YOU
BURKE ACTUALLY- SURE NO ABOUT
AND I STAND LINE YOU HAVE.
BECAUSE YOU MAY HAVE. MISS
GEORGE YOU HAVE A MINUTE. OKAY
WELL- AND MARK CHORE AND ON MY
OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDER SYSTEM. OF COURSE I
WOULD ECHO THE SENTIMENTS THAT
THE SPORT OUR SOCIETY HAD ABOUT
THE FAMILY MEMBERS OF THE
VICTIMS YOU KNOW I'M VERY SORRY
FOR YOUR LOSS I CAN'T IMAGINE
THAT- I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHORS OFFICE FLOOR OUR
DISCUSSIONS BUT UNFORTUNATELY.
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION REMAIN SUPPOSED TO
A BE TO SIXTY EIGHT. FOR THE
FOLLOWING REASONS- IT
UNDERMINES SB FOURTEEN TWENTY
ONE LANDMARK LEGISLATION THIS
BODY CHEST PASSED THREE YEARS
AGO WHICH- AMENDED THE PENAL
CODE TO REQUIRE THAT POLICE
OFFICER AN AGENCY RECORDS.
SPECIFICALLY INCLUDING AUTOPSY
REPORTS FROM POLICE INVOLVED
KILLINGS ARE NOT CONFIDENTIAL
AND AVAILABLE FOR PUBLIC
INSPECTION UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT. AND ON THE
SAME PIECE OF LEGISLATION ALSO
GAVE TO THE AGENCY THE ABILITY
TO READ JACK DOES- AUTOPSY
REPORTS AS APPROPRIATE. S. FOUR
TWENTY ONE WAS PASSED BEFORE
THE NATIONAL OUTRAGE IN THE
WAKE OF THE TORCH FLOYD AND
BRIANNA TAYLOR KILLINGS THAT'S
FOLLOWED AN EARLIER WAVE OF
HIGH PROFILE POLICE SHOOTINGS
AND KILLINGS THIS IS NOT THE
TIME TO WHITTLE AWAY OR CHIP
AWAY AT SB FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE.
ALSO I WOULD ADD THAT THIS IS
NOT. THIS IS BAD PUBLIC POLICY
BECAUSE IT TAKES THE ABILITY TO
BALANCE THE PUBLIC'S RIGHT TO
KNOW AGAINST THE PRIVACY
INTERESTS OF THE INDIVIDUAL.
AWAY FROM NEUTRAL JUDGES AND
GIVE THE FEATHER PARTY TO
PRIVATE CITIZENS AND POLICE OR
PROSECUTORS- WE KNOW FROM.
ASKED WE HAVE THE EXAMPLE OF
THE AUTOPSY OF ANDRES. GUARDADO
IN ASIA A YOUNG MAN WHO THE
MEDICAL EXAMINER EXAMINER
DETERMINED WAS SHOT IN THE BACK
FIVE TIMES AND KILLED BY A LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPUTY. MAJORITY LEASING ME ON
HER LAPTOP YES YEAH THIS IS AN
EXAMPLE. AND WHERE YES I'M
GOING TO WRAP UP THIS IS AN
EXAMPLE WHERE THIS- SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE IS VITAL SO WE
WOULD- THIS IS A DECISION
BETTER LEFT TO THE COURTS AND
THERE'S ON GOING LITIGATION
BATTLE REGARDING THE BORDERLINE
VICTIMS AUTOPSY REPORTS. HELLO
CPD A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
NO VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU. I
NO OTHER ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
THE ROOM IN OPPOSITION ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
TELECONFERENCING LINE AND
EIGHTY TWO YOU CAN NOW OPEN UP
THE TELEPHONE LINES FOR ANY
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND I CURRENTLY
HAVE ONE LINE IN Q. OR TRYING
TO REACH SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON. KATHY
SURE ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION. OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I DO HAVE
ONE MORE COMMENT CHEN Q. IT'LL
JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR THAT
LINE. AND WE'RE TRYING TO
EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR TAKING MY CALL AND
THANK YOU FOR EVERYONE THAT IS
LISTENING TO THIS TODAY WHO
WILL BE AFFECTED BY THIS TODAY
AND WHO'S TAKEN THE TIME CARE
AND CONSIDERATION TO LISTEN. MY
NAME IS LINDA LEWIS MILLER I AM
HERE TODAY REPRESENTING A WING
OF JUSTICE WITH AN ORGANIZATION
THAT I STARTED AFTER MY BROTHER
DAVID EDWARD LEWIS WAS MURDERED
EACH DAY. THEY MURDERED. IT WE
HAD TIME FOR HIS NAME AN
ORGANIZATION. SUPPORT IN YOUR
IN SUPPORT CORRECT. HELLO. DO
WE LOSE OUR. I THINK WE GOT
YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION. SO
THANK YOU. UNDER ANY OTHERS
AT&T I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME OKAY
THANK YOU ANY WILL BRING YOU
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS- REBEKAH POWER K. AND
THEN MISTER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LEE. AND THEN- MISS SHE'S AFTER
THE FLEX. WELL I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL. MINISTERS THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL I THINK YOU
KNOW I HAVE A CONSISTENT.
RECORD OF VOTING FOR
TRANSPARENCY I THINK
TRANSPARENCY IS TANTAMOUNT TO
WHAT WE DO AND WHAT THE
GOVERNMENT DOES- AND I HAVE
SUPPORTED MISS SCANNERS WORK ON
TRANSPARENCY AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT THAT BEING SAID. I
THINK THAT YOU HAVE CRAFTED A
BILL HERE THAT DOES WHAT VERY
FEW BILLS THAT COME BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE DOES WHICH IS PROTECT
VICTIMS. AND THESE INDIVIDUALS
AND MISTER FINAL I WANT TO
SPEAK DIRECTLY TO YOU AS A
PARENT I CAN'T EVEN IMAGINE THE
LOSS YOU FEEL. AND THE FACT
THAT YOUR CHILD WILL FOREVER BE
YOUR CHILD WAS OVER THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN DENIED YOU THE RIGHT
TO THIS PROTECTION IS WRONG.
FULL STOP. AND YOU KNOW THIS IS
A VERY VERY NARROWLY CRAFTED
BILL. AND I WANT THAT TO BE A
100% CLEAR. BECAUSE NOT ONLY
DOES IT ONLY APPLY IN A VERY
NARROW SET OF CIRCUMSTANCES ONE
IN WHICH SOMEBODY HAS BEEN
CONVICTED. OF THE CRIME AT
ISSUE OR THE PERSON WHO
COMMITTED THE CRIME IS KNOWN TO
BE DECEASED. SO MANY OF THE
EXAMPLES GIVEN BY THE
OPPOSITION. AREN'T RELEVANT OR
SOMEONE IS ALLEGED DIED OF AN
OVERDOSE. THERE IS NO CRIMINAL
ACT WITH SOMEONE WHO HAS JUST
BEEN DECEASED OR- CONVICTED OF
A CRIME SO IN THAT CIRCUMSTANCE
THIS BILL WOULD NOT APPLY. THE
SAME IS TRUE OF MR JUST
COMMENT. OF OFFICER INVOLVED
SHOOTINGS AND LEFT THE OFFICER
HAD BEEN CONVICTED. OR THE
OFFICER IS DECEASED IN WHICH
CASE. THE TRANSPARENCY IS THERE
RIGHT THE VINCE OFFICERS BEEN
CONVICTED OF THE MURDER WHY DO
YOU NEED. IN THAT CASE THE
PERSONAL DETAILS OF THESE
PERSON THESE PEOPLE OF LIFE
THAT FEELS. THEY'VE ALREADY
BEEN VICTIMIZED IN THE WORST
POSSIBLE WAY. WE TO VICTIMIZE
THEM AGAIN BY ALLOWING THE
PERSONAL DETAILS OF THEIR LIFE
AT THE TIME OF THEIR DEATH TO
BE RELEASED. THAT FEELS. TO ME
JUST WRONG AND I WANTED TO JUST
SPEAK TO THE ISSUE BECAUSE I
THINK THAT. THERE WAS A LOT OF
DISINGENUOUS COMMENTS MADE BY
THE OPPOSITION WHERE THE BILL
WOULD NOT APPLY. AND I THINK
THAT THIS IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT
STEP. IN PROTECTING PEOPLE WHO
HAVE PAID. A PRICE THE NEW.
WANTS THEIR LOVED ONE TO PAY
AND SO THE- THE SIMPLE ACT OF
PROTECTING THEIR PRIVACY AND
DEATH FEELS. RIGHT AND JUST AND
I WANT TO AND I'M EXCITED TO
SUPPORT THE BILL AND I WOULD
LIKE TO ADD AS A CO AUTHOR.
THANK YOU MISTER LEE. I JUST
WANT TO ECHO SOME OF- SIMILAR
ABOUT CANS COMMENTS ABOUT IT
AND I AND I REALLY THINK-
SIMILAR WOULD FOR WORKING WITH
MY OFFICE AND WORK WITH ME TO
UNDERSTAND THE NARROWNESS OF
THE PROVISIONS OF THE BILL
CERTAINLY I DON'T WANT THIS
BILL TO UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
AND MESS UP THE PROGRESS WE'VE
MADE WITH SB FOURTEEN TWENTY
ONE BUT CAN I ASK THE
OPPOSITION THAT'S ON THE IF
THEY'RE STILL ON THE LINE LIKE.
BECAUSE I UNDERSTAND THE BILL
AND AS SOME OF OUR CAN'T TALK
ABOUT IT'S ONLY POST CONVICTION
AND POST DEATH OF PERHAPS AN
OFFICER SO HOW DOES THIS INNER
WITH SB TWENTY ONE AND THERE
BUT I'M STILL TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND OUR. SO AFTER THAT.
YES PLEASE. YES YES PLEASE-
OKAY. OKAY SO WHAT. ON MY END
IS THAT IN THE WALL SHE- IN THE-
FIRST AN OFFICER ONCE- FRIENDLY
FIRE AND IT TOO I UNDERSTAND
ALTHOUGH I GUESS IT'S STILL YOU
KNOW THAT'S PART OF THE REASON
THE AUTOPSIES ARE AT ISSUE
THERE'S AN ISSUE OF WHETHER OR
NOT. SOME OF THE VICTIMS WOULD
HAVE DIED BUT FOR THE DELAY IN
THE POLICE RESPONSE. SO THAT I
BELIEVE I'LL GO TO THE PUBLIC.
INTEREST REASONS THAT THESE
PARTICULAR AUTOPSIES ARE AT
ISSUE AND YOU KNOW NO ONE I
DON'T THINK ANYONE KNOWS THE
ANSWER TO THOSE QUESTIONS
EXCEPT THE CORNER. WHAT UP
PERHAPS AND NOT THE BORDERLINE
SITUATION THE MORE TYPICAL
POLICE MISCONDUCT CASE OR
CIVILIAN MIGHT HAVE BEEN
MURDERED BY POLICE WHICH IS WHY
SB FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE IS
ULTIMATELY GOING FOR. MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
PRESIDENT BUSH POTTERY THE BILL
GIVES BIRTH FAMILY MEMBERS BUT
POWER TO HEAL THE AUTOPSY- AND-
WHILE THEY MAY NOT LAST A
FAIRLY. LATE REQUESTED YOU THAT
AND THAT AND THEN SOME OF THESE
INVOLVED SHOULD IT. DOWN BY MY
READING GIVES THEM THE POWER.
TO DO SO. I THINK THE THRISSUR
AND MISS. WICKS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AS WEARING- AS A
MEMBER IRWIN IF YOU COULD
ACTUALLY ANSWER THE QUESTION OF
YOUR INTERPRETATION OF YOUR
BILLS IMPACT ON US SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE YEAH SO- BUT WITH-
SB FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE
OBVIOUSLY HUGELY IMPORTANT-
WHAT SB OF FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE
DOES IS IT IMMEDIATELY MAKES
ALL THE INFORMATION WE ARE
ABLE. SO WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
THE CONVICTION SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE IS ALREADY IN PLACE
AND THAT IS FOR YOU KNOW
SPECIFICALLY WHEN- OFFICER-
DISCHARGES FIREARMS AT A PERSON
AND THEN THE I WOULD I WOULD
ALSO- YOU KNOW I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU ALMOST TAKING
MY- MY CLOSING FOR ME. THE
EXAMPLES THAT THEY ARE THAT THE
BOTH THE PUBLISHERS AND THE
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ARE CITING ARE
NONE OF THEM ARE AFFECTED OF BY
SB TWO TWO SIX EIGHT AND SO IT
IT AGAIN THIS IS VERY NARROWLY
TAILORED AND I WILL ALSO SAY
THAT THERE ARE TWENTY STATES
THAT THINK THESE RECORDS ARE SO
PRIVATE THAT THEY SHOULDN'T BE
RELEASED TO THE PUBLIC. AND ALL
AND BOOK BETWEEN SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE- AND THE VERY-
NARROWNESS OF THIS BILL THERE
ARE ONLY A FEW- RECORDS THAT
ARE GOING TO BE PROTECTED AND
SO FROM THE FREEMEN YOU'RE AT
AND IT MUST BE REQUESTED BY A
FAMILY THAT RIGHT AND SO FROM
YOUR INTERPRETATION. YOUR BILL
WOULD NOT OVERRIDE SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE THAT'S RIGHT OKAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER C.
R. TO. RIGHT FIRST I WANT THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING A BILL LIKE
THIS- YEAH ISSUE HITS A LITTLE
BIT CLOSER HOME. WENT TO
CALDERON. AT THE TIME. YEAH IT
WAS PRETTY SCARY. BUT
FORTUNATELY THAT WASN'T THE
NIGHT THAT SHE CHOSE TO GO OUT
WITH HER FRIENDS. UNFORTUNATELY
IT WAS THE NIGHT FOR THIS
VICTIM THAT WE HEARD ON THE
PHONE. AND THAT'S WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT. THIS ABOUT PROTECTING
VICTIMS AND TOO MUCH IN HERE I
HEAR ABOUT NOT PROTECTING
VICTIMS. SO WHEN YOU BRING A
BILL LIKE THIS TO PROTECT
VICTIMS. I'M GOING TO SUPPORT
IT. BECAUSE BECAUSE THERE IS NO
REASON. TO CONTINUE THAT TRAUMA
FOR PEOPLE LIKE THAT GENTLEMAN
THAT WAS ON THE PHONE. OVER AND
OVER AND OVER IN MY CAREER I'VE
SEEN THIS IT'S GROSS. PEOPLE
USE THIS I USE THIS FOR
SENSATIONALISM TO SELL THEIR
THEIR PAPERS THEY USE IT TO
EXCEL- YOU KNOW IT IT DID IT
DID DID GAIN NOTORIETY
BASICALLY FOR THEIR WEBSITES
AND THINGS LIKE THAT PARENTS
CAN'T CONTINUE TO BE
TRAUMATIZED BY THINGS LIKE THAT
SO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
AYE CONTENT TO SUPPORT IT AND-
I THINK IT'S NARROW ENOUGH TO
BE ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH THAT
WITHOUT INFRINGING ON THE
OTHER- THAT HAVE BEEN BROUGHT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR ANY
OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBER. IT
THANK YOU MISTER LUCKY. YEAH I
WANTED TO THE WITNESS WHO SPOKE
EARLIER- THANK YOU FOR HAVING
THE COURAGE TO BRING. SOMETHING
FOR DO YOU KNOW. I'VE BEEN ON
THIS COMMITTEE FOR SOME TIME
NOW AND HOPEFULLY WILL CONTINUE
TO BE FOR A PERIOD OF TIME BUT
WHAT ONE THING I WILL TELL YOU
THAT'S VERY CONSISTENT.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S THAT'S
VERY. SALIENT FACT VICTIMS GET
OVERSHADOWED. AND THE
CONSIDERATIONS THAT ARE BROUGHT
FORWARD HERE. AND IT'S VERY
HEARTBREAKING ESPECIALLY WHEN
YOU HEAR THAT PARENT. I'VE SEEN
TOO MANY. TRAGIC CIRCUMSTANCES.
WHERE THE VICTIM GETS FORGOTTEN
AND I'M JUST THANKFUL YOU
BROUGHT THIS FORWARD BECAUSE-
THIS PRIVACY PROTECTIONS. ARE
SO NARROW HOW CAN YOU VOTE
AGAINST THIS. I THANK YOU FOR
THIS. THANK YOU ARE ANY OTHER
MEMBERS REDDING. YOU MAY CLOSE.
WELL I THINK THE COMMENTS HAVE
BASICALLY MADE MY- CLOTHES FOR
ME I WANT TO APOLOGIZE TO. I'VE
NEED TO ITEMIZE MY HEART IS
WITH YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER SWORE
TO THERE WERE MANY MANY OF US
IN THOUSAND OAKS THAT NIGHT.
THAT HUG OUR CHILDREN BECAUSE
THAT WAS THE NIGHT THEY DECIDED
NOT TO GO TO BORDERLINE AND I
ALWAYS WILL ALSO WANT TO SAY ON
THE TRANSPARENCY ISSUE WE HAVE.
SEEN HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS OF PAGES RELEASED ON
WHAT EXACTLY HAPPENED SECOND BY
SECOND. AND SO I JUST REALLY
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS THIS BILL
THAT'S IT- WILL HELP. FAMILY
MEMBERS PRESERVE THE PRECIOUS
REMAINING MEMORIES THEY HAVE OF
THEIR LOVED ONES. THANK YOU
YOU'RE WELCOME IN. FIRST
CALDERON. ON AB TWO SIX EIGHT
BY THE MEMBER IRWIN THE MISSION
IS TO PASS TO THE PRIVACY
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER NOT
BOATING JONES SAWYER NOT VOTING
BLACKIE BLACKIE AND BARRICADE
HAVE AND CAN I WORK HARD WORK
ACCENT IAGO. THEY ARE TERRIFIED
ARE TO WAKE. WEEKS I. LEE NOT
VOTING HELPS GIVE ME LEAD TIME.
THE MEASURE PASSES. AND NOW
WILL HAVE MISSED TOM LOGGER. AB.
THREE THREE THREE.
PARTICIPATION IN A CRIMINAL
STREET GANG ENHANCE SENTENCE.
WE USUALLY DON'T ALLOW SENATORS
TO GRACE OUR PRESENCE. BEFORE
IT'S THEIR TIME BUT SINCE
YOU'RE A FORMER MEMBER OF TO
STEAM COMMITTEE WE'RE GOING TO
ALLOW AN EXCEPTION- THANK YOU
I'M PRETENDING. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. HI JUST
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTES. I KNOW
HI- FLOOD YOU ALL FOR. I WATCH
THIS COMMITTEE- HERE PUTTING IN
THE HOURS MY FRIENDS- I WILL
JUST SAY DURING MY TENURE AS A
MEMBER OF THE PENAL CODE
REVISION COMMITTEE THIS PAST
YEAR I'VE LISTENED TO OVER
FIFTY HOURS OF TESTIMONY
DETAILING ISSUES. WITH A NUMBER
OF CRIMINAL JUSTICE STATUTES
AND ONE STEP STEP ONE SUCH
STATUTE WAS THE STEP STEP ACT
RELATING TO GANG ENHANCEMENTS
THE MATTER WAS SO PRESSING. AND
THE INJUSTICES SO EGREGIOUS
THAT REVISIONS TO THE STATUTE
WERE ONE OF TEN RECOMMENDATIONS
THE COMMITTEE SUBMITTED TO THE
GOVERNOR AND LEGISLATURE
RESULTING IN THIS BILL.
CURRENTLY GANG ENHANCEMENTS ARE
OFTEN USED FOR PHYLLIS LEE AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY AGAINST
PEOPLE OF COLOR. BLACK AND LET
NEXT PEOPLE COMPRISE 92% OF THE
PEOPLE SENTENCED. UNDER OURS
CALIFORNIA GANG ENHANCEMENT
STATUTE IN IN LOS ANGELES MY
COUNTY THAT NUMBER IS 98% YET
RESEARCH BY THE JUSTICE POLICY
INSTITUTE SHOWS THAT WHITE
PEOPLE MAKE UP THE LARGEST
GROUP OF YOUTH GANG MEMBERS AND
AS THEY MATURE. THEY WILL BE AN
ADULT GANGS. IT IS DIFFICULT TO
IMAGINE A STATUTE ESPECIALLY
ONE THAT IMPOSES CRIMINAL
PUNISHMENTS WITH THE MORE
DISPARATE RACIAL IMPACT. THIS
BILL MAKES CHANGES TO THE LAW
THAT WILL REDUCE THE DAMAGING
ARBITRARY AND RACIALLY
MOTIVATED APPLICATION OF GANG
ENHANCEMENTS. IN CRIMINAL CASES
AND MAKES THE STANDARDS FOR
APPLYING A GANG ENHANCEMENT
MORE RIGOROUS I JUST WANT TO
STATE. THAT THIS BILL DOES NOT
SEEK TO MAKE THE APPLICATION OF
A GANG ENHANCEMENT IMPOSSIBLE
AS WAS WRITTEN IN SOME OF THE
LETTERS NOR DOES IT ELIMINATE
IT ENTIRELY IT WOULD REQUIRE
THAT SUFFICIENT EVIDENCE BE
PROVIDED WHICH IS WHAT I THINK
WE ASK FOR. IN ALL INSTANCES
AND IT WOULD ENSURE THAT GANG
ENHANCEMENTS ARE APPLIED TO THE
SERIOUS AND VIOLENT OFFENSES
AND WHERE IT CAN BE PROVEN THAT
THE PATTERN CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR.
DIRECTLY CORRESPONDS WITH THE
GANG AFFILIATION. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE CLEAR
LIMITATIONS AND DELINEATIONS
WHEN WE ARE ALLEGING. GANG
INVOLVEMENT AND CURRENTLY WE
HAVE JUST THE OPPOSITE WE HAVE
VAGUE DEFINITIONS WE HAVE WEAK
STANDARDS OF PROOF. WE KNOW
THAT THESE GANG ENHANCEMENTS
COME AT A STEEP FISCAL AND
HUMAN COSTS TO OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND THEY ARE RACIALIZED TOOL
THREADED BY FEAR OF GANG AND
GANG MEMBERSHIP TO SENTENCE
BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE TO
LONGER PERIODS OF TIME BEHIND
BARS. THIS BILL WOULD IN THE
ABILITY OF PROSECUTORS TO CLAIM
PEOPLE ARE GANG MEMBERS SIMPLY
BECAUSE THEY COME FROM THE SAME
COMMUNITY. OR KNOW EACH OTHER
OR ARE RELATED IT WOULD
PROHIBIT THE USE OF THE GANG
THE CURRENT CHARGED OFFENSE AS
A PROOF OF PATTERN IT WOULD.
REMOVE CERTAIN. VIOLATIONS FROM
THE LIST OF PREDICATE OFFENSES.
AND IT WOULD REQUIRE DIRECT
EVIDENCE HOW ABOUT THAT AND
BIFURCATE DIRECT EVIDENCE OF
GANG INVOLVEMENT FROM THE GUILT
DETERMINATION AT TRIAL. HERE
WITH ME AND SUPPORT ARGUE CERRO
HERRERA OF THE YOUNG WOMEN'S
FREEDOM CENTER AND CHESAPEAKE
DEAN DISTRICT ATTORNEY FOR THE
CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO AND I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. ARM OKAY I'M
READY MY NAME OF LOS ON THAT
ARE ON THIS. HELLO WE YOU. OKAY
MY NAME IS LOOK AT ON THAT ARE
THE PHONE TERMINATE QUARTER AT
YOUNG ONE TO BECOME. BOARD NFL
MY MOTHER HER COUNTRY DUE TO
THE GOVERNMENT POLITICAL
VIOLENCE THAT'S INTO THE SO WAR.
THE BILL MILITARY FACT TO KILL
TO YOU VIOLENCE. MY CAME TO THE
UNITED STATES OKAY. AND CORRUPT
ONLY THREE THREE MUCH THE THING
HERE. WHAT THE TOPIC THAT THE
MISSION THIS FOR MANY OF OUR
AND FAMILY WERE. IN LATE
MEMBERS. WHEN I SEVENTEEN YEARS
I WAS CHARGE OTHER ADULT THE
GANG AND- NUMBER EIGHT BIRTHDAY
I WILL CONTACT THE DOCTOR JAIL.
MY BROTHER WAS ON PROPER FAR IN
THE SUPPORTED AND- EIGHT. AND
WHAT MURDER AND I THOUGHT I
INTO THOUSAND NINE. MAR LIKE
MANY OTHER CRAP COME TO THE U.
STATES BECAUSE THE LACK OF
RESOURCES. AND EXTORTION BUT
INSTEAD OF FROM VIOLENCE GANG.
WE ARE CRIMINAL BECAUSE OF THE-
AND FOUND WE COME. IT'S ALL
ABOUT THE NINETY SEVENTY. OF
THE STATE PRESS POP. HAS AT
LEAST ONE GETTING. AND MORE
THAN NINETY FOUR OF US ALL WITH
AGAIN AND HAS INTERFACE THAT
THE EITHER BOTH. OR YEAH I CAN
HAVE BELIEVE THE LAW AND IT.
ALL BODY AND SOMETHING BEFORE.
HI BEEN CHARGED WITH THE GANG
AND HAVE I HAVE TO OF THE GANG
THANK YOU A BLUE CAR THAT IT
DOES THE I A GANG MEMBER NOT
ONLY DID A FUEL AS ME TO BEING
BY LAW AND- WHATEVER I WENT AND
MET FACT BRANDON THOUGHT OFTEN
DID NOT OF YOUR. THEY LOOK MORE
AT THE GATE THANK THEM FOR. HE
HAD LEFT ME WITH. EITHER ONE
FEDERAL. AND I'M ONE OF
THOUSAND OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE
HARD. BY CANYON HAS. AND I'M
URGING YOU VOTE YES I AB THREE
THREE. BECAUSE WE NEED TO CHILL.
HELLO EMPEROR PEOPLE NOW BE
HUMAN AND COME. IN CRIMINAL
THEM FOR WHAT LIVE OR THE LOOK.
THE FOR YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION
ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE MY NAME
IS TRACEABLE GAME. BUT I'M
PROUD TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO AS THEIR DISTRICTS
CUTTING. I ALSO WANT TO THANK
SENATOR CALL OTHER PROVIDING ME
TO SPEAK TODAY. AND HER
LEADERSHIP AND COMMITMENT ON
THIS CRITICAL CHANGE IN LAW.
ALSO LIKE ACKNOWLEDGE AND THANK
MUCH SPEAK AND WITNESS TODAY
MISTER HEADED. FROM THE
ELEMENTARY CENTER A CRITICAL.
IN BUILDING SAY. ENCAMPMENTS
AND BEYOND. ONE OF MY FIRST
POLICY DIRECTOR ON TAKE NOT.
WAS TO END THE USE STATUS YES
THE SPECIFICALLY GETTING
ATTACHMENTS AND ESTABLISH A
POLICY BASED ON A PRESUMPTION
THAT THE SENTENCE FOR THE
UNDERLYING CRIME AND THE
ABILITY TO CHARGE APPROPRIATE
CONDUCT ENHANCEMENTS. ARE
ADEQUATE TO HOLD PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE AND PROTECT PUBLIC
SAFETY IN FACT IT WAS A KEY
CAMPAIGN PROMISE I MADE TO THE
PEOPLE OF SAN FRANCISCO DURING
THE CAMPAIGN HERE IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. STATUS SO AND GUESTS
INCLUDING GANG ENHANCEMENTS
SUCH AS THE ONES ADDRESSED IN
THIS LEGISLATION. OUR LEGACY OF
CALIFORNIANS FAILED TOUGH ON
CRIME ERA IN THERE THIS YEAR
OLD NATIONAL CORPORATION. IT
DIFFERENTLY IMPACT AND YOU USE
A COLOR WITHOUT MAKING IT SAFER
BUT WELL BANKRUPTING STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND DEPRIVING
THEM OF RESOURCES NEEDED. TO
INVEST IN AREAS LIKE HEALTH
CARE EDUCATION THAT WE KNOW CAN
PREVENT CRIMES ADULT. STATIONS
ACTIONABLE COMMUNITIES. SB
THIRTY THREE. THREE THREE THREE
PIPELINE A RIGOROUS STANDARDS
THE CURRENT LAW. BY HOLDING US
ALL THE HIGHER CAN. ENSURE THAT
GANG ENHANCEMENTS NO LONGER
CONTRIBUTE TO OVER AND
CORPORATIONS TO HORRIFIC RACIAL
DISPARITIES IN DISPROPORTIONATE.
PUNISHMENTS GETTING HERE PLENTY
HAVE BEEN Y. USED APPROACH
CRITICIZED FOR. TARGET BLACKS
AND BROWN POPULATIONS
PARTICULARLY YOUNG MEN OF COLOR.
RECENT ANALYSIS BY THE LOS
ANGELES CARDS SUGGESTS THAT THE
CAL GAME DATABASE IS WOEFULLY
OUTDATED- HORRIFICALLY
INACCURATE AND RIGHT WHICH
WOULD BE USED UP SOME INSTANCES
OF PEOPLE BEING ENTERED FOR ANY
REASON OR NO REASON AT ALL WITH
THE KIND OF LIFE ALTERING
CONSEQUENCES THAT YOU JUST
HEARD INSTEAD OF. TESTIFIED TO.
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION DATA FROM TWENTY
NINETEEN MORE THAN NINETY
PERCENT. OF ADULTS WITH A GANG
ENHANCEMENT IN STATE PRISON
WERE EITHER BLACK OR LIGHT NEXT
MORE THAN NINETY PERCENT.
ACCORDING TO FLORIDA LAW
PROFESSOR JOHN PASSED AN EXPERT
IN CRIMINOLOGY WHO HAS STUDIED
THE CAUSES AND EFFECTS OF MASS
INCARCERATION. QUOTE THERE IS A
STRONG EMPIRICAL SUPPORT FOR
DECLINING TO CHARGE THE STATUS
AND HENCE MINTS. LONG SENTENCES
IMPOSED BY STRIKE LAWS AND GANG
ENHANCEMENTS PROVIDE LITTLE
ADDITIONAL DETERRENCE. OFTEN
INCAPACITATE LONG PAST WHAT IS
REQUIRED BY PUBLIC SAFETY.
IMPOSE SERIOUS AND AVOIDABLE
FINANCIAL AND PUBLIC HEALTH
COSTS IN THE PROCESS. AND MAY
EVEN LEAD TO GREATER RATES OF
OFFENDING IN THE LONG RUN END
QUOTE. THAT'S ABOUT AS PASSAGE
LANE THAT WOULD RESEARCH A
GROWING BODY OF EVIDENCE BASED
STUDIES HAVE MADE CLEAR THAT
WHAT ACTUALLY DISCOURAGED AND
PREVENTS VIOLENCE AND OTHER
ANTI SOCIAL BEHAVIOR IS NOT THE
THREAT OF A LONG SENTENCE
IMPOSED AT SOME POINT IN THE
DISTANT FUTURE. ONLY IMPOSED IN
THOSE CASES THE MINORITY REPORT
FRANK ABOUT WHAT THE CRIME DATA
SHOWS US WHERE A CRIME GETS
REPORTED RESULTS IN ARREST AND
ARREST THERE'S ALSO NO CHARGE
NO CHARGE RESULTS IN A
CONVICTION KNOW WHAT ACTUAL
DETERS FAR MORE EFFECTIVELY. IS
THE RISK OF DETECTION AND
APPREHENSION IN THE FIRST PLACE
POLICING THE CARS INVESTMENT IN
COMMUNITY AND BUILDING STRONG
FAMILIES TO TURN LONG SENTENCES.
DO LITTLE. AB THREE THREE THREE
WELL KILLED SEXUAL ONE EIGHT
SIX TWO TWO LINDA COLUMN. FIRST
IT WILL END THE ABILITY OF MY
FELLOW PROSECUTORS CLAIM TO
KEEP GETTING WORSE ASSEMBLY.
THEY MAY COME FROM THE SAME
COMMUNITY. WHICH OTHER. FOR IT
COSTS. ADDITIONALLY IT WILL
PRINT USE OF THE CURRENT CHARGE
DEFENSE AS PROOF OF A QUOTE
UNQUOTE PATTERN OF CRIMINAL
GANG ACTIVITY IT WILL FURTHER
REMOVED SPECIFIC CRIMES FROM
THE LIST OF PREDICATE OFFENSES
AND ALLOW GANGS EXPENSE TO BE
CHARGED APPROVING. IT WILL
REQUIRE DIRECT EVIDENCE OF
CURRENT ACTIVE GANG INVOLVEMENT
IN VIOLENCE AND IT WILL
BIFURCATE DIRECT EVIDENCE OF
GANG INVOLVEMENT FROM THE GUILT
DETERMINATION AT TRIAL IN OTHER
WORDS IT WILL HOLD ALL OF US TO
THE HIGH STANDARDS OF THE
PUBLIC DESERVES. IT WILL HELP
IN THAT WAY TO REBUILD
CONFIDENCE AND TRUST IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM AND IT
WILL HELP RESTORE SOME OF THAT
REALLY BADLY DAMAGED
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THE COMMUNITIES
THAT WE HAVE SWORN TO SERVE AND
PROTECT. NOT GETTING HITS WHICH
HAVE BEEN WIDELY CRITICIZED AS
UNFAIRLY TARGETING BLACK AND
BROWN POPULATIONS FOR GOOD
REASON. THIS IS A HISTORIC
OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION TO HOLD OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT PARTNERS TO THE
HIGH STANDARDS AND OUR
COMMUNITIES AND OUR JUDGES AND
OUR JURIES DESERVE AND EXPECT
FROM US IN THIS DAY AND AGE.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN REPAIRING THE
WRONG IT HAS BEEN DONE PLEASE
JOIN. US AT OUR COME WATER IN
VOTING IN FAVOR OF AB THREE
THREE THREE THANK YOU THANK
YOU- ARE THERE. ANY WITNESSES.
HERE IN. IN SUPPORT IN THE IN
THE ROOM ANY ON THE- VIDEO.
COOLEY MISTY OTHER WITNESSES
THE LAST TIME. I SEE IT. IT
LOOKED LIKE WAS COMING ON THE
VIDEO TELECONFERENCING. SO I
WILL GO ON TO WITNESSES ON THE
PHONE OR ANY WITNESSES ON THE
PHONE AT&T. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK OUT IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE THREE THREE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. WE WILL START WITH LINE
NUMBER SEVENTY THREE SEVEN
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO.
HELLO HELLO HELLO YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU. NAME AN ORGANIZATION
I AM IN THE- HI THIS IS ARUN
CARILLO A CALLING ON BEHALF OF
UNITED BROWN COALITIONS AND WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
THREE THREE THREE. THANK YOU.
WELL NOW THAT A LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR THAT'S
ONE FIVE FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
DANNECKER DARNELL ON BEHALF OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE PROUD CO
SPONSOR AB THREE THREE THREE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. WE'RE
GONNA LINE NUMBER THREE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY THAT'S THREE EIGHT
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS
IS JIM WEINBERG ON BEHALF OF A
FRIEND COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
THAT CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. BUT A LINE
NUMBER THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY ONE THAT'S THREE SEVEN
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS
IS KATHY SHARE ON BEHALF OF
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NEXUS LINE NUMBER THREE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY NINE THREE SIX NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
CLEAN IT'S CHEAP AND FROM THE
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION WE
ARE PROUD CO SPONSORS OF AB
THREE THREE THREE. TO TAKE SOME
TIME I'M GOING TO LIST SOME
OTHERS WHO WANTED TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT RATHER THAN
HAVING THEM CALL AND- THAT THEY
ARE PRISON FOCUSED KID
UNIVERSAL. FOR UNITING FAMILIES
CONTRA COSTA. SAN MATEO. COUNTY
PARTICIPATORY DEFENSE.
CALIFORNIA STARTING OVER INC
LEGAL. FOR PRISONERS WHICH- AND
UNDERGROUND COLORS INITIATIVES
FROM OUR TEAM AIRSPEED WE ALSO
HAVE ESTEBAN UNIONS JOSH CAN
YOU. PICK OUT A FEW OF THE V.
AND HENRY MICHAEL MENDOZA AND
SEVERAL MEMBERS HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY GANG ENHANCEMENTS
LISTENING IN RIGHT NOW. WHO ARE
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANKS VERY
MUCH THANK YOU. NEXUS LINE
NUMBER EIGHTY ONE THAT EIGHT
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BURGER
TOWARD THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. SO THE LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN THAT'S
ONE TWO SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS LAYLA AGREED COLORS
OF THE COMMUNITY WE ARE PROUD
CO SPONSOR. WE ALSO HAVE OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS ALL OF US OR NONE
BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR WOMEN PRISONERS.
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE. CLUB STRIKING
COOPERATED ALONG WITH ABOUT
THIRTY OTHER PEOPLE THANK YOU
SO MUCH. VICTOR LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND ELEVEN THAT'S
TRIPLE ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ON BEHALF OF INITIALLY TESTED
IN STRONG SUPPORT. NEXT TO LINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
SIX ONE SEVEN SIX OUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO GOOD WE CAN HEAR
YOU PLEASE PROCEED ALL OF THE
OTHER THAT ON BEHALF WOULD BE
BUGGED AND SOME OF MAY THIRD
HERE IT'S IMPORTANT BEFORE.
THREE THANK YOU NEXT LINE
NUMBER THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY TWO THAT'S THREE SEVEN
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS
SEAN GARCIA LEYS OF THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE JUSTICE CLINIC
OF THE UC IRVINE SCHOOL OF LAW
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
SEVEN THAT'S ONE SIX SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HEY HOW YOU DOING
WHAT GO AHEAD HI BAR SORRY
ABOUT THE HEIGHT IS JOSE BY
WITH SILICON VALLEY DE BUG. ON
BEHALF OF COURAGE CALIFORNIA
FATHER THE FAMILY THE FAMILY
GETTING FRESNO BODY OF THE
NEEDLES I AM GREEN INCORPORATED
ME BOX NATIONAL JUVENILE
JUSTICE NETWORK NEXT GEN
CALIFORNIA. SO CALIFORNIA POTOK
PARTICIPATORY DEFENSE SECURE
JUSTICE. SHOWING UP FOR RACIAL
JUSTICE AT SACRED HEART-
MIDTOWN FAMILY SERVICES UNITED
BROWN COALITION AND ABOUT-
THIRTY INDIVIDUALS- ALL ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA ALSO-
STRONG SUPPORT AB THREE THREE
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU OVER
THE LINE NUMBER THREE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY THAT'S THREE SEVEN
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
NINE THREE SEVEN ZERO PLEASE
CHECK YOUR LINE FOR SELF MUTE.
THE RESPONSE ON THE LINE NUMBER
THREE TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THREE TWO FIVE THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS ANIL.
CALLING ON BEHALF OF WOMEN'S
FREEDOM CENTER EIGHT SOMETIME
OFTEN AGREE THAT CAN HELP- IN
THE PORT AB THREE THREE THREE
WE HAVE. VERY CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY CALIFORNIA AT THE L.
COOK THE COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
CENTER AND COMMON LAW
UNDERGROUND. A PRICE. THAT YOU
PAY WITH CURRENT INSTITUTE
YOUNG WOMEN'S FREEDOM CENTER
YESTERDAY CHANGES WITH YOUR
WORRIES FREEDOM COALITION AND
ABOUT TWENTY INDIVIDUALS-
ACROSS CALIFORNIA AS WELL.
MAXIM I THREE NINE PLEASE AHEAD.
LANDRY'S SEVENTY NINE YOU MIGHT
NEED AN. MAXIMAL TO LINE ONE
EIGHT TEAM LEAVE BEHIND. HELLO
HELLO YES WE CAN HEAR YOU. I AM
A VERY HARD WITH THE LOOK ON
VALLEY DEEPER AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THREE
THREE THREE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MAXELL MULTILINE THIRTY EIGHTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. DANIEL
GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
MAXIMO CAROLINE NINETY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY NINETY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MMHM
YES WE CAN AREA OKAY PERFECT
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ERIC
MARTIN SMITH AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF PAUL LIKE TO BE A
MIND TO BOARDMAN OF COLOR AND
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORTER AB.
THREE THREE THREE. MAXIMO
TRYING TO FORTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CHAIRED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AS FUNDING AS WITH
THE ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION
OF PROD CO SPONSOR I'M OF THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU. MAXIM OF TEL
NINE THREE SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS CHRISTINA MENDOZA I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE FELONY
MURDER ELIMINATION PROJECT AND
FAMILIES UNITE AND LYFT WITHOUT
POSSIBILITY OF PAROLE FROM LATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB THREE THREE THREE
THANK YOU. MAXIMAL TIMELINE
THREE EIGHTY TWO PLEASE CALL I
HAD. YES MY NAME IS THE ALONG.
I AM FROM SAN JOSE AND I
SUPPORT AB THREE THREE THREE I
AM AT BURKE. ADVOCATE THANK YOU.
MAXIM OF TRYING SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE FOR HAD. HELLO. YES
SPEAKING AREA. HI I DON'T GOT A
DEAL- CALLING ON BEHALF OF
JUSTICE X. LEGAL ATTORNEYS AND
EQUAL THAT THEY ARE NOT GO WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE THREE THREE. MAXIMAL
TRYING TO SIXTY PLEASE CALL I
HAD. HI MY NAME IS MELISSA
VALDEZ I AM FROM SAN JOSE'S
WITH THE LECONTE LED BACK AND I
SUPPORT AB THREE THREE THREE
THANK YOU. MAXIM OF TIELINE
THREE EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS TINA BROWN
I'M FROM SAN JOSE I AM THE SON
IMPACTED FAMILY MEMBER AND
ADVOCATE WITH JHARKHAND ALLEY
D. BUG I AM IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE THREE THREE. MAXIMO TO
LINE THREE EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE
CALL ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
BILL WILL REFLECT ACCIDENT ON
BEHALF OF RESTORE JUSTICE COURT
THANK YOU. IN MAXIMO CAROLINE
ONE EIGHT PM PLEASE CALL HADN'T.
AND GIVEN THE VERY HIGH AND I'M
WAS SO COMPELLING PEOPLE AND I
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THREE AND
AT THIS TIME WE SHOW NO ONE
ELSE TO MAKE YOU. THANK YOU ARE
THERE. ANYONE IN OPPOSITION I
HAVE PROJECTION DIVISION CHIEF
OF THIS IDEA COUNTY DA'S UNIT.
AND CAL COREY CELL ZERO
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION. YES THIS IS A
FRIEND JACKSON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE- I AM THE
CHIEF THIS ANY KIND OF GANG
PROSECUTION DIVISION I'VE BEEN
AGAIN PROCTOR FOR FIFTEEN YEARS
I'M APPEARING TODAY ON BEHALF
OF CDA TO OPPOSE AB THREE THREE
THREE. I BECAME AGAIN
PROSPERITY ADVOCATE FOR
FAMILIES IN OUR MOST
UNDERSERVED AND UNDERPRIVILEGED
NEIGHBORHOODS WERE BEING FORCED
TO LIVE THEIR LIVES IN FEAR FOR
THEIR CHILDREN- THAT THEIR
CHILDREN WOULD EITHER BE
RECRUITED INTO GANGS OR THEY'LL
BECOME TARGETS OF GANG VIOLENCE
ENGINE TO BECOME A VICTIM OF
GANG CRIME THEY CANNOT TURN TO
THE POLICE BECAUSE EVEN IF THE
PERPETRATOR WERE CAUGHT. THE
REMAINDER OF THE GANG WOULD SEE
TO IT THAT THEY PAID A PRICE
IT'S TO PROTECT THESE
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WITH A
MAJORITY OF GANG VIOLENCE
OCCURS THE GANG PROSECUTION AND
THE GANG ALLEGATION IS VITALLY
IMPORTANT IT ALLOWS ASIDE YOU
TO ATTACK THE EVIL IT IS THE
GANGS GRIP ON THE PSYCHE AND
SAFETY OF THE COMMUNITY AND
IT'S SENSELESS. VIOLENCE GANGS
BRING WITH THEM. SAN DIEGO HAS
BEEN ONE THE SAFEST. CITIES IN.
AND THE COUNTRY. DUE IN LARGE
PART COURSE. AND FOCUSED. ON
TARGETING GANG VIOLENCE. PLEASE
UNDERSTAND THAT IN ITS CURRENT
FORM THIS BILL WILL EFFECTIVELY
KILL THE GANG ALLEGATION.
GREATLY AFFECTING PUBLIC SAFETY
OF SAN DIEGO AND CALIFORNIA'S
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. WHAT WE
OPPOSE ANY WHOLESALE GUTTING OF
THE GANG ALLEGATION WE DO
APPRECIATE WHAT THE LEGISLATORS
TRYING TO DO IN TIGHTENING ITS
SCOPE. NO ONE QUARRELS WITH THE
CURRENT LAW TO GIVE JUDGES THE
POWER TO STRIKE GANG
PUNISHMENTS WHEN APPROPRIATE.
AND SOME AMENDMENTS PROPOSED BY
AB THREE THREE THREE ARE
PROBABLY WARRANTED. THE
SHRINKING OF THE LIST OF CRIMES
ELIGIBLE TO BRING A PATTERN OF
GANG ACTIVITY AND THAT'S A
DIVISION II. WHAT EFFECTIVELY
LIMIT THE ALLEGATION GROUPS
WHICH COMMIT CRIMES OF VIOLENCE
OUR TOP PRIORITY. DISALLOWING
THE CURRENT CRIME TO BE USED TO
ESTABLISH A PATTERN OF
OFFENSES. I WOULD FIRST FOCUS
ON MORE ESTABLISHED AND
ENTRENCHED GANGS. AND A PART
TIME FOR MORE EVIDENCE TO BE
GATHERED BEFORE CALLING A GROUP
AGAIN. THE LEGISLATURE MAY ONE
CONSIDER LIVING THE CRIMES
WHICH AGAIN ELEVATION MAYBE
ALLEGED. THE ONLY TRYING TO
QUALIFY IS THREATENED. CRIMES
THEREBY CONTINUE TO SUPPORT AND
PROTECT OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. BUT MANY OF THE
OTHER PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
SHOULD NOT BE ADOPTED THREE IN
PARTICULAR. LOOKING FURTHER THE
PROPOSED CHANGE SUBDIVISION HE
WANTS REQUIRED TO BE PROVEN
THAT THE OFFENSE BENEFIT LEAST
ONE SPECIFICALLY IDENTIFIED
MEMBER OF THE GANG. OTHER THAN
THE PERPETRATOR AND THE BENEFIT
ME MORE THAN REPUTATIONAL. THIS
AMENDMENT FUNDAMENTALLY
MISUNDERSTANDS GANG CRIMES. THE
REALITY IS THAT MANY GANG
CRIMES FOLLOW A PATTERN SUCH
AS- A FEW BLOOD GANG MEMBERS
GATHER ONE MORE GUNS AND GET
INTO A CAR AND THEY DRIVE INTO
RIVAL PREPARE STORY. DO YOU
LOOK FOR A GROUPOF YOUNG BLACK
MALES GATHERED NEAR THE
STRONGHOLD OF THE RIVAL GANG
AND HE OPENED FIRE ON THOSE
MAILS OPENED THEIR RIVALS BUT
NOT WORRYING TOO MUCH OF THE
ART. MAY SHOOT INDISCRIMINATELY.
THEY ENGAGE THIS MURDEROUS
ATTACK TO BOLSTER THE
REPUTATION OF THE SHOOTER
ANYONE THE PRESIDENT IN THE
CRIME. TO RAISE THE REPUTATION
OF THE GANG WITH THE RIVALS BY
SHOWING THEIR WILLINGNESS TO
INFLICT DEATH IN THE HEART OF
ANY TERRITORY. TO VISUALLY
DEMONSTRATE THE POWER AND
FEARLESSNESS OF THEIR GANG TO
RIVAL NEIGHBORHOOD. AND CAL THE
LAW ABIDING CITIZENS FROM
COOPERATING WITH POLICE NOW OR
IN THE FUTURE. BECAUSE THEY
UNDERSTAND THE VIOLENCE BEGAN
CAN AND WILL DO. VIOLENT CRIMES
THOSE CRIMES WE SHOULD CARE
ABOUT MOST PEOPLE ARE NOT
CARRIED OUT TO BENEFIT A
SPECIFICALLY IDENTIFIED PERSON
OR FOR REASONS BEYOND RESPECT
AND REPUTATIONAL BENEFIT. IN
VIOLENT CRIMES OR WHAT HOLDS
FAMILIES AND NEIGHBORHOODS
HOSTAGE. GET THE ABOVE
DESCRIBED CRIME WOULD FALL
OUTSIDE THE PROPOSED AMENDED
GANG STATUTE. AND SUCH A
PERVERSE CONSEQUENCE CANNOT BE
THE INTENTION TO FALL.
SIMILARLY THE NEW REQUIREMENTS
SUBDIVISION J. ONE THAT WE
PROVE THAT THE DEFENDANT MUST
PERSONALLY KNOW THE PERSON WHO
COMMITTED THE PREDICATE
OFFENSE. IN CHECK THE
REQUIREMENTS WHICH WILL BE TO
THE DETRIMENT OF DEFENDANTS. IT
EXPLICITLY REQUIRES US TO TIED
TO SENT TO THE PREDICATE CRIMES
AND GANGSTERS. CURRENTLY GANG
PROSECUTORS AND JUDGES ARE VERY
CAREFUL AND EXPLICIT WHEN
TALKING WITH JURIES THE
PREDICATE OFFENSES HAVE NOTHING
TO DO WITH THE CURRENT
DEFENDANT AND MERELY ARE
REQUIRED TO BE PROVEN IN ORDER
TO LEGALLY CALLED QUALIFY THE
GROUP. AS A CRIMINAL STREET
GANG. REQUIRING PROOF OF THE
DEFENDANT'S CONNECTION TO THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE CONVICTED THE
PAST WOULD. HAVE DEFENSE
ATTORNEYS LIKE TO SAY NOTHING
MORE THAN YES. HELLO YES OOPS
YES THEY BEGIN. I'M SORRY I
THINK SOMEBODY GOT ON
INCIDENTLY- OKAY TELL THEM HOW
MAY I. MALCONTENT YOU MISTER
CHAIR YES PLEASE DO. REQUIRING
PROOF OF THE DEFENSE CONNECTION
TO THE PEOPLE WHO ARE CONVICTED
THE PAST WHAT IF DEFENSE
ATTORNEYS ARE WANT TO SAY DO NO
MORE THAN THIRTY UP THE
DEFENDANT WHICH IS NO ONE'S
INTENTION. ADDING ESTABLISHED
HIERARCHY REQUIREMENT AS AN
CURRENTLY ENVISIONED BY THE
CHANGES HAVE BEEN HALF WOULD DO
NOTHING TO ADDRESS VIOLENT
CRIME BUT INSTEAD WOULD ONLY
SERVE TO REQUIRE MORE GANG
EVIDENCE BE PRESENTED TO A JURY
IN AN EFFORT TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS AND WOULD
ULTIMATELY PLACE OUTSIDE THE
REACH OF THE CALIFORNIA GANG
STATUTE MOST VIOLENT CRIMES
COMMITTED BY CRIMINAL STREET
GANGS IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
FRANKLY THEY DON'T OPERATE
WITHIN ESTABLISHED HIERARCHY.
REGARDING A PROPOSAL TO
BIFURCATE THE PROOF OF THE GANG
ALLEGATION STRICTLY BY
FORGETTING ALL GANG EVIDENCE IS
NOT POSSIBLE GANG CRIMES OFTEN
FALL INTO THE CATEGORY OF
OTHERWISE INEXPLICABLE THE
AVERAGE TO REMEMBER GIVEN THAT
THE MOTIVES OF SO MUCH VIOLENCE
ARE COMPLETELY TIED UP AND GANG
IDENTITIES AND GANG RULES.
MOREOVER GIVEN THE INCREASED
COSTS AND CORD INJURY TIME THAT
SUCH BIFURCATED TRIALS WOULD
REQUIRE I WAS SHOCKED TO SEE
THIS BILL IS NOT CURRENTLY
DESIGNATED TO BE CONSIDERED BY
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
BECAUSE IT'S PRICE TAG WILL NOT
BE SMALL. INTEREST OF KEEPING
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA'S
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AS SAFELY
POSSIBLE CAN WE ARE TO VOTE NO
ON AB THREE THREE THREE. THANK
YOU MISTER JACK THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN CHORUS ALTHOUGH.
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION- REGRETTABLY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB THREE THREE
THREE. KNOWING THE COMMITTEES
RULES ON TIME FOR TESTIMONY- I
SEATED MOST OF MY TIME TO-
MISTER JACKSON. BUT JUST WOULD
AGAIN HIGHLIGHT THE- CONCERNS
ABOUT- NOT BEING ABLE TO
DEMONSTRATE. WHICH PARTICULAR
MEMBER OF THE GANG WOULD
BENEFIT FROM. A PARTICULAR ACT
AND SO FOR THE REASONS STATED
BY MY COLLEAGUE- AND OTHERS WE
WOULD RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB
THREE THREE THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR- ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WITHIN
THE HEARING ROOM. CNN ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AND
A WITNESS TO A CONFERENCE ROOM.
SO LADIES. DO YOU HAVE SOMEONE.
YES LEADERS MANY OF THEM. IN
THE TELECONFERENCE ROOM ARE
THERE ARE. HELLO GO AHEAD IT
THIS. ARE YOU WITNESS. AND THE
TELECONFERENCE ROOM OR YOUR
WITNESS ON THE PHONE WHICH ONE
IS IT. SO LET'S TRY THIS AT T.
LET'S GO TO THE TOILET. COMPLEX
GO TO THE TELEPHONE LINE. AND
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
AB. THREE THREE THREE. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE AB THREE THREE THREE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW AGAIN
TO UPHOLD EIGHTY THREE. A PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO NOW. AND WE
HAVE ABOUT SEVEN IN THE QUEUE
LOCAL TIMELINE THREE EIGHTY
SEVEN ONE MOMENT. YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN THREE SEVEN. GOOD
EVENING THIS IS LIEUTENANT
WILLIAM HAMBURG IN A COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT ON BEHALF
THIS YEAR MAKE MAN IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU THANK ONE
MOTEL NINE ONE THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE TERM
MEMBERS ONE CHANNEL THE
RESEARCHERS CONFUCIAN THING IN
A POLICE OFFICER'S ASSOCIATION
IN CALIFORNIA COALITION WHO
PROFESSIONAL- ALL OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MAX WILL MOVE TO LINE THREE
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOUR MEMBERS JONATHON FELDMAN
THE CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK.
THANK YOU. IN MAXIMO TIMELINE
THREE EIGHTY THREE PREFORMATTED.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LORI
HAAS I'M A DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY ON BEHALF OF OUR SAN
DIEGO DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S ASSOCIATION WE ARE
IN STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MAXIMAL TIELINE
THREE SEVENTY THREE PLEASE CALL
HAD. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
BRANDON UP ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR. MAXO MOTEL
NINE ONE THIRTY PLEASE CALL I
HAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MERRIAM HAVING AND I'M A MEMBER
OF THE SAN DIEGO DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S ASSOCIATION
I STRENUOUSLY OPPOSE ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE THREE THREE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THAT VOTE TO
LINE ONE THIRTY NINE PLEASE
WELL I HAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
JAMES COVER ON BEHALF OF SAN
DIEGANS AGAINST CRIME WE
SUBMITTED A LETTER IN
OPPOSITION WERE OPPOSED AB
THREE THREE THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NACTA MOTEL NINE ONE
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS ISSUE WALLER FROM THE SAN
DIEGO DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IN MAXIMO
CAROLINE ONE EIGHT PM PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO. YES WE CAN AREA.
OKAY HI MY NAME IS TO LOOK AT
THE CURRENT TIME A YOUTH
ORGANIZER WITH THE LOOK ON
VALLEY DEEP CUTS AND I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THREE
THREE THREE. OKAY THANK YOU.
MAXIM OF CAROLINE THREE NINETY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS ALEXIS AMISH I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
DIEGO DEPUTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY
ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE OPPOSED
TO I AM OPPOSED TO EIGHTY THREE
THREE THREE. THANK YOU. AT THIS
TIME THERE'S NO ONE ELSE TO
MAKE YOU. THANK YOU BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE. ARE YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU IF YOU DON'T MIND MISTER
CHAIR I WANT TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE- STATEMENTS THAT WERE A-
SHARED DURING THE OPPOSITION IN
MY CLOTHES- I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT THIS WILL NOT. KILL GANG
ENHANCEMENTS EFFECTIVELY THAT
WAS STATED IT WILL ASK
PROSECUTORS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO DO THEIR JOB I THINK THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE ASK OF EVERY
SINGLE ENTITY IN STAKEHOLDER
WHEN WE ARE LOOKING AT POLICY-
TO NOT RELY ON AN ARCANE
RACIALIZED TOOL FOR SHORT CUTS.
SO THAT WE CAN BE LAZY IN THE
COURTS WHEN DUE PROCESS AND
CIVIL LIBERTIES AND RIGHTS ARE
SO VERY IMPORTANT. THIS DOES
NOT APPLY TO SERIOUS AND
VIOLENT OFFENSES WE TOOK THAT
OUT. CD EIGHT CERTAINLY NEVER
CAME TO THE AUTHOR TO TALK
ABOUT ANY OF THE CONCERNS SO
THAT WE COULD HELP THEM
UNDERSTAND THE LANGUAGE IN THE
BILL- THEY MENTIONED THAT THIS
WOULD BE COSTLY COSTLY COSTLY
97% OF THESE CASES ACTUALLY
PLEASE OUT. AND SO IT WOULD NOT
BE COSTLY. AND YET IT IS STILL
REALLY IMPORTANT TO BIFURCATE
OUT YOU CAN TRY. ON TWO
INSTANCES. YOU CAN CHARGE FOR
THE CRIME. AND TRY THAT OR PLEA
IT OUT AND THEN GO BACK IF
THERE'S AN ALLEGATION OF GANG
ALLEGATION. BUT INTERLINKING
THEM. IS NOT HELPFUL IT HAS
GOTTEN US TO THE STATISTICS
THAT WE HAVE NOW. IT WAS STATED
THAT D. A.'S DO SEPARATE ONE
CHARGE FROM THE OTHER THAT IS
NOT TRUE. YOU GO INTO COURT.
AND YOU SAY THIS PERSON SHOT
SOMEONE THIS PERSON STOLE
SOMEONE IN THE JURY SAYS PROVE
IT SHOW ME THE EVIDENCE. THEN
YOU SAY IN THIS PERSON AS A
GANG MEMBER. AND BECAUSE WE
HAVE WATCHED TRAINING DAY AND
COLORS AND MINISTER SOCIETY AND
THE WIDER. IT TRIGGERS ALL OF
OUR FEARS WE SAY- BAD. BECAUSE
I DON'T LIKE GANGS. AND THEY
KNOW THEY DO THAT. MISTER
JACKSON. AND HE SHOULD HAVE A
SIDE JOB WRITING IN THE MOVIES.
I WAS USING THE SAME TACTICS
THAT HAVE GOTTEN US TO WHERE WE
ARE NOW FEAR. FEAR. THIS WOULD
WHAT DID HE SAY. ATTACK THE
EVIL THAT IS HURTING THE PSYCHE
OF OUR COMMUNITIES NO ONE WANTS
GAINES HURTING THEM TERRORIZING
THEM. BUT THIS DOES SAY YOU
HAVE TO PROVE THAT SOMEONE IS
IN A GANG AND NOT JUST BECAUSE
THEY WEAR CERTAIN COLORS IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN CAMERON TERRELL.
WAS WEARING A BLUE BANDANNA
BLUE TEE SHIRT THROWING UP
SIGNS. TO INSIGNIA ROLLING
AROUND IN A CAR AND WAS
SHOOTING PEOPLE KILLED PEOPLE.
MONAKER MILK AND WHY BOY HE WAS
IN A GANG OKAY. BUT YOU KNOW
WHAT GETTING ALLEGATION NOT
LIVING ON HIM. HE WAS WHITE
FROM PALACE THIRTIES. HE SAID I
WAS JUST DOING A DOCUMENTARY
WANTED TO SEE WHAT IT WAS LIKE
IN THE LIFE. RAYMOND. HAPPEN TO
BE IN A GAME THE AVERAGE GANG
MEMBER GETS SENT OUT FIFTEEN
GETS OUT OF TWENTY FOUR. BUT
BECAUSE OF OUR LAWS. YOU ARE
NEVER ALLOWED TO NOT BE AGAIN
IF YOU'RE IN A GAME. AND SO WAS
LOSE SEVERAL POINTS WE MAKE YOU
APPLY TO BE ON THE REGISTRY
EVERY YEAR. WHEN YOU ARE NOT IN
THE GAME ANYMORE RAYMOND WAS IN
A GANG. STOLE FROM THE
CONVENIENCE STORE A TALL CANNOT
BE YEAR AND SOME MILK HE DID
NOT STEAL THAT. BECAUSE HE WAS
A GANG MEMBER. HE WASN'T
STEALING IT AT THE BEHEST OF
THE GAME. HE STOLE IT BECAUSE
HE WAS THIRSTY AND HE HAD A
CHILD WHO NEEDED MILK. AND A
GANG ALLEGATION WAS LEVIED ON
HIM. SO IF THERE WERE
CONSISTENCIES I WOULDN'T BE
HERE. MISTER JACKSON. BUT THERE
ARE. SO BIFURCATE THE ISSUES
CHARGE THEM AS SUCH. BUT LET'S
NOT RELY ON LAZY TOOLS. LET'S
PUT OUR BIG BOY BIG GIRL PANTS
ON. AND FIND THE EVIDENCE TO
CHARGE APPROPRIATELY. THAT IS
WHAT AB THREE THREE THREE IS
ASKING I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
SENATOR- WE HAVE A MOTION. OKAY
THE WE HEAR YOU. AND THE CHAIRS
RECOMMENDED I BOTH CALLED
CALDERON ON AB THREE THREE
THREE BY SENATOR COMMA- THE
MOTION IS TO PASS JONES SAWYER
JONES SAWYER IRAQI. OUR QUE HAN.
BACKHAND I CORK CORK I SANTIAGO.
THEY ARE TO KNOW THE OUR TURN
NOW WICKS. LEE LEE I. THE
MEASURE CALL NEEDS ONE MORE
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU GOOD TO
SEE YOU. THE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTEEN AB FIVE EIGHT TWO
PATTERSON VEHICLE ACCIDENTS
FLEEING THE SCENE OF AN
ACCIDENT. AND THANK YOU MR
PATTERSON FOR BEING VERY VERY
VERY VERY VERY VERY VERY VERY
VERY PATIENT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU APPRECIATE IT- DO SO
WITHOUT. WHAT WILL BE BRIEF AND
MAKE SURE THAT OUR WITNESSES
STAY IN INSIDE THE- THAT THE
TIME LIMIT THEY WILL BE ON THE
SCREENS HERE- GOOD- YEAH IN A
BIT- WITHOUT GOING BACK OVER AT
FIRST WHAT APPRECIATE WHAT THE
CHAIR WHAT YOU HAVE DONE AND
WHAT THE- COMMITTEE STAFF IS
DONE AND MEMBERS AND BRINGING
US TO THE POINT HERE WHERE
THERE IS A- SUPPORT
RECOMMENDATION WE'RE GRATEFUL
FOR THAT. AND WE SAY THANK YOU-
I WANT. I WANT JUST CUT TO THE
TO THE LOOPHOLE HERE- THE- IF
THE DRIVER. UNDER THE INFLUENCE
HITS AND KILLS SOMEONE. YET
STAYS TO HELP. THEY CAN RECEIVE
A MINIMUM. OF FOUR YEARS IN
PRISON IF THEY INSTEAD FREE SO
THAT THEY'RE INTOXICATED STATE
CAN CANNOT BE PROVEN THEY FACE
A MAXIMUM SENTENCE OF FOUR
YEARS. IN THE CASE OF THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO HIT AND KILLED
GAVIN GLAD OF. BELOVED TEACHER
AN EDUCATOR IN THE FRESNO WHERE.
HE WAS SENTENCED TO THREE YEARS
AND SERVED LESS THAN EIGHTEEN
MONTHS CONVERSELY THE YOUNG MAN
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY NOT LONG
AGO WAS GIVEN A TWELVE YEAR
SENTENCE. UNDER VERY SIMILAR
CIRCUMSTANCES AT YET HE DID THE
RIGHT THING AND STAYED. AT THE
SCENE. AS IT STANDS NOW WE HAVE
WE ARE PUNISHING. INDIVIDUALS
FOR DOING THE RIGHT THING. THE
HUMANE THING AND THERE IS THIS
PERVERSE REWARD IF YOU FLEE AND
LEAVE. SO TO CLOSE THE LOOPHOLE
AB FIVE EIGHT TWO WOULD BRING
THESE TWO SENTENCES CLOSER
TOGETHER BY INCREASING THE
SENSE FOR FLEEING THE SCENE OF
AN ACCIDENT RESULTING IN DEATH.
FROM THE CURRENT POSSIBLE
SENTENCE OF. TWO TO FOUR YEARS
TO A POSSIBLE SENTENCE OF.
THREE FOUR FOUR SIX. AND HERE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS READ
THE GLADDING. A GAVIN GLIDING'S
MOM AND MIKE ASEGURA WHOSE
SISTER KOURTNEY WAS ALSO KILLED
IN A HIT AND RUN ACCIDENT. AND
THEY ARE IN THE. IN THE VIDEO
ROOMS GOOD- SO. WHENEVER WE'RE
READY TO ACKNOWLEDGE IN THE
TELEVISION VIDEO ROOM. WHO FOR
NOT SAYING ANYTHING AND HAVE TO
START- THEY CAN SHE CAN IF SHE
IF YOU CAN HEAR US IN THE CAN
YOU HEAR US YOU START TO START
TO TALK AND THEN THE- I GUESS.
AND YOU HAVE DONE ON MEDIUM OF
YOUR BIKE. IS THERE SOMEONE IN
THAT ROOM THAT COULD GIVE THEM
TECHNICAL HELP. BAKER. LET'S
NOT RULE OVER HERE. IS THIS THE
FIRST TIME THAT YES. TODAY CAN
YOU HEAR ME NOW ARE YOU HERE DO
YOU THE CASHIER. OKAY THANK YOU
SO MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON AND-
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN MR JONES
SAWYER SAWYER FOR YOUR SUPPORT
ON THE RECOMMENDATION WE HOPE A
FIVE EIGHT TWO GAVIN THOUGHT.
I'M READY TO GLADDING I AM HERE
TODAY ADDRESSING YOU IN PLACE
OF MY DAUGHTER IN LAW SUSAN
GLADDING. TWO YEARS FIVE MONTHS
AND TWENTY ONE DAYS AGO SHE
BECAME A WITHOUT. MY SON GAVIN
GLADDING. I WAS TRAINING FOR A
MARATHON WHEN AND I'M A
LICENSED DRIVER IN A STOLEN
PICKUP TRUCK FROM HIS FATHER.
LOST CONTROL OF THE VEHICLE
SWERVED OFF THE ROAD. UP ONTO
THE BERM WITH GAVIN WAS RUNNING.
KEVIN WAS HIT WITH THE REAR
VIEW MIRROR ON THE PASSENGER
SIDE- I WITNESSES SAID GAVIN
FLEW INTO THE AIR. ARE BOUNCE
UP AHEAD OF THE TRUCK SEVERAL
TIMES AND FELL TO THE GROUND
WITH THAT. THE NOISE. WAS SO
GREAT THAT. FRIENDS OF OURS WHO
WHO LIVE IN NEIGHBOR I'D
NEIGHBORHOODS NEARBY WERE ABLE
TO HEAR IT AND CAME OUT TO SEE
WHAT WAS GOING ON- WITNESSES
ALSO WATCH THE TRUCKERS IT'S
BEEN AWAY IN A COMPLETE CIRCLE
AS IT'S BEEN A COMPLETE CIRCLE
AROUND THE STREET. AND RACED
AWAY LEAVING GAVIN ON THE SIDE
OF THE ROAD. AMIDST BROKEN
PIECES OF GLASS. AND THE TRUCK
THAT WAS SOAKED WITH HIS BLOOD.
STILL ALIVE. AT THAT POINT THE
FRESNO BEE HEADLINE ON TUESDAY
OCTOBER THE SIXTEENTH TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN READ IN BOLD
PRINT. CLOVIS SCHOOL OFFICIAL
WAS STILL ALIVE AFTER BEING
STRUCK BY DRIVER- WHICH MEANS
THEY LEFT KEVIN ON THE SIDE OF
THE ROAD. AND IT. TERRIFIES ME
TODAY TO BELIEVE AND UNDERSTAND
THAT HE DIED THERE A LITTLE.
THAT DAY SIMPSON BECAME A WIDOW
A SINGLE PARENT NOW RESPONSIBLE
FOR RAISING HER CHILDREN EIGHT
IN TEN AT THE TIME. ALONE NOW
HAVING THE RESPONSIBILITIES OF
BECOMING THE SOLE PROVIDER FOR
HER FAMILY. THAT IS WHY I AM
HERE TODAY SYSTEMS THAT WORK.
AS SHE IS NOW THE SOLE SOURCE
OF FOOD AND SHELTER FOR HER
CHILDREN HER LIFE HAS FOREVER
CHANGED. AS HAS THE REST OF OUR
FAMILIES. THE DRIVER OF THE
PICKUP THAT KILLED GAVIN WAS
NOT GIVEN A MAXIMUM SENTENCE OF
FOUR YEARS THAT WE PLUG FOR. HE
WAS GIVEN THREE YEARS INSTEAD
AND WAS SERVED AND SERVED ONLY
THIRTEEN MONTHS. WHAT HE IS NOW
FREE THE REST OF US LEFT BEHIND
I GABIN WAS LEFT THERE WERE TWO
THOUSAND PEOPLE AT HIS PEOPLE.
I WILL CONTINUE TO GRIEVE HIS
LOSS THIS IS A MUCH AS SHE
COULD BE HERE TODAY. I WISH
KEVIN COULD BE HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MIKE YEAH.
HI THERE MY NAME IS ACOSTA
GATOR. FIRST- I WANTED TO SHARE
MY SYMPATHIES WITH THE CLOUDY
FAMILY- AND I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR FOR SUPPORT
RECOMMENDATION ON THIS BILL- I
APPRECIATE COMMITTEES TIME IN
YOUR ATTENTION ON THIS MATTER.
I LIVE IN FRESNO CLOVIS AREA
SO- WHEN IT WHEN THE SENSELESS
DEATH OF GAVIN GUIDING
HAPPENED. I REMEMBER HOW MUCH
OF IT WAS A SHOCK TO THE
COMMUNITY. IT WAS REALLY TRAGIC
REALLY TERRIBLE BUT- YOU DON'T
REALLY UNDERSTAND HOW TRAGIC IT
HOW TERRIBLE UNTIL IT HAPPENS
TO YOUR FAMILY- MY SISTER
KOURTNEY OUT SKATED WAS KILLED
IN FEBRUARY. I HIT RUN DRIVER
SHE WAS WALKING OUT TO WORK. ON
THE WEIGHT OF A CAR- SOMETHING
SHE OTHER PEOPLE DO EVERY
SINGLE DAY NOT KNOWING IT WOULD
BE THE LAST THING. THAT SHE DID.
A SPEEDING DRIVER. CROSSED IN
THE WRONG LANE SORRY FIXING THE
CAMERA LITTLE BIT- CROSS IN THE
WRONG LANE. AND HIT MY SISTER
SO HARD THAT SHE CAME OUT OF
HER SHOES AND SHE WAS LEFT
THERE TO DIE. THE DRIVER DIDN'T
STOP TO SEE IF SHE WAS OKAY.
DIDN'T EVEN HAVE THE COMPASSION
TO DO THAT. MY SISTER WAS
THIRTY ONE. THE DRIVER TOOK HER
AWAY FROM MY FAMILY. TOOK HER
AWAY FROM HER SEVEN YEAR OLD
DAUGHTER. AND DIDN'T EVEN HAVE
THE DECENCY TO STOP. THIS
WASN'T AN ACCIDENT THIS WAS A
RECKLESS CRIME. THE DRIVER HAS
BEEN ARRESED YET EVEN THOUGH
THEY'VE BEEN IDENTIFIED BY
LOCAL POLICE- WHEN THE DRIVER
IS ARRESTED THE MAXIMUM
PUNISHMENT THAT SHE'LL FACE IS
FOUR YEARS. IS THAT FAIR FOR MY
SISTER'S LIFE. THE FAIR FOR A
FAMILY'S GRIEF. FOR MY NIECE
WHO NOW HAVE TO LIVE WITHOUT A
MOTHER. THIS IS AN INSTANCE
WHERE THE SCALES OF JUSTICE
JUST SEEM OUT OF WHACK. AND
GAVIN LAW HELPS FIX THAT. THE
PUSH A HARSHER PENALTY ON IT
RUN DRIVERS WHO COMMIT THESE
TERRIBLE CRIMES AND DON'T HAVE
THE DECENCY TO STOP AND CARE
FOR THE PEOPLE LIVE UNDER. WE
CAN ALL AGREE THIS TYPE OF
BEHAVIOR REPRESENTS THE WORST
OF OUR SOCIETY. ALL HIT RUN
VICTIM'S DESERVE BETTER THAN
THAT. CAVENDER IS BETTER THAN
THAT AND MY SISTER DESERVE
BETTER. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
I APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU SIR.
THE CLOSER WITNESSES THANK YOU
ARE ANY OTHER WITNESSES HERE-
IN THE- IN THE ROOM AND FORTY
TWO OH TO. SEE NONE OF
BROADBAND THE TELECONFERENCE
ARE THERE ANY OTHER ME TOOS IN
THE TELECONFERENCE ROOM NOT IT
WE CAN ACTUALLY SEE IT- NO. AND
THEN- EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR
TELEPHONE ARE THERE ANY-
SUPPORT SUPPORT ONLINE. AND
MAYBE EVEN GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY
FIVE EIGHT TO PRESS ONE THAN
THEIR OWN NOW AGAIN TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR AB FIVE EIGHT TO
PRESS ONE AND THEN THEIR OWN
NOW. WE HAVE ABOUT FIVE IN THE
QUEUE LOCAL TO LINE THREE SIXTY
SIX. PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
WHO SHALL NOT SURE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. MAXIMAL TIMELINE SEVENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU. PART OF IT
I DON'T PREVAIL IN BEHALF OF
UNITED BROWN COALITION AND WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THOSE WHO
STAY IN DO THE RIGHT THING.
MAXIMO KILLING THREE NINETY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS GABRIELLE WOULD BE
CABIN GLAVIN WITH MY BROTHER
AND I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB FIVE EIGHTY TWO. THANK YOU.
MAXIMO TIMELINE THREE NINETY
SEVEN PLEASE WELL I HAD. BY
LARRY MORRISON- ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE EIGHT TWO
BUT- THANK YOU. MAXIMO CAROLINA
ONE EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS LAURIE MCCLAIN AND
GAVIN GLIDING'S CAMPS AND I'M
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MA'AM. SOME OF THE LINE THIRTY
SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS STEVE MCCORD.
KEVIN GLIDING WAS BY NEPHEW AND
SPENT SUMMERS WITH ME I
CONSIDER HIM MY THIRD SON. THAT
I DO SUPPORT THIS BILL
COMPLETELY THANK YOU THANK YOU
SIR. AT THIS TIME THERE'S NO
ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE. THANK
YOU ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION I EVERITT KATHY SURE
A. C. L. U. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS CAN CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN. GREAT
THANK YOU- KATHY SURE FOR ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION- I WANT TO
START BY OFFERING MY SYMPATHY
TO THE PEOPLE WHO SPOKEN WITH
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THEIR
STYLE- NO ONE SHOULD HAVE TO
SUFFER. THE LOSS OF A LOVED ONE
IN THE WAY THAT THAT YOU LOST
YOUR LOVED ONES- AND I TRULY DO
OFFER MY SYMPATHY ON YOUR LOSS-
I THINK WE ALL SHARE THE GOAL
OF TRYING TO MAKE OUR ROADS
SAFER AND TRYING TO PREVENT- ON
THIS KIND OF EVENT FROM
OCCURRING AND- STOPPING PEOPLE
FROM. FLEEING THE SCENE OF AN
ACCIDENT. UNFORTUNATELY THE
INCREASED TERMS OF IMPRISONMENT
PROPOSED IN EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY
TWO WILL DO NOTHING TO PREVENT
FUTURE DEATHS OR SERIOUS
INJURIES FROM CAR ACCIDENTS.
NOR WILL IT DETER DRIVERS FROM
LEAVING THE SCENE AFTER AN
ACCIDENT- PEOPLE LEAVE THE
SCENE AFTER AN ACCIDENT BECAUSE
THEY THINK THEY ARE GOING TO
GET AWAY AND NOT BE PUNISHED
THEY'RE NOT THINKING ABOUT WHAT
THE- BUT THE COULD POSSIBLE
PENALTY COULD BE. PERSUADING
HERSELF STAY IN- EIGHTY FIVE
EIGHTY TWO WILL ONLY SEND MORE
PEOPLE TO PRISON FOR LONGER
PERIODS OF TIME- WITH THE STATE
OF COURSE PAYING THE INCREASED
COST OF THAT AND NO BENEFIT TO
PUBLIC SAFETY- BECAUSE IT WILL
DO NOTHING TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM IT PROPOSES TO ADDRESS-
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE ON THE EIGHTY. EIGHTY FIVE
EIGHTY TWO. THANK YOU. I THERE
I'M NOT INTO RUSSIA FOR TWO- TO
OTHER ANY OTHER WITH AND AFTER.
SEEING NONE. I'M NOT LOOKING AT
THE TELECONFERENCE ARE YOU
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION- SEEING
OR HEARING NONE- AT AND T. ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES ON THE
TELEPHONE IN OPPOSITION. AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO OPPOSE AB FIVE EIGHT Q.
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW AGAIN
TO UPHOLD AB FIVE EIGHT Q.
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW. MILIK
LIKE WE HAVE TO WIN THE QUEUE
OF LOCALS TO LINE ONE ELEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SERIK ME ON
BEHALF OF INITIATE JUSTICE AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
OKAY MAXIMAL CAROLINE THREE
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE RESPECTFULLY
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IF NOT
WE'LL BRING YOU BACK. UP GO
AHEAD. I'M SORRY WE HAVE ONE
MORE IN THE QUEUE. WHY NO ONE
FIVE FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DENICO RETURN ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFENSE WITH SYMPATHY TO THOSE
WHO HAVE LOST LOVED ONES THAT
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME NO ONE
ELSE AND LIKE YOU. THANK YOU
WE'RE GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE I THINK MR QUIRK HAS
A COMMENT AND OR QUESTIONS ARE
SO IT IS VERY IMPORTANT. THAT
TO THE EXTENT THAT WE CAN WE AS
MEMBERS SHOULD BE HERE ALL THE
TIME IN THESE HEARINGS. AND BE
WILLING TO CHANGE OUR MINDS
BASED ON WHAT WE HEAR. AND
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED A COUPLE
OF YEARS AGO. WHEN MR PATTERSON
BROUGHT THIS BILL UP. THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER POINTED OUT
THAT IF YOU. WE'RE IN NEED AND-
KILLED SOMEBODY IN AN ACCIDENT
YOU WERE BETTER OFF LEAN. FROM
THE SCENE OF THE CRIME. AND
BEAN YOU WILL NOT BE PROSECUTED
IS HARD WE HAVE TO HAVE
CONSISTENT PUNISHMENTS. AND WE
HEARD THAT AND WE CHANGED OUR
OPINION AND AGAIN IT IS RARE
FOR US TO INCREASE PENALTIES
FOR THE REASONS THAT THE ACLU
BROUGHT UP. BUT HERE THERE
SIMPLE AS SIMPLE INCONSISTENCY
IN THE LAW. AND WE UNDERSTOOD
THAT WE CHANGED OUR MINDS IT
TOOK A LITTLE WHILE BECAUSE
PROVIDING ALL THAT FOR THIS TO
COME BACK BUT IT'S HERE AND-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PATTERSON I THINK WE'RE
GOING TO MAKE THE WORLD A
BETTER PLACE- WITH THIS
PARTICULAR PACKAGE THANK YOU.
MATHIS CITY ZERO THREE. THANK
YOU ARE THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PATTERSON FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD- I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL- I UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE IS THIS EFFORT TODAY
TO ONE AND DECREASING CAR
SERRATIONS AND THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE MOVEMENT. BUT THERE'S
SOMETHING LSE HERE AND
SOMETIMES IT'S NOT ABOUT FIXING
IT'S NOT ABOUT FIXING THE
PROBLEM A REHABILITATING IT'S
ABOUT JUSTICE FOR THE PEOPLE
THAT THIS AFFECTED. AND WHEN
THERE'S AN INCENTIVE FOR
SOMEBODY TO RUN OVER SOMEBODY
ELSE AND JUST LEAVE THE SAME
THERE'S A PRICE TO BE PAID FOR
THAT AND THAT PRICE NEEDS TO BE
PAID. FOR THE VICTIMS. OF THIS
BECAUSE THAT IS A CRIME. AND IF
YOU CHOOSE TO DO THAT CRIME.
THOSE VICTIMS ARE THE ONES WHO
DESERVE THE JUSTICE THIS BILL
THAT YOU'RE PUTTING FORWARD.
HELPS INCREASE THE LIKELIHOOD
THAT THEY WILL GET THEIR
JUSTICE. AND SO IF YOU DON'T
MIND I'D LIKE TO BE A CO AUTHOR
ON YOUR BILL OF COURSE WHEN I
WILL BE SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MR
LEE. I WANT TO SHARE MY DEEPEST
SYMPATHIES WITH THE GLIDING
FAMILY IT'S TOO OFTEN IN EVERY
COMMUNITY THAT WE LOSE SO MANY
LIVES OF RECKLESS SPEEDING
RECKLESS DRIVING EFFECT HAPPENS
IN MY COMMITTEE PRETTY REFER TO
ONLY AS WELL BUT I ALWAYS HAVE
A PROBLEM WITH US TRYING TO
SOLVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND
TRANSPORTATION PROBLEM WITH THE
PENAL SYSTEM BY HARPER PUTTING
ON PENALTIES WITH PEOPLE. I
MADE. WE HAVE STUDIES THAT SHOW
THAT INCREASE PENALTIES
INCREASE SENTENCING DOES NOT
DETER BEHAVIOR IN FACT FOR
EVERY ONE YEAR OF ADDITIONAL
SENTENCING. INCREASES
RECIDIVISM. THERE ALL THE DOOR
OF THE PRISON SYSTEM FORTY
SEVEN PERCENT. SO I UNDERSTAND
OBVIOUSLY YOU WANT TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM HERE AND FIX AND MAKE
SURE THAT NO ONE ELSE HAS TO
LOSE THEIR LIVES SO. AWFULLY
AND TRAGICALLY. BUT IS THERE
ANY. DATA THAT PROVES THAT THIS
METHOD YOU'RE GOING FOR
ACTUALLY WILL SOLVE THE PROBLEM
OF HIDDEN RUNS. WHAT I THINK IS
IMPORTANT HERE IS FOR US TO SEE.
THE IMBALANCE IN THE LAW. AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE ATTEMPTING TO
DO. TO BRING THE. PENALTY IF
YOU WILL. CLOSER TOGETHER AS I
SAID EARLIER- THERE IS THIS
GULF. BETWEEN LEAVING AND STAY.
M. THE PENALTIES IMPOSED.
BENEFIT THOSE WHO CHOOSE TO
LEAVE. DATA NOT WAS STANDING I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO.
THINK ABOUT THE FAX OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO HIT KILL AND
LEAVE. AND SERVE. A YEAR. THOSE
INDIVIDUALS AREN'T SILENT. THEY
HAVE FRIENDS. THEY TALK THEY
COMMUNICATE. AND WHAT'S THE
LESSON THEY LEARNED. THEY GOT
OFF. WHILE GAVIN GLADDING WAS
LYING ON THE STREET. WE ARE
LOOKING HERE FOR A BALANCE OF
JUSTICE. BETWEEN FLEEING AND
STATING AND BEING A HUMAN BEING
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT SO I'M HEARING THERE IS
NO EMPIRICAL EVIDENCE ARE
HAVING BETWEEN DETERRENCE AND
SENTENCING. YOU AND I DISAGREE
ON THAT WHY I'M ASKING IF YOU
HAVE THAT IF YOU AND I DISAGREE
ALL RIGHT WELL THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE THAT ARE GOING
THROUGH CHAIR. DARK SERVICES
CHANCER AND THE NO I'M JUST
SAYING I WILL BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THIS BECAUSE I AGAIN I
THINK IT'S DOUBLING DOWN THE
CARDINAL SYSTEM INSTEAD OF
SOLVING INFRASTRUCTURE PROBLEMS.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS MR
LACKEY. YEAH I THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BACK I WOULD.
GOOD WE'LL GET YOU. BECAUSE I
HAVE WITNESSED UNLIKE ANYBODY
ELSE UP HERE THE TRAGEDIES
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS- A MILTON
STATUTORY INCENTIVE TO FLEE. I
MEAN IT DOESN'T TAKE. A STUDY
AT DOZENS TAKE EMPIRICAL DATA.
TO PROVIDE VERY COMPELLING-
UNDERSTANDING OF HUMAN NATURE
WHEN THERE'S THIS KIND OF
INCENTIVE THAT IT'S GOING TO BE
PURSUED AND IT IS ROUTINELY
UNFORTUNATELY PEOPLE DON'T
REALIZE HOW OFTEN THIS TAKES
PLACE WHEN WE HAVE SERIOUS
INJURY NOT ALWAYS RESULTING IN
DEATH. BUT IT'S HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS EVERY YEAR. AND I'M
HOPING THAT BY. PASSING THIS
PARTICULAR PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THAT POSSIBLY. SOMEBODY
REMAINING AT THE SCENE MIGHT
EVEN SAVE SOMEONE'S LIFE. AND
THAT'S REALLY WHAT SHOULD BE
THE INCENTIVE FOR THIS BODY. IS
TRYING TO PRESERVE AND PROTECT
LIFE THAT DESERVES THAT. AND
NOT TO WORRY ABOUT OVER
PUNISHING SO I THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- AND I WANT TO
THANK MR PATTERSON AND- I THINK
THIS CLADDING FOR COMING BACK I
REMEMBER WHEN YOU WERE HERE HE
WAS TWO YEARS AGO IS THAT RIGHT
MR PATTERSON. WITH YOUR
DAUGHTER IN LAW AND HER
POWERFUL TESTIMONY IN THE WAY
HER LIFE WAS CHANGED ON THAT
DAY AND- AS A MOTHER MYSELF I
CAN ONLY IMAGINE THE PAIN.
GAVIN AND YOU KNOW I JUST WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT THE WORK THAT
YOU'VE DONE MR PATERSON ON THIS
BILL WHEN YOU BROUGHT IT FOR
TWO YEARS AGO I KNOW IN THE
COMMITTEE HEARING I SAID I HAD
A PROBLEM WITH YOU RAISING. THE
FLOOR AND YOU HEARD THAT IN
THIS BILL CONTINUES MAINTAIN
THE FLORAL RAISING THE CEILING
TO ENSURE THE PEOPLE LIKE THE
GLIDING'S GET. THEIR JUSTICE
AND I THINK IT'S THAT KIND OF
WORK OR WE CAN COME TOGETHER
AND HEAR EACH OTHER AND FIND
COMPROMISE TO DO THE WORK TO
GET JUSTICE FOR VICTIMS THAT IS
WHAT SHOULD HAPPEN MORE IN THIS
COMMITTEE SO I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PARTNERSHIP IN
GETTING TO WHERE IT IS TODAY
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING. THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER. COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. SEEING NONE. YOU MAY
CLOSE MISSED PATTERSON. THANK
YOU MR I'M GOING TO CLOSE JUST
BASICALLY WITH A BIG THANK YOU-
THIS HAS BEEN. A LONG PERIOD OF
TIME TOGETHER. SO I WANT TO
FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU I THANK
THE CHAIR THANK THE MEMBERS.
WHO LISTENED. AND WHO HEARD AND
HE THOUGHT ABOUT IT. I'M
GRATEFUL FOR THAT- ALSO- I
THINK IT'S I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO. I REMEMBER
THAT ALTHOUGH THIS IS AN
ENHANCEMENT. THIS IS A
BALANCING BETWEEN THE PENALTY
FOR STAYING IN THE PENALTY FOR
LEAVING. AND WITH THAT I'M
ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT. AND
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AGAIN AND THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR YOUR
SUPPORT RECOMMENDATION. UNTIL
JUST WHAT I WANNA DO IS JUST
MAKE SURE WE UNDERSTAND WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN BECAUSE THE BIG
LEADING FAMILIES- TESTIMONY
WITH VERY VERY. VERY POWERFUL
FOR THOSE OF US THAT WERE HERE.
BUT I DO REMEMBER. THERE WAS A
COMMENT MADE AND I BELIEVE IT
WAS THE FAMILY IS THAT IT MADE
IT SOUND LIKE BASICALLY THAT
PERSON HAD NOT BEEN GETTING THE
CONSEQUENCES IT WAS LIKE A
LOOPHOLE IN THE LAW AND YOU
COULD LITERALLY SEE THE HEADS
POP UP LIKE FROM EACH COMMITTEE
MEMBER LIKE WHAT ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT AND THEN YOU KIND
OF CLARIFY WHAT IT IS AND I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU REMEMBER WE
KIND OF. WHICH WE NEVER DO
WE'RE KIND OF CAUGHT CáC
BETWEEN OURSELVES LET'S JUST
WHAT'S GOING ON AND WE MADE A
COMMITMENT TO COME BACK TO WORK
ON IT SOME MORE AFTER IT IS- IT
DIDN'T QUITE MAKE IT OUT OF
COMMITTEE BUT WE MADE A
COMMITMENT TO YOU THAT WE NEED
TO FIX. THAT GAP. IN THE LAW
NINE. THAT WAS FAST THAT'S
REALLY WHAT HAPPENED NEXT IS
JUST ONE OF THOSE TIMES. WHERE
YOU LISTEN TO THE PEOPLE WHO
SPEAK THEY TELL YOU SOMETHING
THAT MAY BE. AN OBJECT ON STAFF
TO SOMETIME STAFF MRS IN THE
STAFF ANALYSIS. AND IT MAKES
YOU GO OKAY THIS IS WHY OF
TESTIMONY SO YOU CAN YOU CAN-
YOU CAN MAKE AN INFORMED
DECISION ARE YOU CAN HEAR
SOMETHING THAT YOU DIDN'T HEAR
BEFORE SIDE YOU KNOW IT IT'S
GOOD THAT YOU YOU COOPERATED
WITH US YOU UNDERSTOOD OUR
DILEMMA. BUT MOST IMPORTANT. IT
WASN'T REALLY- ABOUT THE WHOLE
SYSTEM OF WHETHER YOU BELIEVE
IN. HARSHER PUNISHMENTS OR EVEN
WHEN YOU BELIEVE IN A
REHABILITATION IT WAS ABOUT HOW
DO WE MAKE SURE AT LEAST THAT
PERSON SEARCH THE TIME THAT
THEY SHOULD UNDER NORMAL
CIRCUMSTANCES NOT IN AND SO WE
WORK REAL HARD TO TRY TO AT
LEAST. AS YOU DIRECTOR MUSE TRY
TO BALANCE IT AND SO THAT I
THINK THAT'S WHAT THAT'S WHAT
HAPPENED WITH THIS COMMITTEE
AND HOPEFULLY IS A LESSON TO
OTHERS. THAT YOU YOU WORK WITH
US WE CAN WE CAN ACTUALLY GET
PEOPLE THERE AND SO HOPEFULLY
OF THE FAMILY TO GLIDING'S OR-
GET A BETTER UNDERSTANDING HOW
THE SYSTEM. WORKS AND HOPEFULLY
IT WORKS FOR THEM IN SOME WAY.
SO I MISTER CHAIRMAN LAST WEEK
FOR AN IPHONE. AT THIS-
EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN SOMETHING
THAT- QUITE FRANKLY WILL CEMENT.
ABOUT MY PERSONAL APPRECIATION
M. THE RELATIONSHIP THAT WE
HAVE. THAT TRANSCENDS PARTY AND
TRANSCENDS IDEOLOGY THAT I WANT
TO THANK THE STAFF AGAIN AND I
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR I WANT
TO THANK MEMBERS WHO SAW THE
LOOPHOLE HELPED US. NAVIGATE
THROUGH IT AND WE NOW ARE EVER
ARRIVED HERE I'M GRATEFUL FOR
THAT MASK FOR YOUR ON YOUR-
CLOSELY. ON EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY
TO THE MISSION IS TO PASS TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYERJONES SAWYER HI
LACKEY ARE. BARRICADE CAN BEAR
CAN I WORK OUR WORK I SENT IAGO
SANTIAGO I SEE R. TWO C. R. TWO
I WICKS. LEE NOW LINO. THE
MEASURE PASSES THANK THANK YOU.
AFTER THAT MISS WALDRON. RIGHT
NUMBER TWENTY- AB SIX FOUR FOUR
MOVE THE BELL CALIFORNIA MATT
REENTRY INCENTIVE PROGRAM.
WE'LL STRT OFF WITH A- THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. AB SIX FOUR FOUR.
MAKES MINOR CHANGES. TO MY BILL
AB THIRTEEN OH FOUR FROM TWO
TWENTY TWENTY WHICH IS TABLETS
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICATION
ASSISTED TREATMENT ALSO KNOWN
AS MATT RE ENTRY INCENTIVE
PROGRAM THIS SLIGHT LANGUAGE
CLARIFICATION IS BASED ON AN
AGREEMENT BETWEEN MYSELF AND
THE GOVERNOR GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S
ADMINISTRATION ALONG WITH CDC
ARE. SPECIFIC SPECIFICALLY AB
SIX FOUR FOUR WOULD REFLECT THE
TRUE INTENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
MAT RIA ENTRY INCENTIVE
PROGRAM. WHICH IS TO PROVIDE
CREDITS TO PAROLEES WHO
PARTICIPATE IN A POST RELEASE
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT PROGRAM. AND IT
INCENTIVIZES PAROLEES TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS BY
PROVIDING REDUCE PAROLE
SENTENCES. A SIMILAR BIPARTISAN
MEASURE IN KENTUCKY HAS REDUCE
RECIDIVISM. AND ILLEGAL DRUGS
ALCOHOL OPIOID USE SAVING LIVES
AND MONEY. GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S
ADMINISTRATION AND I AGREE THAT
THE PROVISIONS OF MY FORMER
BILL AB THIRTEEN OH FOUR WOULD
BE MOST IMPACTFUL IF PAROLEES
ARE NOT EXCLUDED FROM
ELIGIBILITY BECAUSE THEY DID
NOT PARTICIPATE IN AN
INSTITUTIONAL TREATMENT PROGRAM.
SO THIS- THIS BILL CLARIFIES
THAT AND INCENTIVIZES
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS TO
PARTICIPATE IN POST RELEASE.
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
OR NOT THEY PARTICIPATED IN
TREATMENT WHILE IN CUSTODY SO.
IT ELIGIBILITY TODAY JOINING ME
ON THE PHONE IS DR KEITH
HUMPHREYS A PROFESSOR FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF PSYCHIATRY AND
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES AT STANFORD
pMEMBER OF THE WHITE HOUSE
COMMISSION ON DRUG FREE
COMMUNITIES AND THE NATIONAL
VICE THREE A COUNCIL OF THE U.
S. SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. AND DURING.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION HE
SPENT A YEAR AS SENIOR POLICY
ADVISER AT THE WHITE HOUSE
OFFICE OF NATIONAL DRUG CONTROL
POLICY- AND I WOULD. ALSO HAVE
WITH US DR JOHN STERN CHIEF
DEPUTY REGIONAL ADMINISTRATOR
OF SOUTHERN REGION
HEADQUARTERS. FROM THE DIVISION
OF ADULT PAROLE OPERATIONS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
AND HE IS HERE ONLY ON THE
PHONE TO ANSWER AND PROVIDE ANY
TECHNICAL- QUESTIONS IF
NECESSARY. AND I'D LIKE TO HAND
IT OVER TO DR HUMPHRIES. THANK
YOU. BUT DON'T PLEASE WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU- CHAIR
JONES SAWYER THANK YOU VICE
CHAIR LACKEY AND THANK YOU
MINORITY LEADER WALDRON FOR-
ASKING ME TO APPEAR DAY HI THIS
IS A SIMPLE MODIFICATION OF THE
BILL THAT'S ALREADY PASSED AND
THE EVIDENCE IN THIS AREA IS
VERY CLEAR SO I CAN BE CONCISE-
HI STUDIED ADDICTION AND ITS
TREATMENT FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS
AND HERE'S WHAT I CAN BOIL
DOWN- FOR YOUR COMMITTEE FIRST.
WE'VE DONE MANY SURVEYS OF
AMERICAN PRISONS AND THEY SHOW
THAT THE MAJORITY OF PEOPLE IN
PRISONS MAKE CRITERIA FOR AN
ADDICTION OFTEN MULTIPLE
ADDICTIONS MOST OF THOSE FOLKS
WLL ONE DAY BE ON PAROLE BUT
THERE IS A VERY HIGH NEED. FOR
THE SERVICE. SECOND I MEDICAID
ASSISTED TREATMENT WORKS VERY
WELL THESE ARE FDA APPROVED
MEDICATIONS THERE STUDIED IN
THE MOST RIGOROUS CLINICAL
TRIALS THE SAME KIND OF
RESEARCH WE DO TO DETERMINE HOW
TO TAKE CARE OF CANCER. AND
HEART DISEASE WE'VE DONE THOSE
WITH HIS MEDICATIONS AND
ACCOUNTS THAT GOES WITH THEM.
THEY REDUCE THE RISK OF
OVERDOSE THEY REDUCE THE RATE
OF ILLICIT DRUG USE HE REDUCE
THE CLINTON OF CRIME. AND
REDUCE THE RISK OF PEOPLE
EITHER REQUIRING FOR
TRANSMITTING INFECTIOUS
DISEASES LIKE HEPATITIS C. AND
HIV. THERE'S ALSO A PUBLIC
SAFETY BENEFITS HERE. PEOPLE
WHO LEAVE PRESENT. AND GO BACK
TO USING SUBSTANCES ARE FAR
MORE LIKELY TO COMMIT MORE
CRIMES. AND THEN END UP IN
PRISON AGAIN SO IT'S NOT JUST
ABOUT THE HEALTH OF THE- FORMER
INMATE IS ALSO ABOUT THE SAFETY
OF THE COMMUNITY. LAST POINT
AND NOT LEAST THE COST BENEFIT
FOR THESE PROGRAMS IS EXTREMELY
FAVORABLE. MY COLLEAGUES AT
STANFORD AND I PUBLISHED A
PAPER LAST WEEK IN THE JOURNAL
OF AMERICAN MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
PSYCHIATRY. WHICH SHOWED THAT
WHEN YOU PROVIDE I AM A T. TO
AN OPIOID ADDICTED PERSON. OUR
LIFETIME HEALTH CARE ACRYLIC
JUSTICE COSTS ARE LOWER BY
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND AND A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS. THAT'S BECAUSE MATT IS
NOT VERY EXPENSIVE BUT A
REDUCES THE LIKELIHOOD OF
THINGS THAT ARE EXTREMELY
EXPENSIVE LIKE SOMETHING
HAPPENED AND SOMEONE HAVING AN
OVERDOSE GOING BACK TO
EMERGENCY ROOM. FOR SOMEONE
GOING BACK TO PRISON. SO THE
EVIDENCE ON THAT AND IT IS
QUITE CLEAR THAT THIS IS AN
INTELLIGENT PROPOSAL THAT IS
GOOD FOR PUBLIC SAFETY. AND
GOOD FOR PUBLIC HEALTH. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NOW GO TO THE
ROOM ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ON TO THE VIDEO CONFERENCING
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. AND
OUT TO THE TELEPHONE AT&T RT OF
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. SURE
IF YOU WISH TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR
A BI SEX FOUR FOUR PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO NOW AGAIN TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR A BI SIX FOUR FOUR
PRESS THE ONE AND THEN ZERO NOW.
AND WE HAVE ABOUT FIVE IN THE
QUEUE GLOBAL TO LINE FOUR OH
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING GOING BACK TO STREET
DRUGS POLICY ALLIANCE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MAXIM OF
TIME AB IF YOU'LL PLEASE CALL
HAD. GOOD EVENING THIS IS
ANTHONY DIMARTINO WITH
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY DEFICIT
IN COURT. THANK YOU. MAXON
MOTOR LINE FOUR OH FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. FOUR OH FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN YOU MAY BE NEEDED
I THANK YOU IT'S MICHAEL
SKIPPER REPRESENTING ALCOHOL
JUSTICE- WE BELIEVE IN THAT WE
BELIEVE THAT STRENGTH IN THIS
PROGRAM WILL HELP REDUCE THE
STIGMA ASSOCIATED WITH S. U. D.
AND ENCOURAGE MATT IN ONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS. WE SUPPORT THE
PROGRAM THANK YOU WE SUPPORT
THE BILL. MAXIMO TRYING TO
FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ALEX CALLING ON BEHALF
OF ALKERMES IN STRONG SUPPORT.
AND MAXIMO CAROLINE EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE WHAT I HAD. MARGO GEORGE
FOR THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND AT THAT TIME THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE IN THE QUEUE. NO ONE ELSE
IN THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU. ANY WHEN IT
OPPOSITION. C. N. LARGER ANTI
LAURIE LAURIE DURANT WITH
ADVOCATES FOR RESPONSIBLE
TREATMENT- WE'RE ALL VOLUNTEER
GRASSROOTS ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION APART FROM THE
ISSUE OF RECOVERY HOUSING- AB
SIX FORTY FOUR WHILE WELL
INTENTIONED AND WE ALSO SUPPORT
MATT NEEDS TO BE CLARIFIED TO
BE EXECUTED WILL. ENSURE
CARLY'S ARE NOT SENT TO FOR
PROFIT STATEMENT WHERE THEY CAN
BE EXPLOITED AND EXPOSED TO
ELEMENTS THAT WILL ENCOURAGE
THEM TO RELAPSE ON BODMIN
CRIMINAL ACTIVITIES SUCH AS
PATIENT BROKERING. IN THE BILL
MANY TERMS ARE ON OR POORLY
DEFINED WHICH LEAVES THE BILL
OPEN TO BROAD INTERPRETATION.
CARROTS AND CLEAR AWAY FORM A
TEAM REFERS TO WHEN A REFERENCE
TREATMENT INCLUDING THAT NON
MATTER INTEGRATED PROGRAMS
RESIDENTIAL OR OUTPATIENT
TREATMENT OR PUBLIC OR PRIVATE
PAY FUNDED TREATMENT. THEREIS
AN IMPORTANT QUESTION IS
WHETHER THE GOVERNMENT SHOULD
INCENTIVIZE PEOPLE TO STAY IN
MEDICARE ON MEDICATION LONGER
THAN THEIR POSITIONS MIGHT
RECOMMEND. WE WOULD URGE YOU TO
REWRITE IT FOR CLARIFICATION
AND UNINTENTIONAL NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ARE ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES. IN THE ROOM. IN
OPPOSITION ANY WITNESSES STERN
TELEX CONFERENCE QUICK STREAM
IN OPPOSITION. AND NOW WE'LL GO
TO EIGHTEEN T. DO YOU HAVE
ANYONE ON THE LINE. IN
OPPOSITION TO IT AB SIX SIX SIX
FOUR FOUR WALDRON. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE
THAT EIGHTY SIX FORECOURT PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO NOW AGAIN TO
OPPOSE THAT. EIGHTY SIX FOUR
FOUR PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
NOW. AND WE SHOW NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
WILL BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS. REBEKAH
POWER QUE HANNAH THANK YOU MISS
WALDRON FOR RINGING THIS BELL
AND OBVIOUSLY THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT WORK AND ENSURING
THAT WE WERE DOING THE WORK
WE'VE TALKED SO MUCH ABOUT
TODAY OF INSURING PEOPLE THAT
RECEIPT OF IT AND ACTUALLY
RECOVER I JUST HAVE A
CLARIFYING QUESTION WHICH IS. A
LITTLE CONFUSED JUST- SAYS THAT
YOU DON'T HAVE TO RETAIN
INSTITUTIONAL- TREATMENT IN
ORDER TO GET THE CREDIT OR IF
IT ACTUALLY MAKES INSTITUTIONAL
TREATMENT NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
CREDIT. CAN WE- YEAH I KNOW
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION- THE
REASON THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND CDCR AND I GOT
TOGETHER. WAS BECAUSE TO
CLARIFY EXACTLY THAT- IN FACT
WHEN PEOPLE ARE INSIDE. THEY
CAN PARTICIPATE AND SHOULD
HOPEFULLY AND MATT TREATMENT
PROGRAMS. BUT THEY DO THEN
QUALIFY FOR EARLY RELEASE
PROGRAMS. BUT THEY CAN IT
CONTINUE ONCE THEY'RE RELEASED
WITH DISSIPATE OUTSIDE. AS WELL
AS PEOPLE WHO DID NOT- DO
TREATMENT WITHIN THIS INSIDE
AND THEN WE TALK ABOUT PAROLE.
SO IT DOESN'T AFFECT THE
CREDITS THAT THEY WOULD GET IF
THEY PARTICIPATE INSIDE BECAUSE
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT. WHEN
FOLKS ARE INSIDE THEY'RE
ACTUALLY GETTING BENEFITS THAT
WILL ENABLE THEM TO RE ENTRY
SUCCESSFULLY AND WHAT WE FOUND
OUT THAT WILL IS- WITHIN THE
FIRST WEEK. OF EXITING PRISON.
THERE'S UP TO AN EIGHT TIME A
CHANCE OF OVERDOSE DEATHS FROM
SO THE GOAL OF THIS IS TO
PREVENT THAT IF THE PEOPLE OF
SERVE THEIR TIME IN A WORKING
TO GET BACK INTO SOCIETY. THAT
WE HELP IN THAT REENTRY. AND
YOU KNOW THE ORIGINAL BILL
THIRTEEN OH FOR WHAT WE FOUND
IN KENTUCKY FOR EXAMPLE FOR
EVERY DOLLAR- THAT WAS INVESTED
WE SAVE FOUR DOLLARS. BACK ON
THE COST OF PUBLIC SAFETY
ACOSTA. JUST RECIDIVISM COSTS
JUST A WHOLE NUMBER OF. THINGS
SO THANK YOU FOR THAT. THANK
YOU- ANY OTHER MEMBERS
QUESTIONS. SEEN NONE I THANK
YOU MISTER. POWER QUE HAN PRE
QUESTION EVEN THOUGH SOME OF US
FOR TRYING TO GET HOME TO OUR
FAMILIES BUT HE MADE THOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE I URGE AND I VOTE FOR.
CALDERON ONE EIGHTY SIX FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER A LACKEY
LACKEY I OUR CAN BARRICADE
HANNAH I CORK ARTWORK I
SANTIAGO. C. R. TWO ARTS
THEATER HI WICKES WICKES HI
LETE LETE I. THE MEASURE PASSES
THANK YOU THANK YOU. MR WARD AB
THREE ONE ONE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY TWO. I KNOW YOU WAITED
PATIENTLY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND- IT'S CERTAINLY-
ENJOY THE DISCUSSION THIS
AFTERNOON REALLY INFORMATIVE I
AM HERE TO PRESENT EIGHT ELEVEN
THE BILL REALLY INTENDED TO
PREVENT UNREGISTERED
UNTRACEABLE FIREARMS. OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS GHOST GUNS THESE
PRECURSOR KIT MARKETS WHICH
HAVE BEEN USED TO COMMIT
HORRIBLE CRIMES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING HOMICIDES
MASS SHOOTINGS AND THE MURDER
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS IN
JANUARY OF LAST YEAR THE L. A.
DIVISION OF THE BUREAU OF
ALCOHOL TOBACCO FIREARMS AND
EXPLOSIVES REPORTED THAT OVER
40% OF ITS CASES INVOLVE THESE
GHOST GUNS IN THAT RATIO IS
GROWING. UNDER EXISTING LAW AN
INDIVIDUAL MAY PURCHASE THESE
KIDS WITHOUT A BACKGROUND CHECK
FOR CASH AND WITHOUT RECEIPT AT
BEGUN SO PRIOR TO THE SOMETHING
THE KID AN INDIVIDUAL IS
SUPPOSED TO REGISTER THEM WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WOULD THEN
CONDUCT A PRECURSORY BACKGROUND
CHECK CAN PROVIDE THE SERIAL
NUMBER TO THE FIREARM BUT
SOMETIMES THEY ARE NOT
REGISTERED IN THE GHOST KIND
WHAT HAD NO SERIAL NUMBER IT'S
UNTRACEABLE BY LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AS IT STANDS THIS POSES A RISK
TO GUN TRAFFICKING TO BUILD-
UNSER REALIZE THERE ARM SOME OF
THEM WHICH CAN EASILY BE
DIVERTED INTO CRIMINAL ACTIVITY
SO THIS BILL IS INTENDED TO BE
ABLE TO PREVENT THE FURTHER
PROLIFERATION OF THESE WEAPONS
WAITING WOULD MEAN TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF MORE OF THESE
UNTRACEABLE AND UNREGULATED
FIREARMS FLOWING INTO OUR
COMMUNITY IT IS GOING TO
PROHIBIT THE SALE A FIRE OF
UNFINISHED FRAMES RECEIVERS AND
KIDS TO BUILD THESE GHOST GUNS
AT GUN SHOWS IN CALIFORNIA. IT
WOULD REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
UNTRACEABLE GHOST GUNS AND I'D
LIKE TO PRESENT MY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL STEVE
LINLEY THE PROGRAM MANAGER FOR
THE CALIFORNIA BRADY CAMPAIGN
AND LAUREN LEAVE THE CHAIR OF
THE BOARD. OF WOMEN AGAINST GUN
VIOLENCE. THANK YOU GOD.
WHENEVER THEY'RE READY. PAUL
AIRLINES ARE OPEN. THANK YOU
HAVE A MEMBER ON GOOD AFTERNOON
HONORABLE COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS TIFFANY I HAVE TWENTY
YEARS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
EXPERIENCE AND WAS THE CHIEF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
JUSTICE PERFORMS IN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE BRADY CAMPAIGN TO PREVENT
GUN VIOLENCE EFFORTS OF OUR
GOAL TO REDUCE FIRE VIOLENCE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES WE ARE PLEASED
TO TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE ELEVEN. IN
NINETEEN NINETY NINE
CALIFORNIAN ACT OF THE NATION'S
BY THIS LEGISLATION TO ENSURE
WE WILL BUSINESS PRACTICES THAT
CONTROLS DESPITE THIS THE
FEDERAL BUREAU OF ALCOHOL
TOBACCO FIREARMS IN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT JUSTICE
INVESTIGATION ATTENTION AS A
RESULT IN ARRESTS RESEARCH
OFFENSES INCLUDING SHOPPERS
JUST SOUTH OF FIREARMS TO
PROHIBIT PEOPLE I'M ASSERTION
OF ILLEGAL FIREARMS THIS ISSUE
HAS BEEN COMPOUNDED BY THE
RAPID AND UNCONTROLLED
PROLIFERATION OF GUNS GUNS.
LIKE FIREARMS ACOSTA KITS
PURCHASED A GUN SHOW SHOW UP A
CALIFORNIA CRIME SCENES AND ADD
TO THE VICTIMIZATION IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. MORE SO WE'RE NOT
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. FORESEEN
IT BIG COSTA CAN SHOW. ME SOME
PURCHASE A EMPEZAR. OF THAT GO
GUN MORNING HONESTLY PERSONONE
OTHER BROKEN WATER STORE OR
EVEN ONLINE. THERE'S NO VIDEO
EVIDENCE OF THE TRANSACTION
FROM SECURITY CAMERAS. YOUR
SEATS NO CREDIT CARDS NO
SHIPPING INFORMATION. ACTUALLY
UNTRACEABLE TRANSACTIONS.
UNTRACEABLE FIREARMS. NOT IN A
SINGLE CONTRACT AT GUN SHOWS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA WE
OBSERVE THE QUICK CASH AND
CARRY BUSINESS PRACTICE WITH
GHOST ADVENTURES WITH NUMEROUS
PERSONS TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
CLEARLY UNDER THE AGE OF TWENTY
ONE. AT SOME WHO ARE UNDER THE
AGE OF EIGHTEEN. COST CONCERNS
A CONTROLS OR THE NEW. FARM IS
OURS NO BACKGROUND CHECKS NO ID
NO SAFETY STANDARDS NO GUN
LOCKS AND NO AGE RESTRICTIONS
BECAUSE GUNS UNDERMINE NEARLY
ALL OF CALIFORNIA FIREARM LAWS
AND REGULATIONS. THE PASSAGE OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIBSON'S HIPS
IN THE BILL EIGHT SEVENTY NINE
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN WAS
MONUMENTAL IT WILL GO A VERY
LONG WAY AND SAVING LIVES
HOWEVER. WANTED BE IT WON'T BE
IMPLEMENTED UNTIL THE EARLIEST
OF JULY TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND
MORE IMPORTANTLY IT DOESN'T
REQUIRE TO TAKE WAITING PERIOD
A PERSON CAN WALK INTO A GUN
SHOW AND BE TEN MINUTES LATER
WITH ALL. THE COMPONENTS OF A
DANGEROUS SPIRAL. BOB THE SALE
GOES OF THE CONCERNS IS. BY
TURNING TO SUE STATE LAST YEAR
THAT DEPARTMENT HAS STOP THERE
THERE'S MANY INFO. AND PHONE
FOR. ACCOUNT GUN SHOWS. ALL WE
ALREADY KNOW FINALLY BY. COST
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS THE PROLIFERATION OF
COURSE GUNS HAVE ONLY ADDED TO
THESE COPS THIS IS YOUR GOES
GUNS FOR CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT ARE SKYROCKETING.
THE CALIFORNIA ZERO FARM STREET
FIVE HUNDRED AND 12% MORE.
THOSE GUNS FROM PERSONS
IDENTIFIED TO THE ARMED
PROHIBITED PERSON SYSTEM
DATABASE IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN. JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY. YEAH CALL BACK- AND
FIREARMS. ANGELES FIELD OFFICE.
BOARDED UP A FORTY OF THE CASE
THEY'RE INVESTIGATING INVOLVED
GOES COMES. SIMILARLY THE LOS
ANGELES POLICE DEPARTMENT
REPORTED 40% OF THE COMPANY
WILL COVER OR CONSIDERED THOSE
GUNS. AND SAN FRANCISCO OPEN
WITH CONSTITUENCIES BY LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT JUMPED SIX
HUNDRED PERCENT. BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN I'M SORRY
200-017-2000 NINETEEN. THE COST
OF PROBLEMS HERE IT'S GOING
EVERY MONTH AND HERE'S TO BE
THE WEAPON OF CHOICE IN THE
RECENT SHOOTINGS AND KILLINGS.
OF CALIFORNIA POLICE OFFICERS
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS IN COMMUNITY BASED
EFFORTS TO REDUCE. FIREARM
RELATED VIOLENCE CALIFORNIA
RECEIVE EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO
CONTINUE TO REDUCE PARLOR
FINEST THE CALIFORNIA WAS NOT
ALLOWED TO SELL GOES BEYOND THE
CONTROLS. WHICH INEVITABLY
ABSENT ACOSTA FINALLY
HOMICIDES. IN THE KITTY
REPRESENTATION AND DEFINITE
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK. TODAY AND
WE ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY MY NAME IS LAUREN LANE MY
FAMILY HAS PERSONALLY
EXPERIENCED GUN VIOLENCE AND
I'VE BEEN A GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION ADVOCATE IN
CALIFORNIA FOR MORE THAN TWENTY
YEARS MY CAREER OF MORE THAN
THIRTY YEARS WITH AN
EPIDEMIOLOGIST AT THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT I'M SPEAKING TODAY
AS A REPRESENTATIVE OF WOMEN
AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE A LOS
ANGELES BASED ORGANIZATION WITH
THE TWENTY EIGHT YEAR HISTORY
AND THEN BOUNCE CONVENTION. I
MEAN AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB THREE ONE
ONE. THE PROLIFERATION OF GHOST
GUNS IN OUR COMMUNITIES IS
DANGEROUS BRIGHTENING AND
COMPLETELY UNACCEPTABLE. WE
KNOW FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT
REPORTS THAT GOES DOWN THERE
MAKING UP A GREATER AND GREATER
PROPORTION OF RECOVERED CRIME
GUNS. THE EASE WITH WHICH BEST
GUNS CAN BE PURCHASED AT GUN
SHOWS WITHOUT A BACKGROUND FOR
PAPER WORK UNDERMINES
CALIFORNIA'S LONG HISTORY OF
LIFESAVING FIREARM REGULATION.
FRANKLY IT'S ABSURD THAT SUCH
RECKLESS BEHAVIOUR IS CURRENTLY
ALLOWED. NOT FAR FROM MY
COMMUNITY IN THE SUBURBS OF LOS
ANGELES A TEENAGER USED TO GO
SON TO MURDER TWO CLASSMATES
AND INJURING THREE OTHERS THREE
OTHERS ON THE CAMPUS OF SAUGUS
HIGH SCHOOL. AS A RESULT
PARENTS WILL NEVER HAD THEIR
CHILDREN AGAIN. CHILDREN AT THE
SCHOOL WILL LIVE WITH THE
TRAUMA OF WITNESSING THE
HORRIFYING ATTACK. AND THE
COMMUNITY HAS BEEN SCARRED
FOREVER. I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE
TO RECEIVE ONE OF THOSE PHONE
CALLS ABOUT A CHILD IN THE PATH
OF THE BULLET. MY CHILD
SURVIVED BUT I ALSO KNOW ABOUT
THE LIFELONG IMPACT ON FRIENDS
FAMILY AND THE COMMUNITY OF THE
CYNICAL AND EMOTIONAL TRAUMA
THAT GOES WITH GUN VIOLENCE. A
PUBLIC HEALTH RESPONSE DEMANDS
THAT WE STRIVE TO PREVENT GUN
VIOLENCE WE CAN DO THAT BY
MAKING IT HARDER FOR DANGEROUS
PEOPLE TO ACQUIRE FIREARMS
RATHER THAN MAKING IT EASIER BY
ALLOWING READILY ASSEMBLE PARTS
TO BE PURCHASED WHILE SKIRTING
REGULATION. HOW CAN THERE BE
ANY JUSTIFICATION FOR ENABLING
SUCH IRRESPONSIBLE BEHAVIOUR.
PRESERVING A LIFE IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN ANY RATIONALE
THAT COULD BE OFFERED. STRONG
GUN LAWS SAVE LIVES IN
CALIFORNIA HAS STEADFASTLY
PURSUED A PUBLIC HEALTH
PREVENTION APPROACH TO REDUCE
GUN VIOLENCE AND IT WORK.
ACCORDING TO GIFFORDS ANNUAL
SCORECARD CALIFORNIA HAS THE
STRONGEST GUN LAWS IN THE
NATION AND HAS ONE OF THE
LOWEST GUN DEATH RATES IN THE
COUNTRY. IF THE REST OF THE
NATION HAD GUN LAWS AS STRONG
AS CALIFORNIA'S ABOUT FIFTEEN
THOUSAND LIVES WOULD BE SAVED
EVERY YEAR. ANGEL THAT OUR LAWS
TO BE UPDATED TO REFLECT
CURRENT REALITIES AND TO CLOSE
DANGEROUS LOOPHOLES THEREBY
MAINTAINING DECORATE DECADES OF
HARD WORK BY THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE. I URGE YOU TO VOTE
HI ON AB THREE ONE ONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NOW WE TAKE IT
TO THE COMMITTEE ROOM SO YOU
KNOW. NO ONE HERE TO SUPPORT-
OF THE TELECONFERENCE LOSE
ANYONE IN SUPPORT. AND NOW WILL
TAKE IT TO THE TELEPHONE LINE
AT&T. SURE LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO USE SUPPORT AB
THREE ONE ONE PRESS ONE THEN
THEIR OWN NOW. TO SHOW SUPPORT
OF AB THREE ONE ONE PRESS. ONE
THEN ZERO NOW. WE HAVE ABOUT
FOUR IN THE QUEUE. GLOBAL TEL
LINE FOR TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OR A TOP ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. NEXT ALMOST TO LINE. FOR
TWELVE. GOOD EVENING THIS IS
JIM LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF A
FRIEND COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK
YOU. ENACT SOME OF THE LINE FOR
ELEVEN PLEASE WELL I HAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BRANDED UP ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SHERIFF AND PROUD
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. IN MAXIMO
FOR FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS CALL. IS ROSY AND SHARP IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE ELEVEN SH
FOR NEVER AGAIN CA AND SAN
DIEGO AND FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHERE 80% OF THE GUN
SALES AND MARK THEIR GROUND.
YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION
THANK YOU. NFS TIME THERE'S NO
ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE. THANK
YOU. ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION I HAVE SAM THREAT
IS. A GOC AND ROY GRIFFIN
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION. SALMON ROY. THANK
YOU SIR MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. OF
THE GROUP WOULD BE CANNOT BE
HAPPENING CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND
PISTOL ASSOCIATION THE NATIONAL
RIFLE ASSOCIATION SAN DIEGO
WILDLIFE FEDERATION I'M HERE TO
VOICE OUR STRONG OPPOSITION
PERSONALLY BILL THREE ELEVEN
ELEVEN IS YET ANOTHER STEP IN
THE VERY MISGUIDED LEGISLATION
DRESS OF THIS FARM PARTS
INSTEAD OF VIOLENT CRIMINALS
KNOWINGLY. USE FIREARMS IN THE
COMMISSION OF CRIMES. ASSEMBLY
EIGHT UP TO ASSIGN INTO LAW
TWENTY NINETEEN BY GOVERNOR
SOME. WHICH DOES NOT AFFECT THE
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE IT'S A
REQUIRED PART PRECURSOR PARTS
BE TREATED IN THE SAME MANNER
AS IF THEY ARE ACTUAL FARMS I
MEAN TO BE SOLD ONLY THROUGH A
DEALER. AND WITH A MANDATORY
BACKGROUND CHECKS. AB EIGHT
SEVEN NINE SPECIFICALLY
ADDRESSES PARTS CAN BE USED TO
REPAIR EXISTING FARM OR USED TO
ASSEMBLE ONE. PARTS INCLUDED OR
NOT I MEAN IT CHOOSE SUCH ITEMS
AS UNFINISHED RECEIVERS AND
PATIENT HANDGUN FRAMES. IN
ANOTHER CELLS PLEASE PARTY
CONSISTS TO TEST BOX BERMAN
THEIR PORTION NOT BE TREATED AS
SUCH. THE MANDATED. TRACKING
REQUIREMENTS AB SEVENTY NINE
OPENS THE DOOR FOR GOVERNMENT
CROSS REFERENCING THE PARTS
PURCHASED FOR VARIOUS FARMS
THAT MIGHT ALREADY BE
REGISTERED IN AN INDIVIDUAL'S
NAME. THIS ALONE IS PROBLEMATIC
AND COULDN'T ON WOULD ONLY MAKE
A LEGITIMATE AND LAWFUL GUN ON
RANDOM CRIMINAL. AB THREE
ELEVEN DOES NOT TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THE NORMANDY AND OUR
INTENTION COUNCIL WHICH WOULD
BE TO RECORD. CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
CURRENTLY HAS REACHED. TO
INCLUDE TRACKING ALL FOR THE
REGISTRATION OF ALL PER BY.
CHECKS WE PERIODS SIMILAR
PROCEDURES FOR A- PURCHASES AND
PUT. ALREADY WENT EIGHT SEVEN
NINE DIFFERENT BUT THAT
IMPLEMENTED THE DEAL WILL BE
TASKED WITH RECORD EACH NUMBER
OF TRANSITION TRANSACTIONS ON
FARMS SINCE OUR LITERALLY MADE
UP OF DOZENS OF PARTS. NOW ADD
TO THAT LIST OF
RESPONSIBILITIES PATROLLING GUN
SHOWS ALL OUT ALL OVER
CALIFORNIA FOR PARTS THAT ARE
NOT EVEN CLEARLY DEFINE. ALL
ALL THIS WHILE THE LIST OF OVER
TEN THOUSAND KNOWN AREN'T
BRITISH ALLEN CONTINUES TO GROW
IN CALIFORNIA. ABOUT THE
AUTHORS INTEND FOR THIS
LEGISLATION AS MENTIONED IN
JULY OF TWENTY SIXTEEN GOVERNOR
BROWN ALREADY SIGNED ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN PIMCO'S
GUN. WHICH REQUIRES THE
STERILIZATION. AB FIFTY SEVEN
ALREADY MAKES IT ILLEGAL TO
TERM FIREARM PRECURSOR PARGETER
FARM WITHOUT PROPER
REGISTRATION STERILIZATION FROM
D. O. J. AND THE COMPLETION OF
A BACKGROUND CHECK. SO WHAT IS
THE TRUE INTENT IN THE SESAME
OF AB THREE ELEVEN. WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT TO THE AUTHOR
SHOULD WE ARE SEEKING TO MAKE A
SELL THESE PARTS UNLAWFUL AND
AFTER OFFICERS IN UNIFORM TO
ENFORCE IT. WE WERE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED ASSEMBLY MEMBER IT
IS CLOSE COULD PLEASE PROVIDE
US WITH A FIREARM PRECURSOR
PARTS DEFINITION WE BASS FOR
THIS MANY TIMES. IT IS YET TO
BE RECEIVED FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE. THE ALIFORNIA
RIFLE AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION
WILL CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
COMMONSENSE GUN LAWS FOCUSED ON
VIOLENT CRIMINALS WHO CHOOSE
USE FARMS TO BREAK THE LAW
HOWEVER AB THREE ELEVEN WILL
NOT DO THAT SHE'S ONLY.
COMPLICATES THE AVAILABILITY OF
SHORT RUN UNTIL TEN PARTS
NEEDED TO REPAIR AND UPGRADE.
LAWFULLY OBTAINED FARMS. YOU
CAN IS A VERY. OF OREGON THEIR
IT HAS BEEN OUR COSTA GOAL TO
TOWARD COMMON SOLUTIONS YOUR
THE ISSUE OF CRIME AND FARM. IS
CAN DONE HOW WITH SACRIFICE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS. AND
ABILITY OF LAW ABIDING CITIZENS
PROTECT THEIR FAMILIES TO HAUNT
ENJOY COMPETITIVE SHOOTING
EVENTS. AND CERTAINLY CAN BE
DONE WITHOUT BANNING THE LAWFUL
OF THE LAWFUL ACTIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS TO PARKS THEY NEED
TO REPAIR THE EQUIPMENT THEY
CHOOSE TO BUY AND ENJOY. POLICE
FOREGOING REASONS A CALIFORNIA
RIFLE AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION
AND OTHER STAND IN STRONG
OPPOSITION AB THREE ELEVEN AND
STRONGLY URGE YOUR NO VOTE FOR
THIS MISGUIDED LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME. THANK
YOU MISTER. MISTER CHAIRMAN.
JIM HE WAS CREDITS. GUNNERS
CAL. I'M SORRY I THINK YOU ONLY
LEFT YOU ONE MINUTE BUT GO HEAD.
STOCKTON FAMILY BE FAXED OKAY
I'M REPRESENTING GOVERNORS
CALIFORNIA AND THE NATIONAL
SHOOTING SPORTS FOUNDATION I
NEED TO POINT OUT A COUPLE OF
THINGS- AFTER SPEAKING WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES INCLUDING
THOSE A TWO FOUR AND SIX
THERE'S THEY'RE STARTING TO
TELL ME THAT EVERY TIME THAT A
CRIMINAL. HE RACES A SERVER
NUMBER OFF A GUN AND MARTINES
THEY'RE CALLING THAT A GHOST
GUN SO THE PROLIFERATION HIS IS
A MESS. CALIFORNIA'S GUN SHOWS
IN HAVE BEEN TOUTED BY EVEN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AS SOME OF THE MOST
CRIME FREE GUN SHOWS IN THE
COUNTRY THEY COMPLY WITH ALL
LAWS FOR DEALERS OF AMMUNITION
OF- UP MY ARMS AND NOW
PRECURSOR PARTS IS. WE WOULD
KNOW WHAT THAT WAS IF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE DID THE
JOB THAT THE LEGISLATURE TOLD
THEM TO DO AND GAVE US A
PICTORIAL- INDICATION OF WHAT
THESE WHAT QUALIFIED AS A-
PRECURSOR PART AND WHAT DID
NOT. THAT WE ARE SENATE LEAVE
WITHOUT. THAT BUT- THERE THERE
WERE IS EVIDENCE A GUN SHOWS
UP- PRECURSOR PARCEL THE GUN
SHOWS LEAD TO PROLIFERATION OF
CRIMINALLY USE THOSE GUNS THERE
IS NO CONNECTION. UNFORTUNATELY
WHAT APPEARS TO BE AN ATTEMPT
TO NEEDLESSLY CRIPPLED GUN
SHOWS HAVE BEEN OPERATING IN
THE STATE. FRANKLY WITHOUT
INCIDENT FOR MANY YEARS
REGARDLESS OF WHAT YOUR TO THE
TESTIMONY YOU IT HURTS THE
TRUTH IS THEY ARE SOME OF THE
MOST LAW ABIDING UNDER CURRENT
LAW ALL. SHOWS UP PRECOCIAL
PARTS MUST BE PROCESSED THROUGH
A LICENSED DEALER AND REQUIRE A
BACKGROUND CHECK WITH THE PARTS
ARE SOLD ON A BRICK AND MORTAR.
STORE OR AT A AT A GUN SHOW THE
TERM GUN SHOW LOOPHOLE THIS IS
SIGNIFICANT MISNOMER GIVEN THAT
EVERY GUN SHOW MUST COMPLY WITH
EVERY STATUTE. BACKGROUND
CHECKS WAITING PERIODS AND
REGISTRATION AND REGARDLESS OF
WHAT WHAT YOU HEAR IN TESTIMONY
HERE WE KNOW FOR A FACT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
REGULARLY SENDS AGENTS INTO GUN
SHOWS TO INVESTIGATE THE SALES
AND ACTIVITIES ARE GOING ON AND
THEY STILL RARELY COME BACK.
WITH THE- INDICATION OF CRIMES
BEEN COMMITTED. ANY ADOLESCENT
DEALER WHO BREAKS THE LAW.
SHOULD BE CHARGED WITH BREAKING
THE LAW. IN FACT ACCORDING TO
NOT OF THE U. S. DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE REPORT. ON THE SOURCE
AND USE OF FIREARMS INVOLVED.
IN CRIME. NOW SHE JUST ONLY ONE
POINT THREE. PERCENT OBTAINED A
GUN FROM A RETAIL SOURCE
INCLUDING REGISTERED- PRECURSOR
PART DEALERS AND EVEN FEWER
FROM GUN SHOWS THE EVIDENCE IS
VERY CLEAR THE COUNCIL'S
THEMSELVES AND THE LAW ABIDING
ATTENDEES ARE NOT THE PROBLEM-
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS.
HERE IN AMERICA WE'VE BEEN
MAKING SO CALLED GHOST GUNS
SINCE THE FORMATION OF THE
COUNTRY IN ALL FIFTY STATES
MAKING THE GUN AT HOME HAS BEEN
ALLOWED BY EVERY STATE AND
EVERY HAND THAT FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. ALL WE'RE DOING IS
CONTINUING TO DO THAT IT IS
LEGAL TO DO SO AS LONG AS YOU
DO OT SELL THAT THAT OR
TRANSFER THAT BYRON HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE ADD THE
REQUIREMENT THAT A SERIAL
NUMBER BE ADDED TO THAT TO BE
LEGAL WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT
THESE LAWS ARE ONLY AFFECTED
LAW ABIDING CITIZENS THEY ARE
NOT. AFFECTING THE CRIMINALS IN
ANY WAY. AND WHEN YOU WHEN
SOMEBODY POINTS OUT THAT WE CAN
PREVENT TWELVE THOUSAND DEATHS
IN THE STATE GOVERNMENT THAT IS
GOOD HOLDEN NUMBER. OF
HOMICIDES WITH A GUN NATIONWIDE
LAST YEAR NOT CALIFORNIA. OKAY
SO YOU'RE- UP. LATE BUT WHEN WE
NEED TO NOT BE DRAMATIC. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS. WITH THE
STRONGEST. OF BLOOD CONCERNED
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL ASK. FOR NO
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NUMBER GO TO THE AUDIENCE
ANYONE. IN OPPOSITION. TO THE
TELECONFERENCE. A VIDEO SCREEN
NOTHING AND NOW- TO EIGHTY
EIGHTY TO THE PHONE LINES. ANY
OPPOSITION TO AB. THREE ONE
ONE. IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE OF
AB THREE ONE ONE PRESS ONE THEN
THEY'RE ON NOW AGAIN TO OPPOSE
OF AB YEAR THREE ONE ONE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO NOW. WE NEED TO
HAVE ABOUT FIVE IN THE QUEUE
LOCAL TO LINE FOR ALL NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HARI HI. YES
YOU ARE YOU MAY BEGIN ANYTIME
YOU NAME AN ORGANIZATION. MY
NAME MY NAME IS SANDRA HAD
STRONG. AB MY AFFILIATION IS A
LIFETIME PRO GUN CONTROL
DEMOCRATS. AND I'M CALLING IN
SICK ALL SUBMISSIONS TO THE- GO
AHEAD YOUR STRONG OPPOSITION GO
AHEAD. MAXALT TIELINE ONE SIXTY
FOUR PLEASE FARHAD. RYAN ONE
SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN YOU
MAY BE NEEDED. HELLO MATE YES
IT DOES I NEVER GOT A NUMBER
OKAY I WAS JUST TAKING A CHANCE
THIS IS CARLENE ELLIS I AM A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE
AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION THE
NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION GUN
OWNERS OF CALIFORNIA BUT I ALSO
REPRESENT THE OVER FIVE HUNDRED
MEMBERS OF THE SACRAMENTO
DEFENSIVE CONSOLE SHOOTERS
ASSOCIATION WE STAND IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO AB THREE ELEVEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM.
MAXIM OF TEL NINE FOUR
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
RON LANDER CHAIRMAN OF THE
SAYING BOTH THE INLAND EMPIRE
CHAPTER OF THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE
AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB THREE ELEVEN. THANK
YOU. MAXIMO TIMELINE. FOR
FOURTEEN. WHY AM FOR FOURTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS BRIAN LONG I'M A MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION RIVERSIDE CHAPTER I
AM STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU SIR. AND NEXT LEVEL
TIMELINE ONE SEVENTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. RESEARCHERS ESTIMATE
BAND I'M THE CHAIR OF THE SOUTH
SACRAMENTO CHAPTER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION AND IN A REMEMBER
IN STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
SIR. L. LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE ONE
MORE AND MAKE YOUR WILL BE JUST
A MOMENT. AND AGAIN TO OPPOSE
THAT AB EIGHT THREE ONE ONE ONE
THAN ZERO NOW JUST A MOMENT FOR
THE NEXT LINE. WE'LL NEXT GO TO
LINE FOR EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE FOUR EIGHTEEN I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF MY HUSBAND
TO DANIEL MCKINNON AND MYSELF.
WHO VERY RECENTLY BECAME A
LEGAL GUN OWNERS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. WE ARE LIFELONG
GUN CONTROL DEMOCRATS AND WE
ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS
LEGISLATION AND WE ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THE ONGOING ATTACK
ON OUR CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS
WHICH I LIKE MANY OTHERS ARE
COMING TO UNDERSTAND AND
LAWFULLY EXERCISED IN THE WAKE
OF WHAT THIS CORRUPT THE
LEGISLATURE IS DOING. IT'S AND
AT THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE IN THE QUEUE. THANK YOU
WITHOUT NOW BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE- WE'LL START WITH
MISS WICKS WHO HAD A NAME AND A
PERSON MISTER SARATOGA THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- I THINK YOU
AS A MEMBER WARD FOR BRINGING
THE BILL IN YOUR LADERSHIP ON
THIS I'M EXCITED TO HAVE YOU AS
A COLLEAGUE HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE- YOUR FRESHMAN TERM
AND I WOULD LOVE TO BE ADDED AS
A CO AUTHOR. THINKING THIS
WORKS. THE SEATTLE HI- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WARD- THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONCERN ON THIS ISSUE NUMBER
ONE- WHERE DO LAW ABIDING
CITIZENS PURCHASE PRECURSOR
PARTS WHICH ARE PARTS FOR
BROKEN GUNS ARE HARDER TO MAKE
ONE YOURSELF. CURRENTLY THAT
HAS. DID THAT WILL PREVENT THE-
MAKING OF A GHOST GUN. IS THAT
WHERE THEY PURCHASED THEM RIGHT
CURRENTLY THEY'RE ACTUALLY ABLE
TO BE PURCHASED AT BRICK AND
MORTAR STORES ONLINE AND- AT
THESE GUN SHOWS SO- WE KNOW
THAT THE IMPORTANT WORK THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIBSON'S BILA
DONE THROUGH EIGHTY EIGHT
SEVENTY NINE IS GOING TO BE
ABLE TO- CURTAIL SOME OF THE
ONLINE AND REGULATED ACTIVITY
THIS BILL AB THREE ELEVEN SEEKS
TO FURTHER NARROW THAT AND WORK
ON THE ISSUE AT GUN SHOWS WITH
SISTER A LITTLE BIT MORE
PERMEABLE- IN THEIR
TRANSACTIONS. SO IT STILL
RETAINS A LAWFUL AN ELIGIBLE
GUN OWNERS RIGHT TO BE ABLE TO
PURCHASE A PRECURSOR KID PART
AT A BRICK AND MORTAR STORE IN
CALIFORNIA. SO THAT WOULD BE A
RETAILER THAT CAN SELL IT AND
THEN OTHER RETAILERS THAT GO TO
GUN SHOWS THAT ARE OUT
OFTENTIMES. BRICK AND MORTAR
OWNERS. THE IMPORTANT THING IS
THAT AND SHOW I'M SORRY AND I'M
THERE. YES SO THE IMPORTANT
THING IS THAT THE POINT OF SALE
AND THE NATURE OF THE
ENVIRONMENT IN WHICH THAT SALE
TAKES PLACE THAT THERE ARE
BETTER CONTROLS WE ALSO KNOW
FROM THE- DEPARTMENT JUSTICE
THAT THEY ARE NOT THEY'VE TOLD
US THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO ENFORCE
MANY OF THE REGULATIONS AT GUN
SHOWS. SO IN THE EFFORT TO BE
ABLE TO FURTHER CURTAIL GUN
VIOLENCE AND PROVIDE
PROTECTIONS FOR OUR COMMUNITIES
I THINK THIS BILL SEEKS TO BE
ABLE TO TRAIN THOSE TOWARDS
BRICK AND MORTAR STORES ONLY.
MY CONCERN IS FOR LAW ABIDING
CITIZENS. WHO NEED GUN PARTS.
TO REPAIR THEIR GUNS AND
PROTECT THEMSELVES. I HEAR THAT
WHILE IN THE MEANWHILE WE HAVE
NON LIFE BY LAW AIDING
CITIZENS. WHO VICTIMIZE
EVERYONE ELSE. AND I'VE SEEN A
LOT OF THOSE- I'VE HAD POLICE
OFFICER FRIENDS KILLED BY THEM-
THEY ARE GHOST GUNS BUT THEY'RE
NOT JUST GHOST GUNS MADE BY
PEOPLE. THEIR GHOST GUNS WHO
WITH SERIAL NUMBER SHAVED OFF-
BAD GUYS ARE GONNA GET THEIR
GUNS. BECAUSE THEY DON'T JUST
COME FROM CALIFORNIA ARE GUN
SHOWS THEY COME FROM ACROSS. IN
OTHER COUNTRIES- IT I KNOW I
JUST DON'T SEE HOW THIS IS
GOING TO HAVE A BIG IMPACT ON
THE SO I'M NOT GOING TO BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL. ANYONE
ELSE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS. WHICH
WAS PARKED QUE HANNAH I WANT TO
JOIN NETWORKS AND THANKING YOU
FOR THIS EFFORT IN EXPANDING ON
MR GIVES IMPORTANT WORK IN THIS
SPACE AND ASK TO JOIN YOUR CALL
THANK. YOU CAN EXPECT. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST HER AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
AND THANK YOU IN THE INTEREST
OF TIME JURORS RECOMMEND I VOTE.
AND YOU MAY CALL THE ROLL ON AB
THREE ELEVEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER HI JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY. LACKEY NO
BARRICADE HIM BACK HE HAD AYE
CORK. QUICK NOT VOTING
SANTIAGO. SEE OUR TOE NO SEE
OUR TURN NOW WICKS HI WICKS I
LI LI I. MEASURES ARE CALLED
NEED TO ONE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU. THERE WERE TWO
OR LAST TWO. YEAH NUMBER ELEVEN
AB TWO EIGHT TWO LACKEY
MISDEMEANOR DIVERSION AND
NUMBER TWELVE AB SIX SIX NINE
LACKEY FIREARMS AND SAPE AND
GUNS. ROOF SAVE THE BEST FOR
LAST. ALL RIGHT WELL THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS. WE'VE
BEEN HERE AWHILE. DIGITAL I'LL
TRY TO BE SO SICK TO DIRECT
BUT- WHAT THESE BILLS ARE VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME SO I DON'T WANT
TO SHORT CHANGE THEM. FIRST OF
ALL LET ME THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT. THIS
FIRST BILL- TWO EIGHTY TWO. I
DON'T WANT TO START BY SAYING I
WILL ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE'S
MEMBERS TO NARROW THE BILL. DO
YOU AYE OFFENSES. DIVERSION IS
ACTUALLY AN ALTERNATIVE. TO
CRIMINAL CONVICTION. FOR
OFFENDERS. I'D JUST REAL
QUICKLY I WANT YOU TO HEAR WHAT
THE GOVERNOR SAID WHEN HE
APPROVED AND SIGNED THE
DIVERSION BILL BY A MOSTLY
MEMBER TEAM. THAT WAS THIRTY
TWO THIRTY FOUR IF YOU CARE.
AND THIS IS WHAT THE WHAT HE
SAID. HE HIT I'M NOT GONNA READ
THE WHOLE THING BECAUSE HE
BASICALLY SUPPORTS THE BILL
MANY SAID HOWEVER I'M CONCERNED
THAT THE CRIME OF DRIVING UNDER
THE INFLUENCE WAS NOT EXCLUDED
FROM THE MISDEMEANOR DIVERSION
PROGRAM. I WILL SEEK TO
EXPEDITIOUSLY REMEDY THIS
ISSUE. WITH THE LEGISLATURE IN
THE NEXT LEGISLATIVE SESSION
AND I WAS PROBABLY. ANXIOUS TO
ANSWER THAT CALL MUCH OF THIS
BILL IS- THIS PARTICULAR BILL
WOULD HAVE EXCLUDED OTHER
CRIMES HEY CRIMES CHILD ABUSE
ELDER ABUSE ALSO FROM DIVERSION.
HOWEVER NOW IT NO LONGER DOES
THAT IT'S SPECIFICALLY TO OUR
DELIGHT OFFENSES. LET ME TELL
YOU WHY I'M SO COMMITTED TO
THIS BILL EVERYBODY. THERE'S
NOTHING THERE'S NO OTHER CRIME
BUT I'M MORE FAMILIAR WITH I
SPENT TWENTY OF MY TWENTY EIGHT
YEARS WORKING GRAVEYARD SHIFT.
IN THE FOCUS OF THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL DURING THOSE
HOURS IS TO REMOVE IMPAIRED
DRIVERS FROM THE ROADWAY BEFORE
THEY CAUSE CALAMITY. I WAS
SUCCESSFUL IN STOPPING SOME AND
I WAS UNFORTUNATELY THE
RESPOND- TO MULTIPLE TRAGEDIES.
I'M A NON DRINKER I'VE NEVER
DRANK AN ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE BY
CHOICE. SO WHEN I FIRST CAME ON
THE HIGHWAY PATROL I DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND THIS IMPAIRMENT
THANK. WHEN I FIRST WAS SHOWED
WHAT WAS AN IMPAIRED INDIVIDUAL
THAT THEY WERE SUBJECT TO
ARREST THAT THAT HELP UNFAIR.
THIS PERSON DOESN'T LOOK DRUNK.
AND THAT'S BECAUSE YOU DON'T
HAVE TO BE DRUNK. TO ACTUALLY
BE THE IMPETUS TO SERIOUS
TRAGEDY I LEARNED THAT AND I
LEARNED IT BY GROUP RESPONDING
TO CASE AFTER CASE AFTER CASE
WITH THE SAME LEVELS OF. BLOOD
ALCOHOL CONCENTRATION. I JUST
WANT YOU TO KNOW EVERYBODY I'M
I'M NOT. HERE PORTION THIS BILL
BECAUSE I WANT PUNISHMENT. I
WANT PREVENTION AND I WILL TELL
YOU THAT IF YOU DON'T HAVE A
CONVICTION FOR DO YOU WHY. IT'S
MUCH HARDER TO GET THAT IT'S
MUCH HARDER TO ARRIVE. AT THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WILL. KEEP
THE OFFENDER FROM REPEATING.
AND THAT HELPS US IDENTIFY
THOSE WHO ARE REPEATING OVER
AND OVER SO THAT WE CAN TRY TO
GET THE INTERVENTION. AND I
JUST HOPE THAT YOU'LL
UNDERSTAND. THE POWER OF THIS
BILL IF IT'S NOT SUCCESSFUL. I
PROMISE YOU I DON'T HAVE
STUDIES OTHER THAN MY OWN LIFE
EXPERIENCE TO TELL YOU THE
PEOPLE WILL DIE. NEEDLESSLY IF
WE DON'T PASS THIS MEASURE. AND
I HAVE A SOMEONE A WITNESS I
HAD TO BUT- WE'RE ONLY GONNA
HAVE ONE. AND THAT'S GOING TO
BE NEAR THE SOLANO. BUSTLE MEN
AND SHE'S WITH CRIME VICTIMS
UNITED HOPEFULLY SHE'S ON THE
LINE. I AM CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
WE CAN GREAT YOU MAY BEGIN
THANK. FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU
ON A WHEELCHAIR- JONES SAWYER
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
ALLOWING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK. CRAPPIE COMMISSION
EITHER WANT TO FIRST THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR RECOGNIZING.
POURTANT MESSED UP PORTENT AT
THIS BILL AND THAT EFFECT ON
PUBLIC SAFETY AND ON CRIME
VICTIMS. DO YOU LIVE OUR CRIMES
THAT PERMEATE OUR SOCIETY AND
CREATE. VICTIMS AS WELL AS- THE
ALCOHOLISM THAT PLAGUED PEOPLE
WITHIN OUR SOCIETY. UNITED
SUPPORT MEANINGFUL CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM UNFORTUNATELY AB
THREE TWO THREE FOUR WAS NOT
THAT WHEN IT COLLECTED TO
INCLUDE DRIVING UNDER THE
INFLUENCE AS A PARENT THAT
SHOULD NOT BE DEFERRED IT. WHAT
THAT DOES IS ACTUALLY PUT
PUBLIC THE PUBLIC SAFETY OF
CALIFORNIA AT RISK AND IT
CREATES MORE VICTIMS. JUST ON
ONE DAY ALONE WHICH WOULD LEAVE
YOUR THE OF THIS YEAR
CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCED THIRTY
DEATH THAT'S NOT JUST THE U. I.
ARREST THE THIRTY DEATHS DUE TO
DRUG DRIVING UNDER THE
INFLUENCE. THAT TO ME IS JUST
STAGGERING WHEN YOU THINK OF
THAT AND JUST ONE DAY OUT OF
THE YEAR- ANYTIME THAT MULTIPLY
THAT THROUGH THE THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY FOUR WE ARE FACING OUR
CORTES PEOPLE GREAT BODILY IT
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN INJURED. I
LISTENED EARLIER TO THE
FAMILIES ACROSS MY HEART OF THE
G. LIKE DRIVERS WHO TOOK OFF
AND LEFT PEOPLE TO DIE THAT
HAPPENS. EVERY DAY IN OUR
STREETS- IT IS AN- THAT WE KEEP
THIS AS A PARABLE OFFENSE I
WOULD JOIN WITH THE HONORABLE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JACQUI AND SAY
THIS IS NOT ABOUT PUNISHMENT.
IT REALITY THIS IS ABOUT
PREVENTION AND I CAN SPEAK TO
THAT PERSONALLY. I HAD AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO I WAS MARRIED TO
WHO HAD AN ALCOHOL IS AN ISSUE.
AND HE DROVE DRUNK IN WHOLE
WALL. LUCKILY NOBODY WAS HURT
BUT I WAS THE ONE THAT MADE THE
CALL TO HAVE HIM ARRESTED. AND
ABOUT THAT ARREST THOUGH IT WAS-HIS SECOND EAGLE AYE HE FINALLY
THE LIGHT WENT ON. AND HE
STARTED PROGRAMMING HE WENT
THROUGH REHABILITATION HE'S IN
A ON A CONSISTENT BASIS. I
TRULY BELIEVE THAT WOULD
BECAUSE NOT BECAUSE I MADE THAT
CALL BUT BECAUSE OF IT BEING A
SECOND DO YOU WHY AND THE
REQUIREMENTS ON THAT OF
ATTENDING CERTAIN THINGS. THAT
IT REALLY DID CHANGE WITH
INDIVIDUAL APPLY. THERE WAS
ANOTHER SPEAKER THAT WAS GOING
TO BE HERE THIS EVENING-
UNFORTUNATELY SHE COULD NOT
HANDLE IT FIVE YEARS AGO TODAY
HER SON WAS KILLED BY DUI
DRIVER IMPOSTER COUNTY ON
HIGHWAY FORTY NINE. THERE WERE
THREE BOYS WALKING TOGETHER TO
THE LOST THEIR LIVES THE
SURVIVING BOY IS SCARRED FOR
LIFE HE WAS EIGHT THIRD TIME
DUI OFFENDER. SO HAVING THESE
CARPOOL DELIGHTS AND NOT
DEFERRED EXAM IS CRITICAL NOT
ONLY FOR PUBLIC SAFETY BUT LIKE
I SHARED WITH YOU A VERY
PERSONAL STORY FOR PREVENTION.
SO ON BEHALF OF CRIME VICTIMS
UNITED ON BEHALF OF PUBLIC
SAFETY IN CALIFORNIA. I AGAIN
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
PRETTY MUCH SUPPORT I KNOW HE
HAS PERSONAL EXPERIENCE LIKE I
DO. AND I WOULD URGE THIS
COMMITTEE TO PLEASE PLEASE PASS
THIS BILL SO THAT WE CAN
PROTECT INNOCENT LIVES IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
DO YOU. ALBERT TO REDUCE NAME
ON HERE IS THE- RESIDENTS NEXT
ONE THE NEXT ONE. DO YOU HAVE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES. YOU DID
NOT OKAY- OUR LIST WILL GO TO
THE ROOM. NO I DON'T SEE ANYONE
THAT'S- BUT HERE IN SUPPORT AND
ON THE VIDEO SCREEN. AND NOW
LET'S GO TO COLLEGE AT&T ARE
THERE IN SUPPORT FOR MR
LACKEY'S BILL. AND MAYBE EVEN
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR A BI Q. EIGHT Q.
PRESSED ONE THEN THEY'RE ALL
NOW AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR
AB TWO EIGHT TO PRESS ONE THEN
THERE ARE NOW. I MEAN DO YOU
HAVE ABOUT FOUR IN THE QUEUE
WELL FIRST CALL TO NINE FOUR
ZERO TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
WHO SHALL MATURE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MAXED ALMOST
TIMELINE FOR TWENTY THREE
PLEASE CALL HAD. YOUR MEMBERS
GOOD EVENING JONATHON FELDMAN
THE CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. MADTOM OF
CAROLINA ONE SIXTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING CHAIRMAN
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS GAIL
STEWARD ON BEHALF OF SAN DIEGO
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY SUMMER
STEPHAN IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO EIGHTY TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MAX
SOMEONE TO LINE FOR TWENTY TWO
PLEASE CALL I HAD. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS-
LARRY MORSE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO EIGHT TWO. THANK YOU SIR.
ENACT A MOTEL NINE ONE THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHARE
MEMBERS RANGE ALONG WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO THE CREATION ALL
FROM FOR. THANK YOU. THERE'S NO
ONE ELSE CAN MAKE YOU. THANK
YOU NOW WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
I'VE GOT THE SHORT END FROM
ACLU AND PETER CALLOWAY SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE. YES GOOD GOOD EVENING
KAREN AND MEMBER KATHY SURE FOR
A DEAL YOU CALIFORNIA ACTION WE
RESPECTFULLY NOT SUPPOSED
EIGHTY TO EIGHTY TWO- I WANT TO
START BY THANKING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LACKEY FOR HIS FOCUS ON
PREVENTION BUT ALSO TO SAY THAT
THIS YOU KNOW IT'S A LONG WAY
TO ACHIEVE THAT. MISDEMEANOR
DIVERSION IS AN IMPORTANT TOOL
THAT ALLOWS JUDGES TO DETERMINE
BASED ON THE INDIVIDUAL
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE CASE
WHETHER PUBLIC SAFETY IS BEST
SERVED BY PROCEEDING WITH THE
CRIMINAL PROSECUTION. OR BY
CONVERTING THE CASE- FROM
PROSECUTION THERE'S NO OFFENSE
FOR WHICH THE VERSION IS THE
ONLY OPTION I WANTED TO MAKE
THAT CLEAR IT IT ALWAYS BY THE
DECISION OF THE JUDGE THAT IT
IS THE BEST CHOICE IN THIS CASE.
IN THE VERSION THE DEFENDANT
GETS THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
THE CRIMINAL CHARGES AGAINST.
AGAINST FROM. THE VENTRALLY.
COMPLIANCE WITH THE TERMS SET
BY THE JUDGE AND PARTICIPATION
IN WHATEVER PROGRAM PROJECT
ORDER. AGUIAR-CURRY A DIVERSION.
IS GOOD RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
DEFENDANTS WHOSE CASES ARE
DIVERTED AND MONITORED BY THE
COURT ARE FAR LESS LIKELY TO RE
OFFEND PREVENTING THOSE FUTURE
CRIME AND FAR MORE LIKELY TO
FIND EMPLOYMENT IN FUTURE THAN
THOSE WHO ARE CONVICTED- AND-
AND- HAVE TERMS LIKE LOCATION
OR NOT WHATEVER PENALTY MIGHT
BE IMPOSED. MISDEMEANOR DUI
OFFENDERS LIKE OTHER OFFENDERS
SHOULD WHERE THE JUDGE FINDS IT
APPROPRIATE HAVE THIS CHANCE.
TO AVOID CRIMINAL CONVICTION.
EXEMPTION OF D. Y. FOR MISTER
DIVERSE IS NOT NECESSARY TO
MAKE THIS PROGRAM CONSISTENT
WITH THE EXISTING VEHICLE CODE
PROVISION REGARDING THE PERSON
FOR D. Y. AND- THE LEGISLATURE
HAS PREVIOUSLY ACTED TO CLARIFY
THAT THE PERSON PROGRAM.
AVAILABLE TO MEMBERS OF THE
MILITARY AND VETERANS INCLUDES
MISDEMEANOR DELIGHT IS NOT
WITHSTANDING SECTION TWENTY SIX
THREE FORTY OF THE VEHICLE CODE
AND COULD ADD TO THAT
CLARIFICATION HERE AS WELL IF
THE CONCERNED IN. OCTOBER THE
POTENTIAL FOR CONFLICT. BETWEEN
THE TWO PROFESSIONAL FOOTBALL.
THIS WE KNOW ALLOWING TO
DETERMINE WHETHER TO VERSION IS
THE BEST COURSE OF ACTION IN
PARTICULAR CASE PROTECT PUBLIC
SAFETY BY PREVENTING RECIDIVISM
IT PRESERVES PUBLIC RESOURCES
AND HELP THE FOUNDERS TO MOVE
ON TO A LOT. THIS IS TRUE FOR
THOSE WHO ARE CHARGED WITH
MISDEMEANOR D. Y. AS IT IS FOR
OTHER DEFENDANTS CHARGED WITH
OTHER CRIMES WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE ON EIGHTY
TO EIGHTY TWO. THANK YOU MR
CALLAWAY. NOW GOOD EVENING
SHARE MEMBERS PETER CALLOWAY
THAT THE PUBLIC DEFENDER IN SAN
FRANCISCO I WORK IN THE
MISDEMEANOR UNIT WHICH HANDLES
THE VAST MAJORITY OF. YOU I'VE
SENT THIS YEAR- ECHOING MAKE
SURE IT'S A IT'S A COMMON
MISCONCEPTION THAT PEOPLE
PUSHING FOR REFORM EVEN IN THIS
SPACE- DON'T CARE ABOUT
REDUCING HARM WHEN ACTUALLY THE
REVERSE IS TRUE- AND MAKE SURE
NOTED. DIVERSION HELPS PREVENT
CRIME CONVICTION DOES NOT
FULLER IT SURE MAKES THIS VERY
VERY CLEAR IN FACT THERE WAS A
RECENT STUDY OUT OF BOSTON
SHOWING THAT DECLINING TO
PROSECUTE NONVIOLENT
MISDEMEANOR CASES REDUCES THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT THAT PERSON
WILL GO ON TO COMMIT ANY OTHER
CRIME IN THE FUTURE- DIVERSION
IS NOT MANDATED IN ANY CASE IT
NEARLY ENABLE JUDGES TO OFFER
IT IN THE RARE CASES WHEN THEY
DEEM IT APPROPRIATE- AND JUDGES
ACROSS THE STATE NEWS ONE
THOUSAND ONE POINT NINE FIVE
RARELY AND ALMOST NEVER. FOR
DRIVING UNDER THE INFLUENCE. IN
CASES WHERE DOES DOES THIS
JUDGE DECIDE TO OFFER DIVERSION
SHE MUST FIRST CONDUCT IN
ELIGIBILITY EVALUATION INCLUDES
AN ASSESSMENT OF PUBLIC SAFETY.
BASED ON THE FACTS OF THE CASE
AND THE PERSON'S CRIMINAL
RECORD IF ANY THIS DECISION
MUST BE. QUOTE GROUNDED IN
REASON JUDGMENT AND GUIDED BY
LEGAL PRINCIPLES AND POLICIES
APPROPRIATE TO THE PARTICULAR
MATTER AT ISSUE AND QUOTE. ANY
REPORTER FEARS OF NEW STATUTES
BEING USED RECKLESS CLEAR BASS
PLAYER. CALIFORNIA JUDGES ARE
AS CONCERNED WITH PUBLIC SAFETY
IS ANYONE AND ALSO TEND TO FEAR
THAT SOMEONE THEY TREATED
LENIENTLY MIGHT RE OFFENSE EVEN
GIVEN WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT THE
LITERATURE- WHEN A PERSON IS
FOUND ELIGIBLE FOR DIVERSION.
INCLUDING IN THE WHITE CASES
THEY'RE TYPICALLY REQUIRED TO
UNDERGO SUBSTANTIAL PROGRAMMING
FAR BEYOND WHAT MIGHT BE
REQUIRED OF THEM EVEN IF THEY
WERE CONVICTED OF THE OFFENSE
THEY'RE CHARGED WITH- GRANNY
CAN LAST TO TWO. AND IF A
PERSON FAILED TO COMPLETE ANY
PROGRAM REQUIREMENTS CRIMINAL
PROCEEDINGS RESUME. IN ONE
EXAMPLE A PUBLIC DEFENDER
CLIENTS CHARGED WITH DRIVING
UNDER THE INFLUENCE WAS GRANTED
DIVERSION ON A NUMBER OF
CONDITIONS INCLUDING THAT HE
REMAINING IN HIS SOBER LIVING
ENVIRONMENT FOR TWO YEARS AND
CONTINUE. DALY ALCOHOLICS
ANONYMOUS MEETINGS. A GUILTY
PLEA OR CONVICTION. AFTER
TRIAL. TO THE CHARGE WOULD HAVE
RESULTED IN NONE OF THOSE
CONDITIONS JUST THE DIY
MANDATED- PROGRAM. CREDIT SCORE
ANY TIME SERVED IN JAIL- AND
COURT PROBATION- SO HERE
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAM REMAINS
IN PLACE ENHANCING PUBLIC
SAFETY FAR MORE THAN THE
ALTERNATIVE AND THIS IS WHY THE
STUDIES THAT SUPPORT. A NO VOTE
SHOW THIS TIME AND TIME AGAIN-
IN ANOTHER POINT OKAY THIS IS A
PART OF A YOUR AT YOUR FIVE
MINUTE MARK COULD YOU WRAP IT
UP. SURE I'LL I'LL JUST NOTE
THAT. IN IN PASSING AB THIRTY
TWO THIRTY FOUR CALIFORNIA
VOTERS REPUDIATED EARLIER
POLICY THAT LED TO MASS
INCARCERATION INCLUDING ALL THE
RACIAL DISPARITIES. THAT
INTENDED DECIDING THAT MANY
MISDEMEANORS INCLUDING D. WHY
SHOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR
DIVERSION PROGRAMS THAT
ACTUALLY HELP KEEP OUR
COMMUNITY SAFE AB TWENTY TWO.
IN THE RETURN TO THE FAILED
POLICIES. THAT HARM CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES AND THEIR COMMUNITIES
CLICK DECADES AND WE URGE A NO
VOTE THANK YOU FOR THE TIME.
THANK YOU. NOW FOR ANY
WITNESSES IN FORTY TWO OH TO.
SEE IN NONE OTHER ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. AND IN
EIGHTEEN ANTI COULD YOU GO TO
THE PHONE LINES FOR ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO AB.
TWO EIGHT TWO. SURE IF YOU WISH
TO OPPOSE AB Q. EIGHT Q. PRESS
THE ONE THAN THEIR OWN NOW
AGAIN TO OPPOSE OF AB TWO EIGHT
TWO. TO ONE THEN THERE ARE NOW.
NOW LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE ABOUT
TWO IN THE QUEUE. WILL START
WHAT LINE AB ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS MARCO GEORGE AND
I AM HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION. RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MAXIM OF CAROLINE FOUR TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES COULD
NOT ZERO HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL. THANK YOU.
AND AT THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE TO MAKE YOU. BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND THIS
WORKS AS A QUESTION THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MISTER LUCKY I
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THE
BILL FORWARD- AND I DON'T AND I
DON'T DOUBT YOUR EXPERIENCE AND
WHAT YOU'VE WITNESSED OVER THE
COURSE OF YOUR CAREER- BUT
FUNDAMENTALLY I BELIEVE IN
JUDICIAL DISCRETION- I WANT TO
GIVE JUDGES THE FLEXIBILITY TO
ENSURE THAT THEY ARE TAKING
INTO ACCOUNT. THE FULL CONTEXT
OF THE TOTALITY OF THE
EXPERIENCE OF WHAT HAPPENED TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUNISHMENT YOU
KNOW IF IT'S A CRIME SORT OF
SPEAK SO AYE IN FIRST WE WILL
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY
BUT I JUST WANTED TO LET YOU
KNOW WHY. IF YES MR BURKE FOR
THE REASONS GIVEN BY THE ACLU-
I ALSO WON'T BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU I JUST WANT TO REMIND
EVERYBODY THAT. THE GOVERNOR WE
HAVE IS NOT NECESSARILY A- LOCK
THEM UP AND THROW AWAY THE KEY.
KIND OF INDIVIDUAL I THINK WE
ALL UNDERSTAND THAT HE- ALSO
UNDERSTANDS THE UNIQUE NATURE
OF THIS PARTICULAR CRIME. AND
AGAIN THE MOTIVATION IS NOT
PUNISHMENT BUT THERE ARE SOME
TO THERE ARE SOME.
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT LEAD TO
DRIVING UNDER THE INFLUENCE IS
THAT NEED THE KIND OF
INTERVENTION THAT ONLY
CONVICTIONS WILL BRING. AND I
JUST I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT
ALLOWING THE WISE TO GO
UNPUNISHED. WILL CONTINUE TO
ENABLE IRRESPONSIBLE BEHAVIOR
PUT. INNOCENT LIVES IN DANGER
AND SOME OF THESE FOLKS WILL
KILL AYE ASPIRIN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU- CHAIRS RECOMMENDED
UNABLE CALL THE ROLL. AB TWO
EIGHTY TO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER I LACKEY LACKEY I PARA
QUE HAN MARCADO AND I WORK.
CORK KNELT SANTIAGO C. R. TWO
I'D SAY ARE TOP FIVE WICKES
WICKES NOW LEE NOW LEAN NOW.
THE MEASURES ARE CALLED NEEDS
ONE MORE THANK YOU. NOW YOUR
NEXT ONE. IN THE LAST ONE- A.
B. SIX AS A FAILURE TO BE ON
THE LAST PHONE FOLKS WITH.
PROUD TO BE THAT THE PRESENTER
HERE AND WILL BE BRIEF BUT ALSO
BE. GIVEN ITS FAIR DO I THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT THIS BILL THE NUMBER
SIX SIX NINE AND IT WOULD ALLOW
COUNTY PROBATION DEPARTMENTS TO
CONTINUE TO USE NON ROSTER
FIREARMS UPON SUCCESSFUL
COMPLETION OF THE FIREARMS
PORTION OF THE COMMISSION ON
PEACE OFFICER STANDARDS AND
TRAINING. THE TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN THE LEGISLATURE
AUTHORIZED COUNTY PROBATION
DEPARTMENT'S OFFICERS TO
PURCHASE. AND UTILIZE NON
ROSTER FIREARMS LAST YEAR
HOWEVER THE LEGISLATURE ADDED
REQUIREMENT FOR COMPLETION OF
THE POST BASIC COURSE QUOTE ON
QUOTE. BEFORE ALLOWING. THESE
PROBATION OFFICERS. TO PURCHASE
AND USE NON ROSTER FIREARMS.
THIS INVERSELY AFFECTED
PROBATION OFFICERS WHO ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO COMPLETE THE POST
BASIC COURSES A CONDITION OF
THEIR HIGHER CONTINUE
DEPLOYMENT. BECAUSE OF THIS
LANGUAGE PROBATION OFFICERS ARE
PROHIBITED FROM USING NON
ROSTER FIREARMS ON DUTY BECAUSE
OF THE POST BASIC COURSE
REQUIREMENTS ONLY. IT WOULD
ALSO FORCE PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS TO PURCHASE NEW
FIREARMS ANY TIME A DEPARTMENT
ISSUED ROSTERED FIRE ARM FALLS
OFF THE LIST AND BECOMES A NON
ROSTER FIREARM. THE
CLARIFICATION OF THIS BILL
PROVIDES. WILL ALLOW THE
CONFIRMATION DEPARTMENTS TO
MAINTAIN THE USE OF FIREARMS
THAT HAVE BEEN PURCHASED AND
USED BY THOSE DEPARTMENTS FOR
WHICH ITS PROBATION OFFICERS
HAVE FULLY BEEN TRAINED.
WITHOUT THIS BILL THESE
DEPARTMENTS WILL REQUIRED TO
PURCHASE NEW WEAPONS FOR
AFFECTED OFFICERS. SB SIX SIX
NINE WOULD ALSO. FUEL THREE
WOULD EXEMPT SALES TO COUNTY
PROBATION DEPARTMENT AND
OFFICERS WHO HAVE COMPLETED THE
FIREARMS PORTION OF THE
TRAINING COURSE SET. FORTH BY
POST AND THEY MUST COMPLETE A
LIVE FIRE QUALIFICATION
PRESCRIBED BY THEIR EMPLOYING
ENTITY AT LEAST ONCE EVERY SIX
MONTHS. AND WE ALSO HAVE HERE
TO TESTIFY TO THIS BILL OVER TO
RECALL I'M SURE HE'S- STILL
HERE. THANK YOU ROOM MISTER
CHAIRMAN MAC YES WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY MR I HAVE NOTHING
BUT PATIENT SIR. OKAY YOU
UNDERSTAND IS A FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THIS PROCESS
GOOD EVENING COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR ALLOWING ME TO TESTIFY.
THIS MEASUREMENT THANK FOR
KAREN LEGISLATION I ALSO
APPRECIATE YOUR STAFF'S EFFORTS
ON THIS AS WELL AS THE
COMMITTEE STAFFS. OBERNOLTE
COMING UP WITH A COLLISION
PROVISIONAL INNOVATIONS
REPRESENTING NEARLY TEN
THOUSAND RECONCILE PROBATION
OFFICERS IT'S ONE OF SUPPLEMENT
SOME OF TOUCH SOME OF THE
COMMENTS FROM MR LACKEY. FIRST
AND FOREMOST. AS A RESULT OF.
THE REALIGNMENT OF PUBLIC
SAFETY OF THE LAST TEN YEARS.
VIRTUALLY EVERYONE THAT LEAVES
A STATE PRISON OR LOCAL COUNTY
JAIL. IS ENTRUSTED TO THE
CUSTODY OF OPERATION OFFICER TO
SUPERVISE TO BE ABLE TO TAKE IT
TO FACILITATE THE REENTRY.
OVERWHELMINGLY MOST OF OUR
OFFICERS DON'T CARRY WEAPONS SO
THAT THIS IS A VERY SMALL
SUBSECTION THE PROBATION
OFFICER PROSTATE. WE CARE WE
DID TWENTY ONE SIXTY FIVE IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN. DECEMBER BONTA
CARRY THE BILL. IN RESPONSE TO
THIS NEW POPULATION BECAUSE NOT
ONLY DO WE HAVE A MORE THEY
JUST POPULATION BUT WE'RE ALSO
PROVISIONS ARE ALSO PART OF
REGIONAL TASK FORCES THAT
INVOLVE. GANG INTERVENTION DRUG
INTERDICTION WITH LOCAL
AGENCIES. THERE THEY REQUIRE
THE THESE OFFICERS ALL TO HAVE
THE TRAINING AND USE THE SAME
WEAPON. WITHOUT THIS WE ARE
VERY MUCH IMPEDE IN THAT IN
THAT EFFORT THAT'S WHAT THAT'S
THE THAT'S THE REASON WE DID
THAT IN THE FIRST PLACE. TWENTY
SIX NINETY NINE. WHICH WAS
PASSED LAST BY MR SANTIAGO MY
UNDERSTANDING FROM THE SPONSORS
WELL IT WAS NOT ABOUT. THE
TRAINING THE BILL WAS ABOUT
EXPANDING. THE NUMBER OF
OFFICERS THE CANOES NOT NOT TO
FARMS AND IN PART OF THOSE
NEGOTIATIONS. DID THIS THIS
POST TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH PUTS
PUT INTO THE BILL AT THE END OF
SESSION. UNFORTUNATELY THAT
POSTING REQUIREMENT IS THAT THE
SAME REQUIREMENT FOR PROBATION
OFFICERS AS MISTER LIKE YOU
SAID. I WANT TO TURN IT OVER
NOW TO MR GREG THROWS ON THE
LINE WHO CAN WHO CAN SUMMARIZE
THE TRAINING REQUIRED
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN. BETWEEN
POST AND PROBATION OFFICERS.
BUT I DON'T HAVE SAYS THE LEFT
WITH THE MOST LIKELY MADE.
POLICE OFFICERS WILL GO TO THE-
TRAINING WILL CALL TO FIND THAT
IN THIS BILL. THEY WILL HAVE
MORE TRAINING- ACTUALLY AS AN
ONGOING BASIS. THEN THE
RACQUETBALL COPSON AND- DEPUTY
SHERIFFS. BECAUSE WE'RE GONNA
REQUIRED TO DRAFTING OR ITS IS
TWICE IT'S ACTUALLY FOUR TIMES.
EVERY QUARTER THE POLICE
OFFICERS WHO HAVE TO GO
THROUGH. TO THE TRAINING TO USE
A GUN. COPSON W. SEVERAL I DO A
ONCE A YEAR SO IN FACT WE HAVE
MORE TRAINING. AND LESS SO WITH
WITHOUT FURTHER DO I RESPECT US
FOR NO ONE AND I LIKE TO. ALLOW
MR. STOBER TO TESTIFY WAS ON
THE LINE THANK YOU. THIS
STEWART ARE YOU READY. YET I AM
SIR WHENEVER YOU'RE READY ALL
RIGHT MISTER CHAIR. OKAY MISTER
CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK MY NAME IS GREG STEWART
ON THE LEGISLATIVE VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE STATE
COALITION INFORMATION
ORGANIZATIONS AND THE PRESIDENT
SEGMENT COUNTY PROBATION
ASSOCIATION. HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SIX SIX NINE. IN
ADDITION ALL OF MR TRICO
STATEMENTS AND LIKE TO ADDRESS
ONE OF THE MAIN CONCERNS OF THE
OPPOSITION THE OPPOSITION
STATED A PROBATION OFFICER DOES
NOT COMPLETE POST BASIC COURSE.
CANNOT BE SAFE WITH GUNS.
RESPECTFULLY THE STATEMENT IS
NOT CORRECT IN THE CERTAINLY
NOT BASED UPON FACTS. FOR THE
POST BASIC CORE STANDARD
FORMAT. THE POST BASIC COURSES
COMPRISES SIX HUNDRED SIXTY
FOUR HOURS OF TRAINING. BROKEN
INTO FORTY THREE LEARNING
DOMAINS. ONLY A SINGLE DOMAIN
ONE DOMAIN WHICH IS DOMAIN
THIRTY FIVE COVERS FIREARMS IN
CARRY AND CHEMICAL AGENTS. THIS
IT TAKES UP TO SEVENTY TWO
HOURS ONLY IT IS THE ONLY
DOMAIN THAT PROVIDES FIREARMS
TRAINING. IT IS IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT SEVENTY TWO HOURS
PROVIDING DOMAIN THIRTY FIVE
INCLUDES A FIREARMS PORTION OF
EIGHT THIRTY TO TRAINING. TO
INFORMATION OFFICERS ALREADY
MANDATED TO COMPLETE. ALSO AS
MR TRICKLE MENTIONED UNDER PC
EIGHT THIRTY POINT FIVE
PROBATION OFFICERS ARE REQUIRED
TO QUALIFY QUARTERLY WITH A
FIREARM WHICH IS TWICE THE
AMOUNT OF OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT.
ACTIVE PROBATION OFFICERS
RECEIVE MORE FIREARMS TRAINING
AND OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS ENFORCING PROBATION
OFFICERS TO COMPLETE FIVE
HUNDRED NINETY TWO HOURS OF
COMPLETELY UNRELATED POST BASIC
COURSE TRAINING. HAS NOTHING TO
DO WITH FIRE AND SAFETY.
SACRAMENTO COUNTY OUR OFFICERS
MUST COMPLETE AN EIGHTY HOUR
FIREARMS COURSE WHICH INCLUDES
POST EIGHT THIRTY TWO TRAINING.
BEFORE EVEN ENTER OUR FTO
PROGRAM ARMED OFFICERS MUST
QUALIFY QUARTERLY WITH A
FIREARM AND MUST COMPLETE
ADVANCED OFFICER TRAINING
ANNUALLY. POLICE OFFICERS ARE
QUALIFIED AND PROPERLY TRAINED
AND WE'VE BEEN USING THESE
FARMS FOR YEARS. FOR THESE
REASONS RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
YES VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
SO ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON THE
TELEPHONE CONFERENCE NINE. AT&T
ARE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON
THE PHONE. MAYBE EVEN GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR
A BI SIX SIX NINE PRESS ONE
THEN THERE- NOW AGAIN TO SHOW
SUPPORT OF AB. SIX SIX NINE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO NOW. WE
HAVE ABOUT YOU AND MAKE YOU
LOCAL TRYING TO ONE THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE ONE
THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOU MIGHT BE NEEDED THE-
MAXIMUM. HELLO MAXIMAL TO LINE
FOR TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS DANIEL SANCHEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICERS OF CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MATT THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE IN THE QUEUE. THANK YOU.
IN NOW- WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
I'M LOOKING UP TO NAY REBEKAH
MARCUS BRADY UNITED ON THE
PHONE. YES GOOD EVENING SHARON
MEMBERS TOBACCO MARKETS
REPRESENTING BRADY AND BRADY
CALIFORNIA CLOSE TO EIGHTY SIX
SIX NINE WHICH UNNECESSARILY
EXPANDS EXEMPTIONS COULD BE
UNSAFE HANDGUNS ACTOR YOU HA
THERE'S NO REASONABLE NEED TO
ALLOW PROBATION OFFICERS TO THE
FAST AND SAFE HANDGUNS WITHOUT
COMPLETION OF THE ENTIRE CUTS
BASIC COURSE. THE POTENTIAL
IMPLICATIONS ARE HARMFUL FIRST
BROUGHT UP BY THE SPONSORS THIS
BILL IS NOT A CLEAN OUT MEASURE
THE CHANGES MADE LAST YEAR WERE
INTENTIONAL AB SIX SIX NINE AND
THAT'S IMPORTANT SAFEGUARDS WE
ASK A FAMILY MEMBER SANTIAGO TO
INCLUDE IN HIS AB TWENTY SIX
NINETY NINE. ADDITIONALLY THE
PROVISIONS ADDED BY AB TWO SIX
NINE NINE OUR PERSPECTIVE IN
NATURE SO A LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER WHO COMPLETED THE BASIC
FIREARMS COURSE PRIOR TO
JANUARY FIRST OF THIS YEAR IS
NOT REQUIRED TO TAKE THE FULL
POST COURSE IF THEY NEED TO
REPLACE. THEIR OFFER AFTER A
FIRE ON. FEDERAL LAW DOES NOT
IMPOSE FACE STAND UNDER.
MANUFACTURED FIREARMS TO THE
CONTRARY EXAMPLE FIREARMS
YOU'RE NEEDING EVEN MINIMAL
STANDARDS. EFFECTIVELY CREATES
A PROTECTED MARKET FOR JUNK
BONDS THAT OFTEN JAM MISFIRE OR
MALFUNCTION DUE TO POOR
CONSTRUCTION OR DESIGN. IN THE
LAST FIFTY YEARS MORE AMERICANS
HAVE DIED IN UNINTENTIONAL
SHOOTINGS ON AN AMERICAN WARS.
IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE
CALIFORNIA FILL GAPS AND
FEDERAL PRODUCTS THANK YOU LAWS
FINANCING THE RIGHT CHECK. THE
U. H. A. REQUIRES THAT ALL
NEWLY DEVELOPED HANDGUN MODELS
MEET BASIC RELIABILITY AND
SAFETY STANDARDS. IN ORDER TO
BE PLACED ON ROSTER BY THE
COUNTY OBJECT. CURRENTLY THERE
ARE OVER EIGHT HUNDRED GUNS ON
ROSTER AND AVAILABLE FOR SALE
CALIFORNIA. THE STANDARDS
MANDATED FOR A FIREARM TO BE ON
A ROSTER ARE FEASIBLE
AFFORDABLE AND NECESSARY. B. O.
H. A. AND OTHER REGULATIONS
HAVE KEPT THE STATE'S RATE OF
UNINTENTIONAL FIREARM DEATHS.
PER ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND FAR
BELOW THE RATE AND THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY. LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS WHO HAVE COMPLETED THE
ENTIRE BASIC COAST COURSE. HAVE
LONG BEEN AN EXACT FROM THE
RESTRICTIONS IN THE U. HA
HOWEVER IN RECENT YEARS THE
LIST OF EXEMPT AGENCIES HAS
GROWN WITHOUT ANY MANDATE FOR
SUCH TRAINING. LAST YEAR AB TWO
SIX NINE NINE CLOSE THIS
LOOPHOLE BY EXPLICITLY
MANDATING FULL POST TRAINING
FOR ALL LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER
TO SPEAK TO PURCHASE OFF FASTER
GOT. AB SIX SIX NINE WOULD
REINSTATE THE LOOPHOLE BY
CARVING OUT AN EXEMPTION FROM
THE RIGHT J. BURKE COUNTY
PROBATION OFFICERS. ALLOWING
THEM TO COMPLETE ONLY THE
FIREARMS PORTION OF COACH
TRAINING. NOTABLY COUNTY
PROBATION OFFICERS ARE NOT
SEEKING THIS CAR ABOUT BECAUSE
WE NEED TO CARRY OFF ROSTER
DONE. OR OR ARE UNABLE TO
COMPLETE FULL POST TRAINING AND
STABBED BAY SIMPLY PREFER
MODELS OF HANDGUNS THAT ARE NOT
ONE OF THE HUNDREDS OF ON
ROSTER MODEL PREVAIL BALL. AND
ALSO PREFER NOT TO UNDERGO FULL
POST TRAINING. EIGHTY SIX SIX
NINE. WHAT LIKELY INTERACT MORE
AND SAFE HAND GUNS AND TO THE
STATE IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS COMPLETE
THE ENTIRE PRO TRAINING TO
FULLY UNDERSTAND. HOW TO HANDLE
DANGEROUS. FIREARMS THERE BEEN
MANY INSTANCES AS OF WELL
TRAINED OFF THE- ON. FIRING
SERVICE WEAPONS. BY ALLO MORE
ON. TO HAVE ACT TO AND THEY
CAN'T BECAUSE OF THE PART. NOT
TO USE ON ROSTER GUNS YES
MEASURE LIKELY. LEAD TO MORE.
DANGEROUS WEAPON AND OF THOSE
WHO SHOULD NOT HAVE THAT.
CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
FOUND GUILTY OF TRAFFICKING
CONTRACTOR HAND GUNS TO
CIVILIANS. EIGHTY SIX SIX NINE
WALKS BACK IMPORTANT SAFEGUARDS
THAT WERE PASSED LAST YEAR. FOR
ALL THOSE REASONS STATED BRADY
AND BRADY CALIFORNIA ASKS FOR
YOUR NO VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. I DO. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN THE ROOM. IN OPPOSITION ANY
OTHER WITNESSES ON A
TELECONFERENCE IN OPPOSITION
AND ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES. AT&T ON THE LINE IN
OPPOSITION. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE
OF AB SIX SIX NINE PRESS ONE
THAN THEIR OWN NOW AGAIN TO
OPPOSE OF. EIGHTY SIX SIX NINE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW. IT
LOOKS LIKE WE DO HAVE ONE IN
THE QUEUE WILL GO TO LINE ONE
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CHEN MEMBERS TRYING TO MOLD
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S LOCATION WE
REPRESENT THAT PROBATION
OFFICERS ARE COUNTY AND- WE ARE
IN SUPPORT. OF THIS BILL- I
WOULD NEVER GET THROUGH EARLIER
THANK YOU. RIGHT THANK YOU.
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE MCHALE
OKAY BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS- I PLEASE. FOR
THE REBEKAH BART K. HAS- AND I
DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS A
QUESTION FOR YOU MISTER WALKER
YOU MISTER TRIGO BUT I GUESS
I'M JUST TO THE POINT OF THE
OPPOSITION I DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHY THIS THEY NEED TO CARRY
THESE OFF ROSTER WEAPONS CAN
ONE OF YOU EXPLAIN THAT TO ME
MISTER TRICKLE FIVE YOUR BEST
PERSON THAT I HAVE AN IDEA BUT
I THINK YOU'LL BE ABLE. TO
EXPLAIN IT BETTER. WELL LOOK.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
SEVEN MEMBER- I GUESS. FIRST
AND FOREMOST I WOULD SAY THIS
ISN'T A QUESTION OF PREFERENCE.
AND AS I MENTIONED EARLIER IN
MANY INSTANCES PUBLISHED
OFFICERS. ARE PART OF. REGIONAL
TASK FORCES. GANGS DRUGS
ETCETERA. SOMETIMES FEDERAL
MARSHALS. IN ORDER TO PRESERVE
THE INTEGRITY OF THAT UNIT ALL
THE OFFICERS ARE REQUIRED TO
CARRY THE SAME GUN SO IF THE IF
THE OTHER OFFICERS TEMPERATURES
MAKE FOR COPS IF THEY'RE
CARRYING ON MOST FARMS THE
PROBATION OFFICERS REQUIRED TO
CARRY THE SAME WEAPON SO THAT'S
NOT A QUESTION OF PREFERENCE
THE OTHER ISSUE THAT WAS RAISED
IN TERMS OF WHAT WE WANT OR
NOT. THE TRAINING FOR PARADE
FOR RENTAL COPS IS COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT FROM PROBATION
OFFICERS AND I THINK EVERYONE
HERE WITH KNOWLEDGE THE
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT JOBS RIGHT
THERE THERE ARE OVERLAPPING
DUTIES YES CERTAINLY BUT
PROVISIONAL ANSWERS THEY DON'T
GO THROUGH POST BUT THE BUT WE
ARE WILLING TO CODIFY AND THE
IN THE BILL THAT CODIFIES THE
HEAD THE FIREARM PORTION OF
POST WHICH MAKES SENSE BUT WHAT
TIME OF DAY TO SITUATION SO
THERE'S NOT A PREFERENCE BUT BY
CHOICE JUST BUT THE REALITY OF
THE JOB. SO YOU KNOW THE RESULT
OF THIS JUST IT'S A TOUGH
SITUATION I UNDERSTAND BUT YOU
KNOW AT AT. I DON'T. ACCORDING
TO SPONSORS. THE WAS NEVER
INTENT. TO SET UP. YOU CAN HAVE
KNOWN AS FARMS THOSE THAT NEVER
THE INTENT OF THE BILL THAT WAS
THAT WAS AN OVERSIGHT. WE'RE
TRYING TO FIX THAT NOW WE CAN
QUIBBLE ABOUT WELL THIS IS
CLEAN UP OR NOT. IT'S A
RELEVANT. BUT THE INTENT OF THE
RISK OF THE SUBTITLES NOT TO
REMOVE REYES OFFICERS NEVER
DELIVER THE INTERN WILL TRY TO
FIX THAT. THANK YOU. IF YOU.
DID YOU HAVE QUESTIONS.
SECRETARY OF- WHY DON'T MISS
WEEKES MAY COME BACK WE DO HAVE
A CLOSING. YEAH WHAT DR- I IT
JUST FOR THIS KIND OF HISTORY
LESSON FOR BOB HELLO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- I'VE- WHICH WHICH IS
HERE SHE MAY HAVE A QUESTION-
HELLO- YOU KNOW LIKE THOSE JUST
LIKE ON SORRY THERE WE GO GOING
TO PULL TOGETHER HERE TEAM OKAY.
YOU KNOW MY CONCERN ABOUT THE
BILL I APPRECIATE YOUR
THOUGHTFULNESS AS ALWAYS MR
LACKEY- I DO VOTE FOR SOME OF
YOUR BILLS I PROMISE. BUT MY
CONCERN ABOUT THE BILL AS A
SORT OF ONGOING EXEMPTIONS TO
ALLOW AGENCIES TO. TO USE GUNS
FROM THE PURCHASED GUNS FROM
THE UNSAFE GUN LIST- AND EVERY
EXEMPTION YIELDS ANOTHER
EXEMPTION WHICH SHIELDS AN
EXEMPTION AND SOME THE WHAT'S
THE SORT OF THE POINT OF EVEN
HAVING LESS SO. WITH THAT I
JUST DON'T THINK IT'S FOR THE
BILL TODAY SO I WANTED TO
EXPLAIN THAT. OKAY OKAY. SO FOR
THIS JUST FOR HISTORY LESSON
FOR MANY SINCE SINCE I'VE BEEN
HERE- I'VE BEEN DOING PIECEMEAL
TRYING TO GET. PROPER WEAPONS
IN FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT TO DEAL
WITH POSSIBLE FIREPOWER THAT
COMES BACK AT THEM THE BABIES.
AND LOT OF TIMES SUPERIOR WATER
WITH A HALF AND- WE SHOULD HAVE
DONE ONE BILL. TO INCORPORATE
ALL OF LAW ENFORCEMENT IN THAT
AND WE COULDN'T WE HAVE TO
PIECEMEAL I'M A YOU KNOW YOU
WHEN YEARS FISHING GAME NEXT
YEAR IT'S A BOOK YEAH NO
EXPOSITION POLICE NATURE IT'S
THE SECURITY GUARDS AT
DISNEYLAND IRATE YOU JUST. IT
JUST GOT A WHOLE IT JUST GOT
OUT OF THE FINAL US. IT JUST
GOT OUT IT IT JUST KEPT GOING
ON AND ON AVERAGE BUT AND I
REALIZE THAT WITH THAT MANY LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS WHO
ACTUALLY HAVE. TO DEAL WITH IN
SOME DEBRIS DANGEROUS
SITUATIONS- AND- AND I CAN DO
IT WHETHER TO USC OR EVEN MY
EXPOSITION POLICE OVER AN
EXHIBITION PARK. WHERE NOT ONLY
WITH ELECTRIC SCUM. THEY WILL
HAVE THE WORLD CUP. AND WE'VE
GOT TO HAVE THE BEST TRAINED
SECURITY. IN THE PARK THAT WERE
MY OFFICES AND- I WISH WE COULD
HAVE. BUNDLED THE BALL IN IT
ONE TIME BUT WE COULDN'T AND SO
I. THE REASON I'M SUPPORTING IT
BECAUSE THIS IS JUST A
CONTINUATION AND I
UNFORTUNATELY- REACTED TO A
PIECEMEAL ONE BY ONE UNTIL WE
GET AS MANY. GROUPS IN AS
POSSIBLE THAT THAT NEEDS.
WHATEVER THEY NEED TO BE ABLE
TO- NOW DEPENDING SALES BUT TO
PROTECT PEOPLE A DIFFERENT
PARTS OF THE STATE SO- JUDGE
RECOMMENDED I. THANK YOU HAVE A
MOTION. OKAY I'LL MAKE A MOTION.
MISTER MISTER CLARK MADE IT YOU
DID AT THE VERY FIRST. SORRY I
COULDN'T HEAR AT ALL THE TIME
HE DID I'M SORRY FOR SPOKE EVEN.
OKAY DO YOU NEED A SECOND. I
CAN SECOND. CALDERON. EIGHT AB
SIX SIX NINE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS JONES SAWYER GENSER ATTY
LACKEY LACKEY AND A BARRICADE
CAN THERE CAN I A QUIRK HI CORK
ICE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I SAY ARE
TOO HIGH THEY ARE TELL I WITH
YOU WICKS NO. LINO. THAT
MEASURE. MEASURE PASSES. YEAH
W. WE HAVE A ADD ON SO. AN ON
CALL THANK YOU. MISS YOU NEVER
LEFT. I DON'T REMEMBER. ONE
ITEM NUMBER ONE EIGHTY SIX
HUNDRED ARAMBULA AT THIS ITEM
HAS BEEN DISPENSED WITH THAT
PASSED. ITEM NUMBER TWO THIS
MEASURE WAS ON CALL AB SEVEN
SEVEN NINE. BAUER CAN BARRICADE
HAD AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
WICKS. WICKS NOT VOTING THAT
MEASURE GETS OUT. ITEM NUMBER
THREE EIGHTY NINE THREE SEVEN
BY SOME MEMBER CARILLO THIS
MEASURE WAS ALSO ON CALL OUR
CAN. BARRICADE HAD NOT VOTING
WICKS. YES MA'AM WICKS I THAT
MEASURE PASSES. ITEM NUMBER
FOUR AB ONE THOUSAND SEVEN WITH
ON CONSENT. I DON'T NUMBER FIVE.
EIGHTY THREE THIRTY EIGHT THAT
MOTION THAT MEASURE FAILED. ON
AB TWO SIX EIGHT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IRWIN SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO
I THAT MEASURE PASSED. I ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN WITHOUT CONSENT I
DON'T NUMBER EIGHT THIS WAS
PULLED BY COMMITTEE. ITEM
NUMBER NINE EIGHTY SIX BY FIVE
BY FAMILY MEMBER KALRA SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WICKS WICKS I THAT
MEASURE PASSES. ITEM NUMBER TEN
THIS MEASURE WAS ALSO ON CALL
AB THREE THREE THREE BY SENATOR
COM LONGER LACKEY. LACKING NOW
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO ADDED WICKS
WICKS HI THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM TWO EIGHTY TWO BY A FAMILY
MEMBER LACKEY SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO HI THAT MEASURE WITH
ON CALL IT PASSIVE. WITH THE
AMENDMENTS YES SIR THE EIGHTY
SIX SIX NINE WAS JUST DISPENSED
WITH I DON'T NUMBER THIRTEEN
NINE NINE EIGHT WITHOUT CONSENT
I DON'T FOURTEEN EIGHT NINETY
EIGHT WITH ON CONSENT ITEM
NUMBER FIFTEEN BY SOMEBODY
EIGHTY TWO TWELVE TWENTY THREE
BY FAMILY MEMBER LEVINE
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I DON'T
NUMBER SIXTEEN WAS PULLED BY
THE AUTHOR ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN WITH ON CONSENT ITEM
NUMBER EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE
EIGHTY TWO BY SOME REMEMBER
PATTERSON WICKS WICKS HI THAT
MEASURE PASSES ITEM NUMBER
NINETEEN WITHOUT A CONSENT ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY. EIGHTY SIX FOUR
FOUR BY SOME MEMBER WALDRON
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO AYE THAT
MEASURE PASSES ITEM TWENTY ONE
WITHOUT CONSENT ITEM TWENTY TWO
THIS MEASURE WAS ALSO ON CALL
AB THREE ELEVEN BY A FAMILY
MEMBER AWARDS SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
I THAT MEASURE PASSES. THANK
YOU EVERYBODY FOR THE- FOR
PUBLIC SAFETY COULD COMMITTEE
RENDON AT SEVEN FIFTEEN. THIS
MEETING IS ADJOURNED.